[Musique]
Ran Branco, bonsoir. Bonsoir. Nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ? 35 ans,
avocat, docteur en droit, écrivain. J'ai
publié un certain nombre d'ouvrages.
J'ai eu la chance de gagner quelques
procès contre Emmanuel Macron, Brigitte
Macron, Didier allemand, Gérald Armanin
en représentant et c'était mon honneur
des des citoyens français qui étaient
attaqués pénalement par ces gens-là.
Donc, les gens les plus puissants du
pays qui s'attaquaient à des gens
extraordinairement fragiles parce qu'ils
avaient posté ici une caricature, parce
qu'ils avaient eu un mot déplacé.
et j'ai passé ces dernières années à
essayer de défendre et de protéger ces
personnes-là et avec les gilets jaunes
notamment à tenter de constituer un
projet politique qui fasse que que ce
soit à travers la voie électorale ou à
travers la révolution, on puisse enfin
sauver ce pays des abîmes dans lesquels
il est aujourd'hui plongé. Et c'est
notre enjeu aujourd'hui et notre
objectif. On est quand même dans un pays
où euh euh des gens s'arrachent les
dents à la pince parce qu'ils arrivent
pas à avoir de
rendez-vous avec des dentistes qui
meurent parce que après avoir eu des
accidents cardiaques, ils ne peuvent pas
avoir des rendez-vous avec des
cardiologues pendant des mois.
un pays où dans le même temps euh
gynécologie, dermatologie, idem toutes
les spécialités euh où on meurt aux
urgences et où dans le même temps comme
ça a été révélé récemment, le canard
enchaîné par le canard enchaîné des
patrons de mutuel roulent en Porsche
Cayenne qui sont des voitures de
fonction. Euh donc on est dans une
situation où en fait ce pays est devenu
un pays d'escroc où la vérité n'a plus
aucune valeur, où l'honneur est est
complètement mis à ou mais il y a pas
que des escrocs, c'est dominé par les
escrocs justement. C'estàd qu'on est
dans un pays où euh où où des millions
de personnes honnêtes et intègres
triment et travaillent pour produire des
ressources qui sont
captées par des castes, par des euh
petites corporations et euh et qui
génère à partir de là des modes de vie
mais aussi une emprise sur les
institutions pour se protéger. Et c'est
là où il y a il y a la corruption et il
y a ensuite la lâcheté, la quardise, la
compromission de la part d'un certain
nombre d'institutions au sein de la
justice, au sein de la police qui
protège ces entités, qui protègent ces
individus et qui font que ce pays est
devenu invivable. Faire justice
aujourd'hui dans ce pays, c'est devenu
impossible. Obtenir une décision de
justice sincère, honnête, dans un délai
raisonnable, c'est devenu inconcevable.
La moindre initiative, le moindre la
moindre démarche en justice va vous
coûter 2000 3000 € d'entrée pour trouver
un avocat qui va essayer de de vous
défendre et qui ensuite va être
impuissant à obtenir une décision en
moins d'un an, 2 ans, 3 ans, parfois 5
ans. Donc dans le même temps,
paradoxalement, il n'y a jamais eu
autant de personnes en prison
qu'aujourd'hui en France. Euh c'est très
étrange. On a l'impression qu'il y a une
sorte de
d'insécurité grandissante qui est réelle
et c'est une insécurité grandissante ou
c'est une augmentation des violences ?
C'est une augmentation avant tout. Sous
Macron, tout a augmenté. C'est assez
étonnant qu'on en parle jamais. avant
tout les violences contre les personnes
notamment tout ce qui a trait au vol, ça
c'est un marqueur très important et euh
et une répression qui qui est devenue
fantomatique ou inutile et inefficace.
C'est-à-dire que comme je vous le
disais, on était on avait à peu près
40000 personnes en prison il y a 40 ans
en France. On est à quasiment 100000
personnes sous écrou. Donc ça inclut
ceux qui sont dans des régimes de
semiliberté et pourtant ça ne fonctionne
pas. Ça ne fonctionne pas pour toute une
séde raison. On pourrait revenir dessus
au niveau judiciaire mais même là on
parle du pénal mais même même le conflit
civil c'estàd quand vous faites
escroquer par quelqu'un ou que vous
essayez de récupérer des sommes des
petites choses des personne mais
personne personne ne pense aller à la
justice aujourd'hui parce qu'ils savent
parfaitement que ça va être un chemin de
croix que le résultat est aléatoire que
ça va coûter plus cher souvent que ce
qu'on cherche à récupérer et vous savez
ça peu à pe ça crée une gangraine. CR
une gangraine parce que au sein de la
société, il y a pas que des bonnes
personnes et il y a des personnes qui
vont qui voient cet espace et qui se la
capare. On pourrait
parler de de au niveau économique euh
d'un côté l'Ursaf qui fait n'importe
quoi, qui parfois vous envoie des appels
de cotisation à des petits entrepreneurs
de 30 40000 €
voilà sans aucune conséquence et parfois
il faut se battre pendant 1 an 2 ans
pour récupérer les sommes qui ont été
soit captées par des commissaires de
justice soit
obtenir le
remboursement jamais évidemment de
jamais d'indemnisation et à côté vous ça
présente combien de dossiers ça ? Mais
ça c'est ça c'est au quotidien parce que
c'est des mécanismes qui sont mis en
place qui euh qui sont automatisés qui
sont sur l'anticipation enfin pardon la
projection de vos revenus par rapport au
revenus de l'année précédente. Vous avez
démarg négociation quasiment nulle. Donc
vous retrouvez quand vous avez une année
un peu un peu jolie, un peu agréable,
l'année suivante ça marche moins bien,
ben vous prenez des appels de cotisation
complètement fous. On pourrait rentrer
dans le détailser derrière mais c'est
pas la question, c'est la pression
psychologique, c'est la violence du
moment, c'est l'incertitude, le fait de
devoir être accompagné, la comptabilité
est devenue infernale dans ce pays.
Infernal, c'est créer créer cette
activité de tricide. À côté, vous avez
une une escroquerie institutionnalisée.
Vous regardez les comptes formation, les
CPF, les comptes personnel formation,
c'est des milliards chaque année. Pour
vous donner un exemple, la justice a
récupéré l'année dernière 400 millions
d'euros euh de montants escroqués sur le
CPF. Imaginez-vous quels sont les
montants réels qui passent à l'échelle
avec à à l'esbrouff avec en plus des
dispositifs où on en est arrivé
maintenant où on vous propose des
échanges en cash. C'est tu prends 60,
moi je prends 40 et je te fais une faux
une fausse formation et c'est du coup
tout le monde devient complice à la fois
le bénéficiaire de la formation fantôme
et celui qui l'a construite. Le crédit
impôt recherche, c'est 8 milliards
d'euros par an qui sont utilisés par les
grandes entreprises pour financer des
dépenses courantes qui aurait eu lieu.
De toute façon, vous allez sur les
mutuels des frais de fonctionnement de
25 %. La sécurité sociale, c'est 3 %.
les 20 % ils partent dans les Porsche
Cayen et ainsi de suite. Vous voyez on
pourrait il y a 2 3 % de marg c'est
peut-être 6 si on compte des frais de
salaire qui sont pas complètement
comptabilisés dans la CQ mais c'est à
peu près la même chose. C'est des
milliards chaque année. Je pourrais vous
les CE les pour le pour les pour les
crédits environnement la ma prime rénove
des milliards. Des milliards. Vous savez
que sur ces dispositifs il y a pas de
contrôle a priori de l'État. C'est que
c'est que déclaratif. Alors sur la
déclaration, on vous embête hein et
alors il va falloir être précis mais au
millimètre la moindre erreur et tout de
suite on vous dit c'est pas possible et
cetera mais par contre si vous avez des
gens qui vous aident à la remplir
parfaitement il y a aucun contrôle
factuel aucun contrôle de la réalité de
ce que vous déclarez. Donc voyez, c'est
cette passion de la bureaucratie qui
étouffe complètement la population. Et
après en aval, ce qui est magnifique,
l'État ne contrôle pas et parfois il
délègue par exemple sur sur le CE, il
délègue à des entreprises privées le
contrôle entreprises privées qui parfois
appartiennent au même groupe qui a mis
en place les dispositifs qui sont censés
contrôler. Là encore des milliards et
vous avez la justice qui parfois vient
intervenir très ponctuellement. Donc je
parle même pas de ce qui s'est passé
pendant le Covid.
le FSE, les milliards qui ont disparu à
Dubaï et ainsi de suite avec le fond de
solidarité pour les entreprises ou le
simple fait que l'État a décidé pour
acheter la paix sociale pour les
individus de leur verser jusqu'à 10000 €
par mois. Qui a besoin de 10000 € de
subvention par mois pour soit vous êtes
riche et vous avez gagné de l'argent,
vous en gagnez beaucoup et donc vous en
avez en stock, soit vous n'étiez pas et
vous avez pas besoin d'atteindre ces
niveaux-là. Et là pareil, quasiment
contrôle, aucun contrôle, des dizaines
de milliards d'euros. Et donc à côté,
comme on le disait, c'est-à-dire euh des
euh des euh des services publics qui
s'effondrent complètement, justice,
police, hôpital ou pire qui se
soumettent euh aux intérêts euh privés.
Donc on est dans une situation où c'est
un carnage. Je veux dire, il faut il
faut avoir à l'esprit qu'on si on n'est
pas touché aujourd'hui directement, on
le sera demain d'une façon ou d'une
autre. Et donc ça commence, c'est là où
ça devient intéressant parce que ça
touche à l'ensemble de la population.
C'est plus que les classes les plus
vulnérables qui sont habituées à
supporter cette violence, à être
toujours celles qui sont maltraitées par
le pouvoir en place, ça commence à
s'étendre à la classe moyenne et aux
classes les plus aisées quand il devient
impossible de se loger à Paris alors que
vous êtes professeur ou ainsi de suite à
cause des spéculations immobilières qui
elle-même est le fruit des politiques
monétaires. Comment vous pouvez pas
fonder une famille quand vous êtes un
jeune entre 20 et 30 ans ? Vous savez
quel est le
taux d'hospitalisation pour tentative de
suicide chez les jeunes femmes de 15 à
25 ans ? La source, il a été euh c'est
l'adresse, il a été multiplié par 8 en
moins de 10 ans. Multiplication, j'ai
vraiment répété ça, multiplication par 8
des tentatives des hospitalisations pour
tentative de suicide des jeunes femmes
entre 15 et 25 ans. Et donc vous vous
retrouvez dans une sorte de violence
évidemment qui commence à devenir
absolument déréglée avec des magistrats
qui sont nommés selon les accompances
politiques, sur leur capacité à rendre
service selon les accomenances
politiques. Moi ce que je vois en tant
que en tant qu'avocat, c'est que
évidemment que vous avez pas vous pensez
vraiment que le ministre de la justice
et son cabinet savent qui sont les
magistrats dans les villes moyenne et de
province. Ils s'en fichent complètement.
Eux ce qui compte c'est les détenteurs
du pouvoir dans les grands pôles. Vous
voyez ceux qui vont être au sein du
parquet national financier, ceux qui
vont être au parquet de Paris, ceux qui
vont leur permettre à un moment donné
d'instrumentaliser la justice. Et donc
vous avez des magistrats simples qui eux
essayent de faire leur travail de façon
intègre et honnête et qui se voi en fait
enfermé et écrasé par une tutelle qui
elle est dans la magouille, qui elle est
dans les arrangements. Vous avez des
éléments pour corroborer vos dire ? J'ai
passé ces sep dernières années, ces h
dernières années, j'ai passé ce que ces
quinquen et demi à me battre contre des
personnes qui se mettaient à genoux
devant le pouvoir et qui portaient une
robe qui était censée être portée au nom
du peuple français et qui atteignait et
qui atteignait aux intérêts de citoyens
français pour défendre leur carrière.
J'ai vu des gens instrumentaliser des
questions de violence sexuelle. J'ai vu
des gens instrumentaliser de façon et
hontée des questions de lutte contre la
corruption. J'ai vu des gens protégés
des violeurs, protégé des corrompus,
protéger des personnes qui étaient en
train de manipuler les le budget de
l'État pour en détourner des quantités
astronomiques pour leurs amis. et tout
ça dans un mais bien sûr parce que la
seul le seul avantage c'est vachement
important pour nous de c'est c'est il
faudra nous donner les sources qui qui
peut corroborer vos déclarations pour
nous c'est très important vous les avez
peut-être pas de nous les donner par
exemple les chiffres duf les machins les
il faut ça c'est quelle étude qui à
chaque fois sur le cr et ainsi de suite
tout ça c'est c'est les statistiques de
l'état parce que la corruption qui nous
gangraine n'a pas touché tous les corps.
Et euh vous pouvez faire confiance à des
agences statistiques comme l'INC, vous
pouvez faire confiance à des agences
d'État comme l'adresse qui s'occupe des
questions de santé. Vous pouvez faire
confiance encore à ces à ces personnes
qui sont très mal payées et qui
justement ont chevillé au corps le
service de l'État. Vous savez combien de
combien quel est le salaire de départ
d'un chercheur au CNRS ? Je vais vous
donner je vous déjà d'abord je vais vous
expliquer ce qu' le CNRS et ce qui un
chercheur au CNRS. C'est quand même
important. 1650 balles je crois non ?
1700 balles. Le CNRS c'est l'Institut de
recherche publique de l'État. C'est
notre joyau. C'est ceux qui en toute
matière que ce soit la sciences dur,
sciences humaines, ainsi de suite sont
censés recueillir les plus brillants
chercheurs français. Donc des gens qui
ont fait 8 années d'études après le bac,
qui ont fait un doctorat qui après sont
un peu politisés ces gens-là. Non,
attendez, j'arrive, j'arrive. qui qui
après un doctorat, on fait souvent des
des postdoctorats qui ont des thèses de
plusieurs centaines de pages et qui à un
moment donné décident de postuler dans
la recherche publique, qui veulent pas
partir dans le privé, qui veulent pas
partir dans la finance comme le font de
plus en plus d'étudiants des grandes
écoles parce qu'il croient encore dans
l'idée que bah se passionner pour un
sujet x ou y va avoir une
valeur.
Aujourd'hui, je vais vous donner mon
exemple, c'était il y a il y a 10 ans.
Je fais une thèse en
droit et en philosophie à l'École
normale supérieure. Je fais un post
doctorat au Max Plan Institute qui est
l'équivalent du CNRS en Allemagne
extraordinairement prestigieux, très
bien payé comme seigneur chercheur
seigneor et ainsi de suite. Et donc je
me dis je vais peut-être faire ça de ma
vie. Et je postule du coup au CNRS.
Alors, je postule en philo. Première
étape, je découvre qu'on est 250
candidats, 250 docteurs, des gens qui
ont fait un doctorat pendant 3 4 5 ans
qui en plus après ont fait publier des
des articles, ainsi de suite, qui ont
fait des séjours à l'étranger pour un
poste. Pour un poste, c'est-à-dire vous
allez avoir 249 personnes qui vont pas
avoir de poste, qu'on a formé, qui nous
ont coûté de l'argent, qu'on a à qui on
a donné accès au plus aux institutions
les plus exigeantes de de la République.
OK. Première étape, écrémage, il en
reste 50. Écrémage sur dossier écrit,
c'estàd la thèse, ainsi de suite. Et là
donc il y a un jury de trois personnes
qui est censé examiner les dossiers de
50 docteurs. Donc lire 50 thèses de
plusieurs centaines de pages, tous les
articles qui vont autour, leur projet de
recherche, notivation et décider parmi
eux lequel doit être sélectionné. Vous
savez combien de temps dure l'examen
oral, donc la phase d'admission au CNRS
? 10
minutes. Et donc vous allez nous faire
croire que ces personnes qui font ça,
c'est ces chercheurs eux-mêmes, ces
professeurs d'université qui ont toutes
les autres obligations qu'ils ont, qui
n'ont évidemment pas eu le temps de dire
250 thèses, même pas les parcourir, vont
véritablement faire ce travail de
sélection, ainsi de suite. Moi, j'ai
refusé de participer à cette pantonymie.
J'y suis allé en disant "Écoutez, ce que
vous faites est vraiment une comédie et
insultant pour tous ceux qui participent
et je suis parti. Euh tout ça pour
gagner 1950 € net par mois. Vous
commencez votre carrière à 1950 € net
par mois. Vous ne pouvez pas vous loger
à Paris avec ce salaire. C'est
impossible. Et vous répercutez ça sur
l'ensemble des professions qui ont une
valeur pour la société aujourd'hui.
L'ensemble des personnes qui essayent de
contribuer d'une façon un minimum
honnête et intègre. Et donc évidemment
derrière la corruption, évidemment
derrière le désespoir. Et quand vous
avez Emmanuel Macron qui va faire le
guignol en essayant de surfer par le
biais de ses conseillers en
communication sur guignol et ainsi de
suite sur les
chercheurs parce que c'est c'est vous
avez raison et en même temps c'est
difficile de
pas de pas ressentir une forme
d'indignation à l'égard de ce qu'ils
font parce que ces conditions dans la
recherche publique française n'ont pas
empêché Manuel Macron de prétendre qu'on
allait accueillir des chercheurs
États-Uiens qui soi-disant allaient fuir
ce qui se passait avec Donald Trump. On
a besoin de sociologues. C'est des gens
qui sont de toute façon payés quat c
fois minimum en début de carrière que
les chercheurs français. Il y en a pas
un qui viendrait de toute façon. Et nous
non seulement on prétend pour les
caméras pour donner l'impression qu'on
existe encore politiquement, qu'on a
encore quelque chose à porter au monde,
que on va pouvoir les accueillir et il
débloque une 100 million d'euros qui ne
va pas à la recherche française, qui ne
va pas à la recherche fondamentale. Il
faut pas s'étonner derrière de
l'effondrement du pays, y compris sur
des questions que ce soit nucléaires et
ainsi de suite parce que on se retrouve
dans des situations où on maltraite des
personnes à qui on promet beaucoup. Et
ces gens-là font beaucoup d'efforts pour
s'intégrer, pour essayer d'offrir
quelque chose à la France, pour
respecter les exigences de de ces
différentes institutions et se
retrouvent pris dans des engrenages
absolument délétaires. Vous rajoutez à
ça la violence qui croit au sein de la
société parce que ça commence à créer de
la colère, ça commence à créer et à un
moment donné si vous purgez pas cette
colère, vous la retournez contre ceux
qui sont à côté de vous. Vous la
retournez contre ceux qui plus fragiles
que vous se retrouvent. Donc moi je
pense qu'on est à un moment qui est qui
est d'une particulière gravité pour pour
notre pays. On était à 100 m de l'Élysée
avec les gilets jaunes et on n'est pas
rentré dedans parce qu'on sentait pas
légitime, parce qu'on s'était pas
préparé à le faire et parce qu'on savait
que ce que faisaient ces gens au pouvoir
était mauvais pour le pays. Mais on ne
considérait pas que c'était à nous de
prendre la place sans élection et ainsi
de suite. Je pense que maintenant le
temps est vraiment venu de commencer à à
réfléchir sérieusement sur la
construction d'une alternative. C'est
pour ça qu'on a on a on a on a créé ce
projet. On vous allez vous présenter aux
élections présidentielles de 2027. On va
notre objectif c'est c'est de les faire
tomber d'une façon ou d'une autre et de
faire retrouver à à notre peuple sa
souveraineté. Que ce soit par
l'élection, par des formes
sansurrectionnelles ou révolutionnaires,
tout est ouvert. La question à un moment
donné c'est encore une fois c'est des
vies à sauver. C'est des vies qui sont
en train d'être détruites et c'est des
gens qui n'arrivent plus à aimer, qui
n'arrivent plus à désirer et qui
n'arrivent plus à se lier. Et si on
n'analyse pas, y compris tout ce qui se
passe autour de Mou à l'égard de ce
prisme, de cette destruction, de cette
dévoration de la société par elle-même,
on ne comprend pas pourquoi est-ce qu'on
va de panique morale en panique morale,
de percé de haine en percé de haine sans
à aucun moment trouver l'apaisement qui
permettrait à une société de se
développer.
va vous poser des questions sur votre
programme, sur comment ça a été la
genèse de tout ça autre
que des mots qui a bûché sur la
politique étrangère, sur le déficit de
la France, sur le roulement de la
dette, sur la politique énergétique et
comment on fait le ménage de ce qu'il a
à
nettoyer. Comment s'appelle le projet ?
le projet justement très simplement
c'est en gros notre idée c'est de
générer des aurores après les
crépuscules qui avaient été décrits dans
dans l'ouvrage qu'on avait présenté ici
il y a quelques années. On s'est réuni à
15000 autour d'une plateforme quelque
chose qui s'appelle un Discord. Je sais
pas si vous avez déjà entendu parler.
C'est euh une plateforme qui permet en
fait notre idée c'est quoi ? que on a
plus besoin de 20 ou 40 millions d'euros
comme c'était le cas classiquement pour
faire de la politique en France chose
collaborativ voilà avec des plateformes
publiques open source avec toute une
série de de mécanismes très faciles y
compris les réseaux sociaux à à
manœuvrer. On peut générer une
alternative crédible aux personnes
existantes en contournant le mur
oligarchique c'està-dire en contournant
les médias traditionnels et leur
contrôle par des personnes dont on sait
très bien qu'il les achètent dans le
seul but d'influencer les politiques.
un livre crépuscule que vous avez
peut-être lu et qui et qui décrit par le
menu
comment aujourd'hui le journalisme en
France n'a plus de rapport à la vérité
ou à l'intérêt général mais mais n'est
qu'un un vecteur et un véhicule de
corruption. Enfin, je pense que c'est
quelque chose d'ailleurs de toute façon
qu'on a qu'on a tous perçu qui nous
amène à nous détacher de ça, mais qui
génère aussi beaucoup
de beaucoup de dangers parce que si on a
plus de référence commune sur ce qui est
et ce qui n'est pas euh la désagrégation
en fait tape à la porte et la
désagrégation d'un pays comme la France
serait extraordinairement dangereuse
pour nous et pour le reste du monde.
Moi, j'ai beaucoup de j'ai une
sacralisation du de mon pays assez assez
profonde qui je pense est lié à
l'origine de mes parents et au fait
qu'ils ont choisi de venir en France. Et
j'accepte pas en fait cette cet
effondronnement. J'accepte pas vraiment.
C'est quand je vous dis quand quand
quand j'ai vu apparaître sur mon fil
cette image de la pince avec la dent
arrachée par une personne que j'avais
rencontré pendant les gilets jaunes et
que que je l'ai reposté et que j'ai vu
les centaines de commentaires de chaque
personne en laer dans la drôme qui
racontait les difficultés qu'ils
avaient, les personnes qui étaient
mortes, les personnes qui avaient vu de
façon définitive leur vie s'effondrer.
C'est c'est quelque chose à laquelle
vous pouvez c'est même pas que vous
pouvez pas rester indifférent, c'est
qu'en fait ça tangibilise tout ce que
vous craignez les années précédent. La
première fois qu'on s'est vu, je pense
que j'avais une dénonciation donc
c'était le premier Thinkeriew, c'était
en 2017, j'avais une dénonciation de
principe. Vous voyez, je considérais
qu'il y avait un problème de principe.
C'est le le rapport au mensonge, le
l'indifférence à la vérité, la
corruption me blessait en tant que
éthiquement, en tant qu'être humain,
mais abstraitement. Là, on commence à
voir s'inscrire dans les chaires, les
conséquences de cette déréli. C'est
dizaines centaines de milliards d'euros
qui disparaissent, qui s'évapore. C'est
quand même, on peut pas, on peut pas on
peut pas faire grandir ses enfants dans
un pays où il est beaucoup
plus rémunérateur à la fois en argent,
mais aussi symboliquement d'escroquer
quelqu'un qu'en essayant de contribuer
au bien commun. Or, aujourd'hui, c'est à
ça qu'on est en train d'arriver. Je me
suis rendu compte quand j'étais prof
remplaçant à Saint-Toin et à Tier,
j'avais beaucoup de mal à je me je me
disais moi moi c'était des moments
voyez, j'étais à côté avocat ou avant au
Quadorsais mais je me disais je voyais
la difficulté pour mes mes collègues
professeurs de se faire respecter et de
faire autorité sur les gamins qu'ils
avaient à traiter alors qu'ils avaient
le salaire d'une d'un caissier ou d'une
caissière de supermarché. Vous voyez ?
C'estd que les amener à à faire le
chemin compliqué surtout lorsque vous
venez de classe populaire où vous avez
pas tous les codes. C'estàd que vous
devez faire un effort supplémentaire par
rapport à ceux qui qui viennent des
classes les plus favorisées. Comment les
inciter à aller vers là quand le but et
le résultat en terme de hiérarchie
sociale, de respect que ça génère est
quasiment nul, voire négatif. Soit je
parle des caissiers et caissières, au
moins c'est un métier noble. Enfin, vous
voyez, c'est qui qui est qui est qui est
difficile, qui est euh pas de
sous-métier, voilà. Mais aujourd'hui, le
problème, c'est même plus ça. C'est même
plus une question de hiérarchie sociale
qui incite justement la personne qui euh
voudrait contribuer un peu plus à
société, avoir un peu plus de confort en
retour et ainsi de suite. Non, là on est
face à des une l'alternative c'est quoi
? Voilà, pouvoir partir à Dubaï parce
que vous avez avec le CPF, avec je sais
pas quoi. Et Dubaï c'est intéressant
parce que c'est pas seulement l'arnaque,
c'est qu'en plus derrière vous partez
avec la valise. C'est c'est même pas
comme si vous êtes dans votre
escroquerie, vous restez en France et
puis ça ça à un moment donné ça revient.
Non non, c'est cette idée absolue. C'est
non seulement je suis en train
d'escroquer cette société qui m'a tant
donné, mais en plus je file avec avec
les valises. Et quand à la tête de
l'État, c'est le même exemple qui est
donné, quand à la tête de l'État, vous
avez des systèmes pour protéger là
encore hier, la procureur de la
République qui refuse de poursuivre
Alexis Colère parce que il n'a pas
respecté une obligation légale qui était
de se rendre à une
convocation de d'une commission
d'enquête parlementaire. Donc c'est pas
qu'elle refuse de le renvoyer au
tribunal et éventuellement qu'il se
fasse condamner, c'est qu'elle refuse
d'enquêter, c'est qu'elle refuse de
l'entendre, de le convoquer en édition
libre pour qu'il s'explique et qu'il
donne ses raisons pour lesquelles il n'a
pas respecté la loi. Quand l'impunité
arrive à ce niveau-là, c'est-à-dire que
même le processus judiciaire, même le
processus judiciaire, je dis parle pas
de la condamnation euh n'est réservé
qu'à quelques ans. vous retrouvez euh
évidemment, mais pour être présumé au
nacent, il faut que la loi puisse
s'appliquer. C'estàd qu'il faut que vous
passiez par les étapes euh que la loi
prévoit. La loi, c'est théoriquement la
l'expression de la volonté générale. Et
d'ailleurs, c'est un des enjeux
fondamentaux parce que on le voit bien
que l'Assemblée nationale, le Sénat
n'ont plus vraiment de légitimité. Moi,
honnêtement, un des enjeux fondamentaux,
c'est que demain on puisse tous voter
directement. le modèle suisse avec des
référendums sur des sujets divers et
variés à initiative des citoyens même
pas en attendant que le grand maître à
un moment donné décide de nous rendre
comme des petites miettes la parole non
notre capacité nous a décidé un moment
de d'intervenir sur un sujet à un moment
donné avec les applications, avec tout
ce qu'on va pouvoir générer avec la
blockchain c'estàdire vraiment la
possibilité de retracer pour s'assurer
qu'il y a pas de corruption de man in
the middle et ainsi de suite on va
pouvoir générer des dispositifs qui vont
faire que le parlement tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui
sera peut-être plus nécessaire. Il faut
commencer à réfléchir à ces sujets. On
peut pas rester sur des structures de
pouvoir qui datent du 18e siècle quand à
un moment donné la communication est
devenue si immédiate. Il y a un moment
donné où les 577 députés qu'on paye
aujourd'hui, les centaines de millions
d'euros qu'on dépense pour eux, il faut
regarder les choses en face. Ils ne
servent plus à rien. On ne les reconnaît
plus ni comme personne qui défendent nos
intérêts, ni comme expert évidemment, de
moins en moins, ni comme personne qui a
pas doté d'un sens commun ou d'une
légitimité ou d'une sagesse. Au
contraire. Au contraire. Donc tout ça,
il faut il faut le remettre à plat. Les
référendum initiative citoyennes, les
mandats impératifs et révocatoires, des
revendications des gilets jaunes, la
possibilité de choisir notre propre
politique monétaire et lire le
gouverneur de la Banque de France, c'est
quelque chose de très simple, c'est
qu'on a une campagne avec des gens qui
vont proposer des politiques monétaires
différentes et c'est à nous et pas à des
gens dans des comités, je sais pas quoi,
de décider, non, à nous de décider si on
veut plus ou moins d'inflation, si on
veut plus ou moins voyez, ces facteursl
sont sont fondamentaux. Rendre la parole
au peuple, permettre au peuple de
décider directement. C'est aussi simple
que ça. Avoir des défenseurs de droit,
faire lire les magistrats. Pourquoi
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on est jugé ?
Pourquoi est-ce que les gens qui ont le
contrôle sur la chose la plus sacrée
dans un pays sont des gens qui alors
qu'ils étaient des gamins ont réussi un
concours plus ou moins intéressant, plus
ou moins technique à 22 23 ans et toute
leur vie en toute impunité vont pouvoir
décider de la vie de gens, affecter la
vie de gens, parfois détruire. la vie de
gens sans qu'il y a aucun moment un
contrôle démocratique. Les statistiques
concernant les erreurs judiciaires, vous
savez combien
de au mi-temps des années 2010 euh on a
décidé de permettre au justiciables de
saisir le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature qui est l'organe qui est
censé contrôler les les magistrats et
donc de pouvoir déposer une plainte pour
pouvoir enclencher des actions
déontologiques ou disciplinaires contre
contre contre les magistrats. Il y a eu
plus de 15000
sisésines. Vous savez combien de son
combien de dossiers à l'année ? Euh non
non, il y a eu plus de 15000 fois le le
le l'institution a été saisie plus de
15000 fois par des citoyens. Vous savez
combien de sanctions ont ont été
prises aujourd'hui ? Je pense que c'est
trois.
la il y a un an quand j'ai regardé
c'était un et c'était un blame la
sanction la plus basse qu'on puisse
expliquer. En attendant, on a des
magistrats qui ont été pris la main sur
le fait en train d'essayer de prostituer
leur fille de la vendre à des réseaux de
pédoproxitisme. Magistra qui s'est
masturbé des comportements des violences
dans dans des choses mais vraiment de
tout ordre. Ça c'est ça c'est disons la
partie la plus visible. C'est c'est
quatre mais mais il y a surtout il y a
surtout la compromission. Il y a combien
de l'erreur la la l'acheté c'est que à
un moment donné regarde un je vais vous
donner un exemple un juge d'instruction
aujourd'hui a entre 100 et 150 dossiers
à traiter en continu. C'est 100 à 150
vies au moins parce que les dossiers
souvent impliquent qui qui soient entre
ses mains une grande majorité
criminelle. Et vous devez en permanence
sur le qui vient sur chacun de ces
dossiers. vous devez connaître les
centaines de pages qui sont entre vos
mains et ainsi de suite. Et injuste
instruction, on a l'image dans l'espace
public d'une toute puissance et ainsi de
suite. Quelqu'un juste instruction quand
vous retrouvez dans dans son cabinet
aujourd'hui surtout au tribunal
judiciaire de de de Paris qui est encore
les fruits d'une d'un scandale
particulièrement
marquant une compromission entre BIG et
Sarkozi. Vous retrouvez il y a des
traces, il y a des sources. Ah j'ai
gagné un procès contre Buig. chez Big
parce que du coup ça c'est le comble le
tribunal judiciaire de
Paris est entre les mains de Big
appartient à BIG donc on juge donc m'a
poursuivi ça veut dire quoi il est entre
les mains et c'est quoi il l'a construit
il a construit ils ils sont encore les
les les les murs sont à eux et on a une
sorte de concession pendant 25 ans.
C'est c'est assez extraordinaire. Le
montage est un peu un peu complexe mais
a permis en gros de récupérer un peu
plus d'un milliard d'euros de trop
perçus qui ont été offerts par le
pouvoir d'abord sarcosiste. Votre
interprétation. Ah mais là pour le coup
Dieu sait si je ne supporte
pas euh euh je je vous répondre je ne
supporte pas l'instrumentalisation de
l'autorité judiciaire qui est très loin
aujourd'hui d'être en mesure de dire la
vérité. très loin et ça ça participe de
notre crise de confiance majeure. Mais
comme la question je j'imagine est
inquiète des répercussions du cir de ce
que je vous dis euh BIG a tenté de me
faire poursuivre parce que j'avais
révélé ce scandale et euh a perdu euh
malgré les quatre avocats qu'ils avaient
euh dépêchés euh devant le tribunal
duire qui appartenait à Bib. Vous avez
vous avez commencé votre interview en
disant "Ah, j'ai j'ai gagné des procès
contre Pierre, Paul, Jacques d'Armanin
et Jean-Passe contre Buig. C'estd qu'il
y a encore une justice en en me
défendant seul. Non non, à chaque fois
c'est vous êtes sur le fil du rasoir et
à chaque fois et à chaque fois vous
retrouvez dans une situation où j'ai
survécu. J'ai survécu. Vous avez perdu
combien de pensé à
des à titre personnel en ce qui me
concerne moi parce que j'étais ciblé
j'ai eu le droit à à 43 procédures
judiciaires pendant sous la macronnie.
J'en avais eu zéro avant. Zéro. Vous
voyez comment en fait en en quelques
années on vous on vous on tente de vous
faire
basculer du tout au rien juste parce
qu'à un moment donné vous êtes décidé de
dévoiler le fonctionnement interne.
C'est c'est très effrayant le
fonctionnement actuel français et on et
ils savent aussi que la procédure en soi
suffit à détruire, suffit à intimider,
suffit à fracasser. Donc euh la question
qui se posait
sur
sur BIG et de façon générale sur ce que
vous me demandiez à l'égard de à les
sources, cet attachement que vous avez
professé en début d'entretien est
exactement le même qui m'a amené à cet
engagement ces dernières années et
surtout à faire un travail vraiment de
décorticage étape par étape de
l'ensemble des systèmes auxquels on
était confronté pour essayer de
factualiser
euh ce que ce que j'énonçais et et on a
réussi sur toute cette période à
résister à de grandes offensives. Par
exemple, au Sénégal, on a quand même
réussi à
sortir quelqu'un qui est accusé du viol,
d'attentat, de vol de téléphone portable
pour lui permettre de se présenter aux
élections qu'il a remporté brillamment
et de devenir premier ministre alors que
son compare c'était président. Est-ce
que la justice était indépendante au
Sénégal ? Au quel moment ? Donc ce qui
se joue, c'est pas du tout
l'indépendance de justice. C'est pas
c'est la capacité pour des personnes
comme moi à avoir des instruments qui
permettent de faire face et de limiter
les dégâts. Est-ce que ces instruments
sont entre les mains de n'importe quel
français ? Pas du tout. J'ai le
privilège d'avoir une formation, d'avoir
un métier qui me permette d'essayer un
peu de protéger. C'est ce qui m'a permis
d'obtenir ces victoires contre. Mais
n'importe quel si vous pensez que quand
Brigitte Macron, Emmanuel Macron, Gérald
Armanain vont porter plainte
personnellement ou pire dépêche leur
directeur de cabinet, leur chef de
cabinet comme si c'était des laquets
personnels chargés de non c'est
factuellement ce qui est arrivé quand
vous avez Gérald Darman ministre de
l'intérieur qui a d'autres chat à fouer
que d'aller porter plainte contre Ro qui
dépêche son alors contre moi ça ça on y
reviendra mais contre non c'est encore
pire qui dépêche son directeur de
cabinet au commissariat du 8e
arrondissement à côté de la place
Beauaveau de Paris pour porter plainte
contre un ouvrier handicapé à cause d'un
accident du travail qui a eu le tort de
poster en
commentaire d'un poste sur un groupe
privé sur Facebook une caricature de
Darmanin le montrant avec le masque.
Vous saure qu'on avait fait sur De
Gaulle en 68 où de Gaulle avait le
masque d'Hitler, il enlevait, on voyait
de Gaul et on le mettait. sorte de
provocation comme ça 68 et en gros ce
gif quand vous tapez aujourd'hui d'armin
sur Facebook euh quand vous tapez sur
les gif c'est le premier qui apparaît
mais avec la tête de Darmanin donc euh
cette personne qui qui habite dans le
centre de la
France poste sur un groupe privé en
commentaire d'un toc toc gendarmerie
national convoqué à 400 km de chez lui à
Pontoise pour être jugé pénalement sur
plainte de Gér Géral
d'Armanin, à quel moment le directeur de
cabinet, un ministre de l'intérieur qui
est censé
s'occuper à tout instant de la sécurité
des Français, à tout instant, sans une
minute de Répi, trouve le temps d'aller
au commissariat de déposer plainte pour
son ministre du fait de ce commentaire
là. Ça c'est la réalité à laquelle on a
été confronté au quotidien. que Géraldin
porte plainte contre moi quand j'ai
défendu un de mes clients Kamy Sebba euh
avec voilà qu'on a passé au grill à qui
on a retiré la nationalité française
pour une raison très simple c'est parce
qu'il s'est opposé à la guerre au Niger
que la France voulait déclencher qui
fricotait avec les Russes ou les
Iraniens pas la France pas la France
qu'Emmanuel Macron vou Emmanuel Macron
voulait nous emporter et nous amener à
la guerre contre contre le pays qui est
aujourd'hui en terme de PIB le plus
pauvre au monde. Il a voulu déclencher
avec la CDAO, il a essayé de créer une
coalition mon seulement l'opposition de
la société civile et donc de Kimba qui a
empêché cette catastrophe de la même
façon que si on n'est pas devenu les
principaux alliés de Netaniaahu dans le
massacre qu'il est en train de commettre
à Gaza. C'est pas parce que nous avons
voulu, c'est parce que la proposition
d'Emmanuel Macron, souvenez-vous, de
constituer une coalition internationale
au côté de Netaniaou pour mener cette
guerre à Gaza a été refusé par
Netaniaou. De la même façon que si nous
ne sommes pas aujourd'hui en guerre
contre la Russie avec des troupes au
sol comme l'avait proposé Emmanuel
Macron, ce n'est pas parce que nous
avons réussi à l'empêcher ou parce
qu'Emmanuel Macron s'en est rendu compte
de l'absurdité de laqu c'est parce que
Trump a été élu. Je me fais l'avocat du
diable, on a le temps. Mais je finis
c'est que à trois reprises ces dernières
années, à trois reprises, on a failli
entrer en guerre et on ne se rend pas
compte du fait qu'on était complètement
impuissant à cet égard. Je me fais la
vocale du diable.
Géraldin, il a aussi sa sensibilité. Il
voit ça, il est choqué, ça ça le blesse.
Il voit ça. Vous pensez vraiment qu'il a
vu ça ? Bah forcément, il traîne dans
des groupes
privés, il a pas autre chose à faire.
Non, il a pas vu ça. Il a pas vu ça.
Vous savez ce c'est le plus effrayant ?
et qu' il y a des rapports des RT, des
renseignements territoriaux qui vont
écumer au lieu au lieu de s'occuper de
la sécurité des Français, de la
stabilisser, au lieu de faire remonter
les difficultés pour se soigner, pour
avoir accès à la justice, pour tout
simplement se nourrir, ils font ils font
de la police politique. Ils vont voir
dans les groupes privés de gilets
jaunes, ainsi de suite. Juste un détail,
vous êtes pas au courant de ce qu'ils
font monter. Vous êtes pas dans le
secret des dieux. Ah bah c'est la c'est
là la la Qu'est-ce qui vous dit
qu'est-ce qui c'est là la chance qui
vous a dit qu'il faisait pas remonter la
prise de température de la France le
dossier judiciaire ? Pourquoi c'était à
Pontoise ? Bah parce que la direction de
la gendarmerie nationale qui s'en
occupait était à Pontoise. C'est pour ça
qu'il est des juifs là-bas. Et en fait
la chance qu'on a comme avocat et c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont essayé par tout moyen
et qu'il continuent à essayer de me
retirer du barreau, c'est que on a accès
à une partie du secret des dieux parce
qu'ils sont bien obligés d'expliquer
comment ils en sont arrivés là. Vous
voyez cette cette obscurité autour de
comment fonctionne l'appareil d'État
s'éclaircit lorsque vous avez accès au
dossier judiciaire. Quand vous avez là
Brigitte Macron euh qui euh euh décide
de faire arrêter euh euh un certain
nombre de citoyens français à cause des
rumeurs qu'il y a eu sur son identité
sexuelle et que il se retrouve 6h du
matin toc toc à la porte. Elle se fait
emmerder à longueur de de
journée. Son honneur. Je pense qu'il y a
il y a beaucoup de Français qui
rêveraient d'avoir les difficulté que
vous mentionnez euh avec la vie qu'elle
a protéger comme elle est et avec les
bénéfices qui sont une raison. Ça reste
quand même une personne humaine. C'est
important de défendre tout le monde. De
défendre tout le monde. Ouais. pas
d'instrumentaliser en l'occurrence le
commandement militaire de l'Élysée. Le
commandement militaire de l'Élysée,
c'est le monde qui l'a révélé à rien de
chemin. Le commandement militaire de
l'Élysée pour diriger des opérations de
police et soi-disant de justice. Là, on
commence à toucher à quelque chose qui
est particulièrement grave. Là, on
va au-delà de l'indécent. parce que que
l'on décide de s'aborder des principes
qui en France dominaient depuis 1880 qui
consistent à refuser une quelconque
mesure privative de liberté contre
quiconque du fait de l'usage de la
liberté d'expression. Principe cardinal
inscrit dans la loi lorsqu'il s'agit de
liberté d'expression, y compris de
mesages, y compris d'ffamation, y
compris d'injure, on ne met pas
quelqu'un en garde à vue, on ne met pas
quelqu'un en prison. Qui c'est qu'on
renverse cela comme ça a été le cas à
travers l'instrumentalisation. Vous
savez cette loi sur le cyberharcèlement
qu'on a fait
adopter en prétendant protéger les plus
vulérablèse on est en guerre avec la
Russie on est en guerre économique on
est en guerre de sanction a mais non on
n pas en guerre avec la Russie
arrê terminé pas terminé
mettez-vous une seconde on fait une
expérience de pensée ensemble allons-y
mettez-vous à la place du
pouvoir. Notre économie est menacée. Il
y a des puissances étrangères
prédatrices. Il y a de
l'ingérence X Y Z de Pierre Paul Jacques
de Sergeil ou de du lord britannique et
j'en passé des
meilleurs. Le pouvoir a des raisons de
voir que il y a des opérations
coordonnées pour faire
passer Brigitte Jean-Pierre pour des
cocaïnoman ou pour des pour autre chose.
Ouais. Ils se disent "On va aller
écouter ces gens-là, on va essayer de de
comprendre qui les finance, qui les
influence, ils font leur job." Ah parce
que c'est ça qu'ils ont fait. Bah ils
ont ils ont été quatre mecs au milieu de
nulle part qui n'avaient aucun rapport
avec rien. Il se dit ils ont sacré bonne
couverture. Ouais. Donc c'est eux voilà
c'est le citoyen lambda en France qui
bien sûr est en connexion directe avec
les antennes de Moscou qui sont en train
de téléguider le pas vu la séance euh
celle-ci non mais je sais je sais de
quoi il s'agit. C'est-à-dire de
l'infiltration d'espions russes dans
dans Oui, comme si c'était une famille
lambda.
Soit on parle d'intérêt d'état, de
dissuasion
nucléaire, de gestion de nos armées, de
nucléaires tout court, civil et là là
j'attends de mes services de
renseignement qu'il me protège en tant
que citoyen. J'attends qu'il prennent
des
mesures qui fassent que face à
l'ingérence de la CIA, du SRU, du
voilà, on se retrouve dans une situation
où il y a une vulnérabilité.
Quand avec Julien et Wikileak, je révèle
que il y a un espionnage systématique
par la NSA de toute entreprise française
qui participe à des appels d'offre
supérieurs à 250 millions d'euros, qui
se retrouve fiché au contreespionnage,
qui se prend les
sanctions de la part de la France ?
Est-ce que c'est la puissance américaine
? Est-ce que c'est ceux qui ont mis à
nos intérêts, qui ont sacrifié des
milliers d'emplois ? c'est moi. Donc ne
venez pas me faire le discours de la
DGSI, ADGSE. Non, la DGC et la ADGE
servent le pouvoir en place avec
certaines limites avec des agents qui
parfois essayent d'empêcher que cela
aille trop loin. Mais quand vous êtes en
France un opposant qui essaye de façon
la plus digne et la plus respectueuse
possible de la vérité, de l'intégrité,
de la souveraineté nationale de vous
opposer à ce pouvoir en place, et bien
vous vous faites massacrer. Et
qu'importe c'est moi c'est c'est quelque
chose que j'ai j'ai trouvé scandaleux au
cours de cette période en défendant un
certain nombre de personnes, cette idée
de se dire on va protéger cette personne
parce que quoi qu'il arrive elle est
française et elle contribue à quelque
chose au sein de société. Même si on
n'est pas d'accord, même si elle
s'oppose à ceux qui nous dirigent
aujourd'hui ainsi de suite, elle aura
peut-être une valeur de main et au
contraire le fait de la détruire
volontairement sans aucune difficulté,
sans aucune censure parce que on
considère que la France c'est soi-même
en fait. C'est ça la confusion. euh sur
l'affaire Brigitte Macron. C'est ça qui
fait que le commandement militaire se
retrouve impliqué dans une procédure.
C'est factuel. C'est ça vient de là.
Cette confusion un peu monarchique qui
consiste à penser que l'État leur
appartient. Qui sont ces gens pour
prétendre que l'État leur appartient ?
parce qu'ils ont gagné dans des
conditions que l'on sait deux élections
à un moment donné avec des
manipulations, des effondrements
successifs des candidats des autres
forces politique. Un moment, il faut
avec l'instrumentalisation en 2022 de la
fonction présidentielle autour de la
guerre en Ukraine
pour se mettre en avant et écraser les
autres candidats en refusant de débattre
avec les autres candidats, en les
empêchant d'accéder à la possibilité de
faire concurrence et de et de et de se
légitimer dans le cadre de la
perspective présidentielle. Parce que
une campagne présidentielle, voyez,
c'est un rituel. Et si aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron se retrouve seul à
chaque fois qu'il fait ses défilés du
humé, ainsi de suite et qui salue des
platanes plutôt que des foules qui
viennent le voir, il faut quand même
s'interroger sur ce qui l'échec qui est
le sien dans sa capacité à incarner
cette fonction présentielle. Si comme ça
a été le cas par encore une fois une des
personnes que j'ai défendu, il finit par
se retrouver souffleté par un par un
citoyen français comme c'était le cas de
la part de Damien Tarel à son égard. Il
faut quand même à un moment donné que
raisonne en lui les interrog quand si se
retrouve la cible de rumeurs sur son
identité sexuelle, sur sa euh sa son sa
consommation de drogue et ainsi il y a
un moment donné où ces personnes doivent
s'interroger sur qu'est-ce qui fait que
ça devient possible de les attaquer
cette façon au lieu d'essayer d'écraser
à chaque fois celui qui de plus ou moins
bonne fois va essayer d'appuyer sur le
point sensible. Il faut essayer c'est un
peu c'est un peu la critique que je fais
à l'extrême droite par rapport à
l'islam. Je leur dis, c'est très bien de
créer des boucles émissaires et d'être
obsés. À un moment donné, il faut se
dire qu'est-ce qui donne notre société
des failles pour qu'on narrive pas à
produire et à générer des horizons qui
soient plus attrayants que ceux d'un
islamisme radical. Donc pardonnez-moi,
il y a quand même en terme de capacité
de séduction, c'est relativement faible.
C'estàd que les devenirs qu'on vous
promet euh à part si on pense à
l'au-delà sont pas non plus florissants.
Donc qu'est-ce qui au sein de nos
sociétés fait que en terme identitaire
notre offre n'est pas suffisamment
puissante pour faire contrepoid à ces
entrepreneurs, soit de haine, soit soit
d'idéologie radicale. Et bien cette
réflexion là n'apparaît pas et elle
n'apparaît ni à droite ni à gauche.
Cette gauche Zara que que je critique
souvent, j'ai pas compris. Mais oui,
c'est très simple en fait. Quand vous
regardez le programme du NFP, vous
comprenez qu'en gros le seul objectif
qui la seule perspective qui était
proposée c'était de permettre de
consommer plus. À aucun moment, il y
avait une
interrogation. On est on a une crise
identitaire en France profonde. Il faut
il faut il faut il faut il faut arrêter
de de nier cette évidence. Mais elle
vient d'où ? Elle vient entre autres du
fait que on s'habille comme n'importe
quelle personne partout dans le monde et
on continue à pouvoir s'habiller malgré
les salaires qui sont écrasés ainsi de
suite parce qu'on a des esclaves à des
milliers de kilomètres de chez nous dans
le sud-est asiatique qui sont en train
de trimer pour nous fabriquer des
vêtements qui sont dessinés par des
personnes de façon être le plus
standardisée possible qui font qu'on a y
compris dans notre y compris lorsqu'on
se regarde on a plus d'identité c'est
qu' on n plus rattaché à un territoire
on n'est plus rattaché à une communauté
il n'y a plus rien qui nous ressemble et
qui du coup nous rassemble. Et donc au
lieu de réfléchir à ce qui génère cette
crise et la façon de la corriger,
c'est-à-dire réinterniser de la
production et pas seulement d'industrie
de masse aussi quelque chose auquel j'ai
pensé qui m'a d'où me vient cette
réflexion, c'est les les deventures de
des boutiques Louis Viton. Voyez, c'est
ces boutiques qui se font de plus en
plus qu'ololé récemment. On conna
pas ils ont ces derniers mois, pendant
quelques mois, ils ont eu comme
deventure euh toute une série d'images
euh sur les Champs-Élysées euh sur
Champs-Élysé ou même à à au boulevard
Saint-Germain euh qui était dans
l'imagerie du Paris des années 1900.
Donc il reprenait, voyez les stations de
métro et ainsi de suite. Mais quel
révélateur ! du fait que on est obligé
d'aller puiser un siècle en a plutôt le
simple fait d'ailleurs que ça s'appelle
encore le Viton, Christian Dior, il
Saint-Laurent c'estàd que des noms de
créateurs qu'on a jamais réussi à
remplacer et pourquoi ces créateurs
existaient étaient si puissants c'est
parce qu'ils arrivaient à mêler la
tradition ce qui venait de leur terre du
plus profond d'eux même avec de
l'originalité de la modernité ainsi de
suite. Aujourd'hui, on ne génère plus du
tout ça. Aujourd'hui, on est soit
complètement américanisé, soit de plus
en plus standardisé de façon, c'est même
plus identifiable aux États-Unis. Voyez,
c'est une sorte de ventre mou. Ça ça
crée de la crise identitaire parce que
il y a plus de sentiment d'appartenance.
Ces choses-là ne sont pas traitées par
la force politique aujourd'hui, mais
elle est complètement C'est quoi
l'identité française ? Des des
agglomérés. C'est avant tout une terre.
de la France. C'est avant tout en fait
c'est des paysages quand là j'ai donné
des conférences pour justement essayer
de d'aller chercher
des des personnes qui sont désespérées
du politique. On a donné une conférence
à Firminie donc à côté de Saint-Étienne
puis après à Saint-Paul 3 châteaux dans
la Rome. Euh quand vous arrivez et donc
entre-temps on est passé par Lyon,
Saint-Étienne et ainsi de suite, vous
arrivez à Firminie. Euh Firminie, c'est
une terre désolée parce que c'était une
terre qui euh qui euh reposait sur
l'industrie lourde, sur un certain
nombre d'industries extractiv qui ont
été complètement euh euh détruites dans
les années 80 par un choix politique et
euh et qui euh avait euh fait naître une
forme d'espoir au sein des populations
jusqu'à l'ors. C'est-à-dire que par
exemple, vous avez le Corbusier, grand
architecte français qui avait cré
construit une unité d'habitation avec
une école au-dessus d'une barre HLM en
gros et une chapelle qui a été finie
récemment tout en béton avec cette
idéologie du progrès et ainsi de suite.
Pour rappel, Corbus a failli détruire
tout le centre de Paris. On est passé à
ça après, il voulait créer des barres
énormes mais bon donc on est sur un une
terre presque une terre du passé, vous
voyez ? et et la conférence qu'on a
donné là-bas à Emmaus, vous sentiez tout
de
suite c'était très émouvant parce que
vous aviez ce qu'on appelle vraiment des
des gens du peuple, c'est-à-dire
vraiment des des gueules cassées, des
gens qui qui à un moment donné euh après
des années et des années de
précarisation, de violence et d'absence
de perspective finissent
par avoir une émotion à l'égard du
politique, ce qui est devenu très rare
parce que c'est des gens qui en fait ont
vu à quel point le politique avait
détruit leur et qui en fait en pleure et
ça c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
à à à voir parce que pour moi c'est le
ferment c'est le ferment de la France de
demain en fait c'est à partir de cette
émotion là des gens qui qui n'ont qui
n'ont pas encore accepté que c'était
normal voyez qui sont encore dans une
forme de résistance émotionnelle à
l'égard de de ce qu'ils ont vécu. Donc
vous voyez ça
Firminie on descend voiture Valence on
arrive on passe par Triastin les
centrales nucléaires. Il y en a il y en
a trois autour de de Saint- Paul 3
Châteaux et on arrive à Saint-Paul
Châteaux. Le simple le le simple trajet
d'un heure et de le changement de
paysage immédiat. Vous passez des bois
humides de cette forêt française quoi
qu'on connaît qui remonte jusqu'à
Roléan. Enfin, vous voyez qui constitue
d'une grande partie du pays et tout d'un
coup vous rentrez tout de suite en
Provence, vous voyez en 1 heure tout
d'un coup vous basculez sur le paysage
méditerranéen. Ça ça c'est la France
pour commencer. C'est une géographie.
C'est une terre qui est qui a été
travaillée pendant des siècles par des
populations qui ont peu à peu commencé à
se connecter, qui ont peu à peu et
lentement commencer à parler la même
langue après s'être distancié pendant
une période après l'Empire romain qui
sont retrouvés et qui ont constitué une
unité spirituelle d'abord à travers une
religion puis après une identité
symbolique à travers les premières
monarchies qui ont commencé à tenter
d'unifier ça puis après une unité
politique à travers des institutions qui
ont commencé à construire et qui ont
commencé à unifier ce territoire et qui
aujourd'hui se retrouve dans une
situation de puce appartenir avec des
villes d'ortoir où on se concentre des
gens qui n'ont plus de lien avec leur
terre qui ont été à après à partir de
l'après-gerre amené en masse exfiltr en
masse fermini c'est ça c'est beaucoup de
populations immigrées arméniens
italiens maghrébains et beaucoup de
populations rurales qui sont concentrées
dans ces villes et qui tout d'un coup on
été
abandonné au 80 on a décidé qu'ils
étaient plus utiles qu'on allait
importer en fait ce qu' produis jus
l'identité française mis à part les
paysages et c'est pas les paysages,
c'est les c'est la c'est la le travail
d'une terre. C'est le travail d'une
terre siècle après siècle qui a créé un
certain nombre de comportements. Après
vous vous pouvez venir sur tout le
reste, sur la gastronomie, sur la
langue. La langue la langue c'est la
chose la plus précieuse qu'on est. une
langue qui est en train de s'effondrer à
la fois en à l'intérieur mais surtout
dans le reste du monde. cette cette
merveille dans tous les drames que la
colonisation a généré qui fait que vous
pouvez moi en tant qu'avocat, je peux
aller plaider à Dakar à des milliers
komè de chez moi et je peux être
entendu, compris, je peux participer
parce qu'on a ça ça c'est des choses qui
sont extraordinairement précieuses et
qu'on est en train de renoncer
complètement et après évidemment c'est
c'est le génie philosophique musical et
compagnie que d'autres pays ont
différemment mais nous on a nos
caractéristiques et nous on a fait
rayonner en terme d'idée en terme de
création vraiment quelque chose de très
particulier. Mes parents sont venus en
France à cause de l'idée de la France.
Ils sont venus, ils ont choisi la France
parce que on enseignait le français
comme première langue en Espagne, au
Portugal jusqu'aux années 80, pas
l'anglais et parce que on enseignait à
admirer Hugo Balzac et ainsi de suite.
Vous voyez ces choses-là, c'est des
choses qui aujourd'hui n'existent plus.
Qui est-ce qui est-ce qui aujourd'hui
fait rayonner la France et qui est
protégé accompagné couvé pour faire
rayonner la France ? On en est
instrumentaliser des écrivains comme Wem
Saal en Algérie, voyez, pour essayer
d'en faire des instruments du mal, pour
faire de la violence dans le rapport au
peuple au lieu d'être dans cette
perspective d'attrait et de direction.
Quand vous avez Bruno Retaillot qui fait
de la du rapport avec une puissance
qu'il ne faut pas déconsidérer, c'est
que on reste fixé sur la la colonisation
avec l'Algérie comme si c'était une
terre en gros qui est soit soumise, soit
rebelle. Mais avant ça, c'est des terres
où il y avait beaucoup d'interaction y
compris de confrontation avec la France
qui était difficile de gérer. Il y a eu
des trafic d'esclaves, il y a eu des
confrontations entre cors pirat enfin
c'est une terre qui de toute façon il y
a eu des essais nucléaires aussi et qui
et qui restera parce qu'elle est
géographiquement là. C'estàd qu'on il y
a ces réalités géographiques qui sont
complètement ignorées par nos dirigeants
qui pensent qu'à un moment donné on peut
oblitérer un pays. Voilà, il disparaît
et puis on peut pour des raisons
idologiques. Non non non, c'est cette
dynamique là, elle n'est absolument pas
réfléchie parce qu'on s'inscrit dans
dans le temps court, parce qu'on on
s'inscrit dans l'instrumentalisation du
sentiment, du ressenti et de la violence
que génère l'histoire.
On va regarder la table des matières de
votre programme. Ah ok. Puis ensuite, on
va vous pouvez me poser des questions au
hasard he sur la mesure. On les a
vraiment travaillé.
T'inquiète, on va te souer. Alors, tape
des matières, nos priorités, l'urgence,
les normes, démocratie, fin d'impunité,
souveraineté. Ça c'est les concepts. Il
vaut mieux rentrer dans les mesures
parce que si on rentre dansque société
géographie des pouvoirs, les réformes,
la justice, l'intérieur. géographie et
pouvoir par exemple, on veut sortir euh
de la présidence de l'G, la justice,
l'intérieur, l'extérieur et la défense,
l'économie, grandes orientations,
gestion de l'État, fiscalité,
préélèvement social, travail, commerce,
marché et système bancaire, industrie,
le numérique instruction supérieure,
secondaire, primaire et ané primaire, la
santé, le handicap, la protection de
l'enfance, l'agriculture, le vivant et
la mer.
Je tourne la page et c'est bientôt
fini. Les arts et la communication,
l'écologie et le logement, l'Europe
entre parenthèses
transition, l'administration et le
politique. Je vois pas marquer énergie.
Bah si, bien sûr. C'est dans à la fois
dans l'écologie et dans l'industrie.
C'est fondamental. On est dans une
situation c'est fondamental
mais parce qu'on fait n'importe quoi
déjà pour commencer si on reprend la ces
ces 15 dernières
années tout s'est joué autour du
nucléaire non c'estàd qu'on est passé de
fermerfheim à décider de relancer la des
EPR des EPR2 en passant par suspension
de tous les programmes nucléaires le
même Emmanuel Macron avait basculé sur
les de 10 dimensions et là et là on est
dans une situation complètement
schizophrénique et dangereuse dans
laquelle on a relancé quelques la
construc construction de quelques
réacteurs EPR2. Donc en gros des
réacteurs nouvelle
génération qui sont plus puissant que
les les 57 centrales nucléaires
aujourd'hui existantes à l'exception de
Flamville. C'est-à-dire on était sur du
900 MW et on n'est pas on passe sur du
1300 1400 ce qui génère beaucoup de
difficultés accrues. C'est en fait c'est
exponentiel le coût et les difficultés
de gestion. Et donc on est sur une sorte
de il faut on surestime beaucoup ce qu'a
fait la France dans ce domaineel. Il
faut pas oublier qu'on avait des
licences américaines pour faire les
premiers réacteurs nucléaires. C'était
des Westing House. C'està-dire que en
gros nous avons un peu mâché le travail
quand même. Et donc à un moment donné un
peu par excès du bris, on a décidé qu'on
allait faire notre chose à nous
exclusivement et en le faisant mieux,
plus puissant, plus fort et ainsi de
suite et nous retrouve avec des
programmes qu'on arrive plus à gérer,
qui nous coûtent de plus en plus cher et
on va basculer de de 70 € le MAW à 42.
Non, de 70 pour le pour le le coût moyen
de de Saufreur à 100 en gros et on va
considérer que c'est acceptable de
passer à à 100. Et donc, on se retrouve
dans une situation où euh on le fait
entre autres parce que on est on est on
on ne sait pas en fait. Macron, il a
relancé un programme de construction
mais il a relancé qu'à moitié. C'estàd
que là avec le programme de construction
qu'on a lancé, on remplace pas du tout
le parc nucléaire existant et on arrive
à une fermeture progressive d'une grande
partie des euh une baisse tendantielle
de la part du nucléaire sans 10 m fin.
Or euh moi je considère que le nucléaire
ça peut être catastrophique à plein
dégâtard mais une fois que vous avez
fait le choix du nucléaire faut le faire
jusqu'au bout. Ça sert à quoi de le
faire sans enfin donc d'avoir tous les
problèmes de déchets, de sécurité, ainsi
de suite que ça peut générer euh tout le
faisant à moitié et de façon à ce que ça
nous coûte le double ou le triple de ce
que ça coûterait si vous faisiez de
façon sérieusement sérialisée et avec un
vrai investissement de masse. On se
retrouve
avec EDF qui doit faire des prêts pour
financer enfin ce qui ce qui est le
comble tout ça parce qu'on les avait on
avait voulu privatiser. C'était le plan
d'Emmanuel Macron à un moment donné et
euh à cause des retards de l'EPR2 et de
Flamville, qui est-ce qu'on fait nommé à
la tête du programme ? On fait nommer la
directrice du projet Incley, donc qui
était Incle Point qui était au
Royaume-Uni pour sauver les EP de alors
même que Incle Point est une catastrophe
absolue à tous les niveaux. Donc on est
dans dans une sorte de de d'éréliction
qui est moins visible, qui est peut-être
pas aussi excitante que l'effet d'hiver
dont on nous parle au quotidien. la
télévision, ainsi de suite, mais qu'on
va payer très cher à l'avenir.
L'appartenance au marché européen de
l'électricité, c'est quand même quelque
chose qui enfin je veux dire, il faut en
sortir point. Il y a pas il y a pas il y
a pas de débat. C'est pas possible qu'on
peut pas être indexé, avoir notre
production électricité indexée sur le
gaz alors qu'elle a une part minoritaire
dans le mix énergétique français et
faire payer à toutes nos entreprises et
à nos citoyens un surplus qui est
complètement légitime. Tous les
fournisseurs d'électricité privé, mais
je vous j'entendais vos vos
interlocuteurs hier qui disaient "Oui,
il faut écrêter je sais pas quoi, mais
non, enfin non seulement il faut tous
les faire fermer, mais il faut envoyer
en prison ceux qui leur ont permis
d'exister." C'est un monopole naturel
d'électricité. À quoi ça sert
d'avoir des boîtes aux lettres qui,
comme il le disait très bien, ne font
qu'émettre des factures, qui ne
produisent pas d'électricité et qui
capte une partie de la la plusvalue
plusvalue qui aurait pu être donné soit
pour réduire les impôts, soit au moins
pour financer les programmes électriques
de demain. Moi, j'étais à au Portugal
quand il y a eu Blackout, je peux vous
raconter, c'était c'était plutôt c'était
plutôt intéressant comme comme
expérience. Il y a eu un blackout
généralisé hein en Espagne. Enfin, je le
dis parce que les médias en ont si peu
parlé comme si c'était vraiment un petit
événement. Oui, d'accord. Mais facile de
le rater quoi. C'est-à-dire que le
lendemain la douceur des Espagnols et la
douceur des Portugais qui étaient
résignés à bord des bières chaudes. Bah,
je vous raconte moi au Portugal, j'ai
j'étais à la campagne, mon père est
portugais donc il habitait à la
campagne, j'étais avec avec lui et enfin
j'étais pas avec lui. Lui est à Lisbonne
au travail. Moi, j'étais j'étais resté à
la maison et il m'appelle parce que le
réseau fonctionnait encore en me disant
écoute l'électricité coupée ici à
Lisbon, je sais pas ce qui se passe et
nous on a un peu de de photovoltaïque et
ça tenait encore à ce moment-là. Euh
mais fais gaffe, voilà, je sais pas si
je vais pouvoir te rappeler. Bon euh
mais apparemment ça vient d'Espagne,
toute l'Espagne est coupée, ainsi de
suite. Je me connecte sur El Païs, qui
est le plus grand média espagnol, il y a
rien. Pourquoi ? Parce que ils ne
pouvaient même pas actualiser leur site
internet. Je donc ça commence comme ça.
Il faut quand même avoir conscience que
le point de départ c'est tout d'un coup
vous ne savez plus. On n'est plus du
tout habitué à ça. Ça vous avez plus
accès à l'information à la radio. Euh
les d'abord ça a été coupé un temps puis
après ils arrivaient pas à joindre leur
correspondant. Euh une fois sur deux ilà
on est avec telle personne bonne ah en
fait on n'y est pas. OK premier point.
OK appel. Une demi-heure plus tard, elle
me dit "On me dit que le Royaume-Uni, la
Finlande sont aussi touchés
euh là très très raisonnablement, il y a
pas d'interconnexion électrique." Um dit
bah une amie qui apparemment était au
Royaume-Uni. Oui, mais sur sur le
moment, il me dit pas la rumeur, il me
dit une amie m'a dit que n na non non,
ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est ma ma
réaction immédiate. Je me dis il y a pas
d'interconnexion électrique entre
l'Espagne, le Portugal et la Finlanda et
le Royaume-Uni. Donc si vraiment euh il
y a ça, c'est que c'est une attaque. Euh
et s'il attaque, il va y avoir
représaille parce que là il y a des gens
qui vont mourir et s'il y a représaila,
on est vraiment vraiment mal. Le temps
de me rendre compte que non, s'ils ont
pas réussi à faire sauter le réseau
électrique ukrainien, a priori euh en
toutes ces années, ils sont pas capables
de faire sauter l'Espagnol et le
portugais. A
priori c'est c'est pas intégré.
Entre-temps, je suis déjà en voiture,
espagnol et les pauvres portugais. Non
mais parce que c'est pas que enfin
justement là c'est ça qui génère le
doute c'est que on me dit non il y a ça
OK donc le temps de réfléchir je suis
déjà en train de prendre la voiture pour
me dire bon je vais quand même faire
quelques courses au supermarché parce
que avant que ça avant que ça parte en
ville parce qu'on est à la campagne
encore une fois un peu difficile d'accès
ainsi de suite arrive tout le
supermarché fermé 1 2 3 et cetera je
finis par en trouver un avec je rentre
que de 3h 3h de queue euh impossible de
de récupérer quoi que ce soit
d'important tout a étaitisé, il restait
un pack et demi d'eau mais vraiment
c'est vous savez c'est les grands
supermarchés/ash hypermarchés vous avez
de l'eau sur enfin vous avez de quoi
nourrir un régiment quoi. Normalement là
c'est
vidé que dans le superché entière
derrière moi de bacaliao il même plus de
bacaliao il y a plus de conserve tout de
suite mais en en un claquement de doigt
il il ferme les portes 10 minutes après
que je sois rentré les gens commencent à
s'accumuler à
l'extérieur du du superché qui ne
fonctionne que parce qu'il est encore un
générateur. Vous voyez, c'est le seul
qui fonctionne de l'ensemble de Et
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a plus d'eau ?
Parce que les pompes à eau fonctionnent
à
l'électricité. Parce qu'il y a plus
d'eau courante dans la ville. Et là, je
peux vous dire que les gens, c'est pas
le Covid, c'est la possibilité de filer
de l'eau à votre gamin, à votre bébé.
C'est la possibilité si vous avez du
lait en poudre quand vous avez un bébé
de pouvoir tout simplement le mettre
Vous avez plus de micro-onde en plus
parf ça ça très vite très vite ça
commence à devenir sérieux mais beaucoup
plus vite qu'on peut le penser.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe pendant que je
suis en train de faire avec e au
supermarché depuis 1 heure ? Tout d'un
coup le réseau tombe et là vous êtes
dans un film le réseau téléphonique, il
y a plus de il y a il y a plus de
connexion. Et là, vous retrouvez tous et
vous regardez tous en trouvant en disant
"We ce qu'on savait pas et heureusement
qu'on savait pas c'est que pour des
questions techniques là sur laquelle je
vais parvenir, en gros ils avaient
jusqu'à 23h30 pour rétablir le courant
sinon ça allait prendre plusieurs
jours."
Ils ont réussi à le rétablir avant
minuit, mais s'ils avaient pas réussi,
je peux vous dire ça serait très vite
très vite mal passé parce que euh autre
exemple, les
paiements, des terminaux de paiement,
c'est la carte. tirer du cash, le réseau
venait tomber, on pouvait pas tirer
cash. Donc soit vous aviez du cash, soit
vous pouviez même plus vous acheter
d'eau à l'épicerie du coin pour vider
les stocks et ainsi de suite. Les quand
j'écris mon mon mon livre un peu
insurrectionnel avec ce titre un peu
provocateur qu'on a vu la dernière fois,
comment fabriquer une guillotine,
j'avais identifié j'avais essayé
d'identifier tous les points de
vulnérabilité du pouvoir. Est-ce qui
n'allait pas ? ce qui était euh euh ce
qui faisait qu'en cas d'insurrection
type gilet jaune, on pourrait
éventuellement réussir à faire quelque
chose qu'on avait pas réussi en 2019.
J'ai découvert qu'ils ont basculé toutes
les communications d'état, y compris
police, pompiers et cetera sur la 4G. La
4G, c'est des bornes qui dépendent de
l'électricité et donc vous avez 2 3
heures de marge. C'est pour ça qu'on a
eu du réseau alors qu'il y avait plus du
tout d'électricité. pendant 2 3 heures,
les pompes à essence ne fonctionnaient
plus parce que c'est plus le mécanisme
euh maintenant c'est
électrique. Donc Emmanuel Macron a bien
fait de faire comme les les Suédois,
d'envoyer un petit bouquin pour que les
Français soient plus robustes avec un
petit peu de stock de flotte de 48 he on
se rend pas compte de notre niveau de
vulnérabilité, on se rend pas les feux
qui ne fonctionnaient pas. Donc il y a
il y a eu pas mal d'accident il faut lui
donner ça quand même. Ouais, il a de
nous préparer au pire qu'il qu'il
prépare en de créer cette boucle là.
Bien sûr, c'est un peu comme avec le
crème. Euh on a terminé avec le
Portugal, ça c'est ça c'est bien
terminé. Et donc et donc oui, donc je
finis par par mettre en fait la radio
sur mon sur sur ma voiture. Tu voyez,
c'est la seule c'était la seule
possibilité. Mais c'est là aussi hein
vraiment il y avait plus d'autres façons
de d'avoir accès à l'extérieur. La
vieille qu'on a vu. Ouais. Et une belle
une belle la première diesel Mercedes
appel à payé combien ? Euh 4000 € euh à
Braga que j'avais fait descendre de
Braga à Lisbonne au nord au nord de P de
Valsim. Euh, on avait trouvé ça dans un
un peu une carcasse mais mais avec une
peinture très belle. Donc ça passe. Et
donc on se retrouve dans une situation
où où
euh vous pouvez plus parler avec votre
père qui a un certain âge qui est en
ville, don sait pas s'il va pouvoir
rentrer ainsi de suite. Enfin,
heureusement, on avait de l'essence, on
avait fait enfin on était pas mais les
Portugais sont beaucoup plus robustes
que les Français en terme de résilience.
La grand-mère, elle a le potager la
campagne. Ils ont le puit avec la pompe,
ils sont tous bricoleurs. Qui est
bricoleur une surbanisation au Portugal
avec notamment des des hypermarchés à à
l'américaine. Des énormes centres
commerciaux qui ont concentré un peu
toute l'activité
économique de détail. Et vous avez une
urbanisation galopante d'expansion de
Lisbonne par exemple qui est qui est
massive. Et euh et donc quand je vous
disais que ça s'est joué à pas
grand-chose, c'est parce que notamment
les générateurs qui permettaient de
faire tourner enfin on était à ça de la
bascule. Il y a eu il y a eu quelques
morts. Il y a eu cinq morts en Espagne,
quatre morts au Portugal, principalement
euh des gens qui à domicile avaient
besoin de enfin avait des respirateurs,
des des questions d'insuline et ainsi de
suite qui qui ont pas pu suivre leur
traitement jusqu'au bout. Mais le bilan
aurait vraiment été tout autre en 2 3
jours parce que euh au-delà du fait que
le système électrique lui-même était
beaucoup plus difficile à redémarrer si
si ça dépassait ce seuil, euh toutes les
conséquences euh que ça aurait engendré
social en terme de désorganisation
aurait été euh extraordinaire. Donc ça
les gens ont pensé à à une attaque
informationnelle ou une attaque bien sûr
russe. Bien sûr, bien sûr. Ça a été la
la le premier
réflexe de de beaucoup et on est dans
une situation où parce qu'il y a un
conflit politique en Espagne sur la
question de l'utilisation des
renouvelables. On a décidé d'un peu
d'enterrer le sujet en renvoyant à 6
mois un rapport pour décider ce qui
s'est vraiment passé ou pas. Ce que je
veux dire par là, c'est
que on n'est pas du tout prêt. On n pas
du tout prêt. Or, on est vulnérable à
l'égard d'événements comme ceci et on et
on est avec des dirigeants qui sont en
train d'accroître notre dépendance. Il
faut faire quoi pour être prêt selon
vous ? Mais je pense qu'en fait on a on
est dans un pays où de toute façon le
rapport à la contrainte c'est beaucoup
relâché. Euh nous ce qu'on propose par
exemple notre projet c'est qu'il y a un
référendum sur l'établissement le
rétablissement d'une forme de service
militaire à la Suisse voyez avec un
système de réserviste et ainsi de suite
qui fasse qu'on ait tous justement des
formations pour se protéger. N'autre
idée c'est de façon plus générale de
basculer d'une armée de métier à une
armée à nouveau de conscription c'est
une armée populaire. Pourquoi ? parce
que ça réduit les véléités
expéditionnaires coloniales qui se
disent que on va s' on va aller en
Afrique sauver les uns les autres et
ainsi de suite. Et ça génère une
protection, une résilience beaucoup plus
importante au sein même de la société,
au-delà même des effets qu'on connaît
déjà de brassage réel ou supposé que ça
peut produire. Donc ça permet aussi de
créer un lien avec la nation et le
territoire auquel on appartient. C'est
quelque chose qui est qui est beaucoup
publié et qui génère beaucoup de du
désemparement qui nous frappe et aussi
de la distanciation entre les population
d'arrivée plus récente de celles qui
sont inscrites depuis plus longtemps où
il y a des formes de tension qui
commencent à naître parce qu'on
considère qu'ils font pas assez
d'efforts pour s'intégrer ainsi de
suite. Bon bref tous les discours euh
qu'on connaît et pour certains des
réalités. Donc ça ça permet de se dire à
un moment donné on aura tous donné. Vous
avez discuté avec des instructeurs
militaires récemment euh directement
non. Pourquoi ? que paraît-il que les
instructeurs militaires ils peuvent plus
rien dire sinon ils font ennuyés.
Mais ça c'est une question plus générale
encore une fois sur le rapport
d'autorité. Non,
c'est je pense qu'il y a il y a une
question du sens en fait. Qu'est-ce qui
fait qu'on fait société ? Qu'est-ce qui
fait c'est quoi le lien ? C'est quoi
l'appartenance à laquelle on a ? Encore
une fois, quand vous avez tous les
exemples que j'ai cité sur la première
heure ou la première demi-heure de notre
entretien de fraud en cascade,
d'impunité généralisée, de
compromission, complaisance et ainsi de
suite, est-ce que ça justifie qu'il y a
des gamins qui se casteent dans un
tribunal ? C'est-à-dire c'est-à-dire que
vous avez vu récemment, il des gamins de
bande rival ou qui qui venaient se
battre.
Ça pour moi c'est un c'est vraiment un
enfin ça c'est ça c'est c'est vraiment
l'écume pour moi. Ça c'est la une sorte
de de d'éventuels symptômes d'une déréli
beaucoup plus profonde qui a une
déstructuration profonde de la société.
C'est ça qu'il faut traiter. C'est la
c'est la c'est c'est vous me parlez
d'autorité, moi je parle d'essens mais
derrière c'est qu'est-ce qu'on a offrir
comme perspective commune ? Vous voyez ?
Et à un moment donné, quand la seule
perspective commune qu'on vous offre,
c'est en gros de vivre dans une société
complètement enquistée ou créer une
quelconque activité économique est
devenu quasi impossible où l'accès aux
fonctions de l'État est réservé aux
classes les plus bourgeoises de la
société et en à Franceori avec un niveau
de compromission et de soumission
extraordinairement important ou de plus
en plus qu'on nous raconte c'estàdire
l'entrée en guerre avec une puissance
nucléaire parce que pourquoi pas enfin
vous voyez enfin on est à ce niveau de
de raisonnement en guerre il a dit qu'on
enverrait des troupes pour pacifier la
situation Vous savez
moi est-ce que vous vous souvenez des
Pentagon Lak ? Bien entendu.
Euh on est les seuls à les avoir publié.
Tous les tous les journalistes en ont
parlé. Le monde le New York Times
Personne n'a osé les publier. Pourquoi
? exemple pour qui dit que c'est
jeunessant. C'est tu fais ça, tu risques
de passer 8 ans dans une ambassade puis
4 ans dans une prison antiterroriste.
Euh vous rappelez les disques durs du
guardian percé à la perceuse ? Bien sûr
ça ça c'est très intéressant à ce moment
où Juan Nassange fait ses révélations
sur les câbles diplomatiques
États-uniens et les Warlogs, donc les
les journaux de guerre en Irak et en
Afghanistan. Euh, il le fait en
partenariat avec des médias
traditionnels, le Guardian, le New York
Times, le monde et ainsi de suite. Et le
Guardian, en panique à un moment donné
va détruire les données auxquelles ils
avaient accès alors que Jean Assassange
va décider de les publier dans leur
intégralité. Et c'est ça qui va faire
deux destins. Celui de la pourriture et
de la compromission, mais bien rémunéré
et protégé au sein de nos sociétés et
celui de l'héroïsme et du courage mais
qui a été payé un très haut prix. On
peut pas dire qu'il était pourris au
gardien.
Ils se sont comportés comme tel. Bah ils
sont ils sont ils ont eu peur. Ils ont
ils ont abandonné un homme à son destin.
Et nous on a dû ramasser les miettes
pendant des années et essayer de le
sortir de la situation ou lui rajouter
une petite accusation de viol
entre-temps pour s'assurer que les
bonnes âmes ne s'en approchent plus et
qu'il soient bien isolés, bien
marginalisé. Et et voilà, le travail a
été fait. Et le travail a été fait et
pourquoi je vous parle des pentagonic
pour plusieurs raisons, notamment celle
de l'effet signal. Si vous en laissez un
tomber de cette façon, derrière, vous
assurez que le comportement de tous les
autres restera des c. C'est pour ça
aussi qu'on toute la lutte que j'ai mis
en œuvre ces dernières années pour
survivre à sorte de d'avan qui s'est
mise en place après la préparition de
crépuscule avait une une fonction
socialisante. C'était aussi de pas les
laisser envoyer un signal au reste de la
société française comme quoi il serait
impossible de toucher au Bernard Arnaud,
Xavier Niel, la Garder Drace des
compagnie et on était et c'était un
signal aussi envoyé aux journalistes.
C'est pour ça que j'ai toujours été très
véhément. Pour une parenthèse. Ouais.
Ruffin, il a gagné son procès. Euh
Bernard Arnaud était témoin, il était
pas accusé. Il a tout mis sur son numéro
2. Squarcini, ex-directeur de la DGSI,
recruté par celui-ci par Bernard
Arnaud, donc payé 2 millions et demi
d'euros pour pour espionner Fakir et
Ruffin. Parler avec la secrétaire
particulière de Bernardo, ça été établi
judiciairement parlant. Ah oui, mais ma
secrétaire particulière m'informait pas.
Il voyait ça avec son numéro 2. Pourquoi
est-ce que ça passe ? Pourquoi est-ce
que ça passe ? Parce qu'il pèse 250
milliards d'euros et parce qu'il a fait
Emmanuel Macron. C'est grâce à lui
qu'Emmanuel Macron est président. Des
sources de ça ? Euh oui oui, ça c'est le
dossier judiciaire. Ça c'est c'est le
fait qu'il ait fait Emmanuel Macron, il
y a des sources. Ça c'est crépuscule.
Moi, j'écris pas d' pour rien quand
même. Enfin, je veux dire, c'est
Grépuscule qui lui-même repose sur un
travail documentaire qu'on a qu'on a
qu'on a qu'on a décliner depuis de façon
constante. Guardian,
euh Rena Guardian, revenons au Patagon
X. Donc moi je vois l'effet signal et je
vois la peur y compris dans des
institutions puissantes et intouchables
en réalité comme le monde ainsi de suite
et on dit non non nous on va leur
montrer avec notre petit site qu'on est
capable de
de faire face et de rendre accessibles
ces données. Par c'est quoi votre petit
site ? C'est le le site que vous avez
sur mon compte Twitter qui permet
justement de récupérer toutes ces
informations. Vous parmi les et en fait
c'était les plans de la contreoffensive
ukrainienne qui avait été révélé par un
américain sur Fchan, un soldat américain
qui avait eu accès. Une une défaillance
de sécurité classique. Évidemment, on a
cru que c'était les Russes, c'était pas
du tout les Russes. Je pense pas qu'il a
ses capacités aujourd'hui. Et donc on
les rend publique. Parmi les éléments
importants qui sont complètement passés
à l'ass, c'est que qui était la
puissance étrangère qui avait le plus de
personnel au sol en Ukraine après les
États-Unis ? la France dans mon souvenir
98 force spéciale on est sur le terrain
mais une chose c'est d'être sur le
terrain
une autre une chose c'est d'être ils
sont instructeur ils sont partis tout
seuls ils ont pas de petit drapeaux pour
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que j'ai
essayé de vous reprendre quand quand
vous avez dit on est en guerre avec la
Russie ainsi de suite. très dangereux en
fait de rentrer dans cette
dynam c'est quand même quelque chose de
très je dis on éétait pas en guerre
peut-être en guerre commerciale et
guerre économique mais la guerre c'est
un c'est c'est pas c'est c'est quelque
chose c'est quelque chose un service
militaire non moi j'ai fait JPD parce
qu'il y avait pas de service militair
déjà tiré au famas par contre j'ai j'ai
postulé pour être préparation militaire
non non non je voulais être pilote
d'hélicoptère donc je suis allé au je
suis allé à Vincen au centre de
recrutement c'était en en fin 2019 euh
et j'arrive devant la recruteuse ou je
voulais passer par quoi que ce soit je
vais pas faire la réserve qui est quand
même quand vous voulez vous distinguer
dans le petit paris aujourd'hui vous dis
j'ai de la réserve je sais pas quoi tu
parle enfin bon bref donc moi je voulais
vraiment je m'engager quoi pour pour 5
ou 10 ans une bonne coupe de cheveux
avec oui avec mes petites oreilles qui
aurait ressorti et on et je me retrouve
face à la donc j'avais été avocat deilix
tout ça enfin je me retrouve devant
l'agent la la recruteuse qui qui ne sait
pas qui je suis et qui me dit mais non
mais elle regarde mon CV qui me dit mais
vous avez le profil parfait pour faire
du renseignement. J'ai un poste pour
vous. Là, je la regarde, je dis euh
comment vous dire ? Je suis pas sûr que
ça passe ni que ce soit et si si
vraiment non mais non mais j'étais venu
pas la DRM, j'étais j'étais venu pour le
poste le truc de pilote d'hélicoptère,
c'est c la dernière année où je pouvais,
j'avais 29 ans je pense, je pense que
c'est jusqu'à 30 ans et elle insiste
insiste, elle insiste et et elle me dit
"De toute façon, on vous revient, vous
avez le poste parfait, on vous contacte
dans un mois, vous allez vous allez
voir, ça va être génial, je sais pas
quoi." Et un mois plus tard, qu'est-ce
qui arrive ? l'affaire
Grivveau. Je suis l'avocat de celui qui
a sorti les vidéos. Là, je peux vous
dire que je voilà le chemin m'a il m'a
été imposé de choisir. Mais pour vous
dire, ça crée une telle panique cette
affaire de façon générale que Normal
Sub, donc mon alem mater l'université où
je suis allé a a tout de suite mis en
place un programme pour envoyer ses
gamins filer des coups de mains dans les
hôpitaux. Et donc je postule, je suis
inscrit, je sais pas quoi, et à un
moment
unarc, j'ai j'ai utilisé un terme un peu
désagréable m'appelle pour pour me dire
"Mais vous êtes le roi de branco de
l'avocat ?" Mais non, c'est un livre. Ou
bon, qu'est-ce que ça ? Pourquoi ?
Enfin, qu'est-ce que Ah non, mais ça va
pas être possible monsieur, pour filer
un coup de main. Euh en l'occurrence
c'était à Cochin, j'étais déjà affecté,
j'allais euh compter des masques. Enfin,
vous voyez, un truc quand même pas très
euh pas très euh engageant en terme de
skiruté ou quoi que ce soit. Paf ! Mais
ils ont donné une petite justification
où ? Ah bah, la directrice adjointe de
la PHP qui n'avait que ça à faire
visiblement de cette période m'a écrit
un mail pour me dire que elle
soupçonnait que on donne pas un mail
privé. Euh, vous êtes avocat, vous êtes
pas avocat ? Mais j'ai pas j'ai pas
donné son identité. D'accord. la direc
qui m'écrit. Ah non non si si al ça je
vais vous faire une petite leçon de
droit. Quand on vous adresse une
correspondance vous vous avez le droit
d'en faire ce que vous voulez. C'est les
correspondances de tiers que vous avez
pas le droit d'utiliser. Mais toute
correspondance, ça c'est important que
les gens le sachent, toute
correspondance qui vous est adressée euh
enfin perd son caractère de de
confidentialité.
Donc ça c'est à savoir parce que parfois
on peut on peut se retrouver en
difficulté à à vous êtes trop qualifié
pour compter des masques. Non non non,
elle a assumé, elle a dit "Je doute que
vous soyez sincère dans votre démarche."
C'est incroyable. C'est incroyable.
C'était quelque chose de peur que vous
fassiez du renseignement. Ouais.
Non, c'est une sorte de parano plus
envie de faire payer l'affront porté au
pouvoir ça. Oui. Enfin, j'essaie de bon
les phrases la phrase est quand même
assez explicite. Enfin, c'est c'est
votre interprétation. Et il se trouve
que une semaine après, on a révélé qu'il
y avait des millions de masses qui
étaient stockées dans des dans des
banques et qui n'étaient pas mobilisé
par au moment même où vous savez, les
infirmières n'avaient pas de est-ce
qu'on savait pas si ça allait être un
virus extraordinairement dangereux ou
pas. Enfin, il y avait une sorte de bon
reviendra peut-être pas revenir sur le
Covid parce qu'il y aurait beaucoup à
dire mais mais c'était une petite
anecdote par rapport à la à à la
quardise et et la lâcheté de ces
êtres-là. Ils avaient peut-être trop de
personnel.
Oui, c'est ça. C'était c'était c'était
probablement ça. Et et ça montre à quel
point en fait l'intérêt général et
compte de façon prioritaire ou alors à
quel point ils n'avaient rien à cacher.
Enfin, qu'importe, ça c'est leur
problème. Mais il y a un moment donné où
quand même quand vous retrouvez face à
des tentatives de stigmatisation et
d'isolement, enfin oui, en fait c'est
des tentatives de destruction de façon
générale et ça touche à tous les
domaines. Enfin là, je vous donne un
petit exemple, mais je trouvais moi
j'avais un enfin on peut on peut on peut
jouer à l'anecdote, mais euh euh je
m'étais retrouvé euh Ça vous intéresse
euh en terme de sur comment le Si je me
lève pas et que je te mets pas une
grande, c'est que ça va. Non non, c'est
euh j'ai une amie qui est euh qui est
très lié au milieu de de la mode et donc
pendant les Jeux Olympiques où j'ai pas
pendant les Jeux Olympiques, j'ai pas eu
le droit de rentrer chez moi parce que
j'étais dans le périmètre d'interdiction
et j'ai et le tribunal administratif a
considéré que mais de la même façon que
j'ai pas pu visiter la centrale
nucléaire de Triquestin. Mais ça c'est
normal parce que avoir été non non non
alors que on est on avait enfin des gens
de la centrale qui voulaient nous
montrer des non qui qui étaient vraiment
une enquête de proximité ils ont regardé
votre dossier ficher triple z et vous
pouvez pas rentrer dans une central
c'est intéressant non et j'ai pas pu
rentrer chez moi pendant 4 jours. C'est
quand même incroyable pendant les Vous
avez insisté un peu ou pas ? Ah oui je
suis allé au tribunal administratif. Ah
oui oui oui. Non je suis allé jusqu'au
bout du truc. Ah non c'est la France en
2025. Mais je peux vous en faire euh
vous voulez que je vous raconte à chaque
fois la sortie du territoire euh tout ça
non ? Ah oui non mais c'est de le de
d'habiter chez moi, enfin de rentrer
dormir chez moi, je veux dire c'est
quand même on en était là. Donc ça c'est
les faits de l'état. Quand vous passez
les frontières, il vous regardent avec
un grand sourire. Ah non, on a le droit
au au passage à la PAF dès que c'est
hors Union européenne bien sûr. C'est
quoi un passage à la PAF
? Veillez me suivre. Voilà, veuillez me
suivre. C'est c'est jamais un problème
des agents. Enfin, en tout cas, à ce
niveau-là,
c'est voilà, ils sont obligés de faire
leur travail. Tout ça, c'est nouveau. Il
vous contrôle pourquoi ? Il vous demande
vous étiez où ? Ah non, non, non, il
pose pas de question. C'est comme Mais
ça ça m'était déjà arrivé avec Wikileak
aux États-Unis. J'étais une petite
fouille, j'étais à Yel. Non, non,
c'était incroyable. Et je passais
systématiquement ce qu'ils appellent les
secondary screening, donc les les trucs
derrière les 81 là. Euh et et on posait
aucune question.
C'est juste pour signaler, vous voyez ?
Et 45 minutes, une heure comme ça,
bloqué là et après c'est bon, vous
pouvez y aller. Et vous avez pas essayé
du genre "J'ai envie de faire caca"
quoi ? De m'enfuir ? Non, je pense pas.
Non, c'est pas c'est pas très opportun
ni très rationnel comme comme façon
d'agir. Non, vous êtes obligé de
composer avec d'ailleurs ça m'est
réarrivé là au retour d'Haïti. J'étais à
Haïti cet été pour parce que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé ces derniers mois.
Déjà, j'ai dû partir 6 mois de France,
hein, quand même parce que il voulait
m'arrêter placement garde à vue, je sais
pas quoi, plusieurs reprises, tentative
hein, enfin ça ça a jamais abouti et euh
et menace assez sérieuse. Donc j'ai
passé euh euh quelques et donc en fait
je suis allé au Mexique euh et dans un
certain nombre d'autres territoires pour
essayer de profiter de ce temps pour
essayer de réfléchir à la question du
narcotrafic. qui c'est qui fin moi-même.
Et je peux vous dire que les conditions,
l'exil c'est c'est quelque chose de pas
drôle hein. Enfin et là c'était court
donc je je vais pas me plaindre mais euh
ça a
été particulièrement désagréable à vivre
y compris sur la question de savoir
quand est-ce que je vais pouvoir
revenir, comment, à quelles conditions
et et par contre ça m'a permis donc au
Mexique d'abord puis à Haïti euh d'aller
chercher sur le fonctionnement des
réseaux de narcotrafiquants et la
réaction de l'État à leur regard parce
que cette Kangraine dont on parle que
depuis quelques mois en France, c'est le
début c'est c'est le début D'autant plus
que tous les réseaux de corruption dont
je vous parle sur CPF et compagnie sont
complètement embranchés au narcotrafic.
Ça s'alimente mutuellement. C'estd que
en fait c'est des réseaux de de
corruption et de blanchiment. Ben bien
sûr c'est quand vous avez les
influenceurs à Dubaï qui se sont
arrêtés, il y en a eu quelques-uns pour
la forme sur le CPF, vous vous rendez
compte que sur un dossier sur deux,
c'est des gens qui en fait soit
blanchissaient de l'argent pour le
narco, soit enfin voyez qui qui avaient
des la les mêmes fausses entreprises qui
vous permettent de récolter du CPF en
faisant des fausses formations et
compagnie permettent aussi de blanchir
de l'argent.
pour vous donner un exemple et donc vous
avez des systèmes comme ça d'imbation de
la corruption qui les rendent
extraordinairement puissants et qui dans
certains pays déjà font qu'ils sont plus
puissants que les États eux-mêmes et que
donc la capacité à faire à le temps
qu'on a mis pour arrêter Mohamed Amra,
c'est effrayant. On nous promettait
qu'il serait arrêté dans dans le mois ou
dans c'est c'est un miracle. C'est parce
que pardonnez-moi, c'est pas quelqu'un
de très intelligent qui pensait qu'il
fallait qu'il suffisait de se tteindre
en orange les cheveux. C'est sur le job.
Oui. À travers un signalement quand même
qu'il est venu. C'estàd qu'il y a quand
même un il faut
pas faut pas être dans un discours
dénigrant parce
que il y a quand même encore des
compétences dans ce pays même si on
essaie de les détruire à la police
judiciaire avec la nationalisation de la
police judiciaire. pourrait rentrer dans
le détail parce que ce qui est
intéressant avec ce avec ce programme,
c'est qu'on a vraiment pris le temps de
rentrer euh euh de façon technique.
C'est qu' il y a une déclaration
d'intention qui est très politique, mais
derrière on a compris que la politique
c'est une affaire de technique,
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut vraiment rentrer
dans les réformes qui ont vraiment
détruit l'intérieur. Le CPF, le CE, moi
ça me rêve pas d'en parler hein. Enfin,
c'est pas des choses la C2 pardon.
Ouais. Alle vous le maîtrisez
correctement votre programme. Ouais.
Ouais. Allez-y. Bah c'est moi qui l'ai
fait. Donc avec tous ceux qui nous ont
envoyé des mais on a sélectionné il y a
eu de l'IA qui a reformulé
rien. Là là vraiment il faut il faut se
protéger. Bon bref, allez-y dites-moi.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait en terme de guerre
économique ? Mais prenez-nous des des
propositions au hasard hein. Je pense
que enfin qu'est-ce qu'on fait en terme
de guerre économique ?
Ben, on réalou les moyens que la DGSI
aujourd'hui met en place pour aller
surveiller le gust qui fait un
commentaire sur un groupe privé sur
Facebook avec une carature de Darmanin
vers le compte espionnage. Alors ça pas
être la même personne parce qu'il faut
des formations différentes que c'est les
RT pas la DGI. L'idée d'ensemble, c'est
la surveillance de la population est
peut-être importante pour satisfaire
certains intérêts particuliers, mais ce
qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui, c'est
l'infection en France par des réseaux
pour le coup de services de
renseignement qui eux-mêmes sont au
service de grande puissance économique.
Pas que les Russes hein. Mais non, les
Russes les Russes n'ont pas le début des
moyens que commencent à avoir les
Chinois et n'ont pas le début des moyens
qu'on les États-Unis. Sauf que on est
aligné avec les États-Unis et avec les
les Anglais. Oui, enfin c'est c'est un
peu intermédiaire les anglais en France
en tout cas. Mais la CIA ce que je à
chaque fois que je viens ici, je vous le
dis 200 200 agents de la CIA pour quatre
agents de la DGI au contrepionnage
chargé de les surveiller. Le
déséquilibre est pas tant. On est sur
une on est sur une terre colonisée, vous
voyez. Enfin, il faut vraiment avoir
conscience de nos élites sont des élites
Comprador. Ça veut dire quoi ? C'est un
terme assez assez classique en théorie
marxiste en l'occurrence, mais qui
consiste à qualifier ces élites qui
servent à faire la transition entre le
pouvoir étranger et le pouvoir local. Et
pour attrahir vers l'internationale,
vous avez besoin de porte-fling, vous
avez besoin de gens qui tiennent la
porte, qui vous l'ouvrent. Et ces
gens-là aujourd'hui, c'est Emmanuel
Macron. L'affaire Hubert, l'affaire,
l'affaire technique, enfin vous pouvez
les multiplier à l'infini. À chaque
fois, c'est c'est des perceptions de
ressources. qui partent à l'étranger et
on leur ouvre la porte. Emmanuel Macron,
pourquoi vous dites que c'est un
porteflingue ? Parce qu'il est quoi
d'autre ? Vous avez des sources de son
implication ? S'il a été en contact ou
sa combien de temps l'enquête
préliminaire sur l'affaire Uber est
ouverte
? 9
ans. C'est long non ? pour une enquête
préliminaire et enquête préminaire,
c'est bien parce que ça permet de
d'éviter que les parties n'aient accé au
dossier. Je peux vous les multiplier à
l'infini les exemples comme ça, mais il
m'intéresse pas Emmanuel Macron, il est
il est
fini. Il a il a brûlé sa vie. il en est
en fin de carrière à à faire poursuivre
et faire arrêter des citoyens parce
qu'ils disent que sa femme est un homme.
Je l'envis pas. Vous voyez, c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait un choix pour les
Ukrainiens. Il essaie que l'Europe
survit. Il a failli nous amener à la
guerre. Il a failli nous amener la
guerre à trois reprises. Donc dont avec
une puissance nucléaire et pas n'importe
laquelle. Euh il a généré des réseaux de
commission et de corruption au sein de
ce pays qui l'ont déstructuré de façon
extraordinairement violente. J'ai pas
envie de rire à l'égard d'Emmanuel
Macron, mais je tous les exemples que je
peux vous donner, je peux vous je
pourrais vous faire le détail fait de
bien dans
dans quelque chose qui je vous donner un
exemple. Pourquoi est-ce qu'on pourquoi
est-ce qu'on crée le CPF ? Bon allez le
compte non mais le compte le compte de
de formation le compte professionnel de
formation pourquoi est-ce qu'on le crée
? C'est pas par c'est pas par que les
salariés s'endurcissent dans le marché
du travail. OK, je vais vous donner la
véritable raison. C'est parce qu'il y a
trois
stagiaires à l'équipe d'en marche pas à
campagne qui font tourner pas l'IA mais
ce qu'il connaissait à l'époque,
c'est-à-dire les publications
internationales sur les modèles sociaux
et compagnie et qui sans rien connaître
se disent "Ah tiens, il y a un truc qui
fonctionne bien au Danemark, on va faire
exactement la même chose en France.
C'est pas mal non ? Ouais. Vous êtes des
milliards dépensés en pure perte avec
des escroqueries à Touva et aucun
contrôle. Au Danemark ? Non, en France
au Danemark ça marche très bien.
Pourquoi ? parce que c'est intégré dans
un système qui justement dans la société
en question et eux non, ils font
copiercoller et pourquoi ? Parce qu'ils
font leur programme pas comme nous. Ils
font pas leur programme comme on l'a
fait avec les 15000 personnes qui sont
sur Discord déplacement après
déplacement. On a en cherché des
spécialistes dans du terrain. Vous voyez
des gens qui sont confrontés à la
réalité. Un truc tout bête le transfert
de la police judiciaire au ministre de
au ministère de la justice le sortir du
ministère de l'intérieur parce que c'est
les policiers qui enquêtent pour les
juges d'instruction pour les procureurs.
C'est logique qu'il y ait pas cette
double tutelle. C'est logique, il
travaille de façon c'est petites choses
que vous pouvez décider que si euh vous
avez une connaissance intime du
fonctionnement de l'État et euh des
défaillances auxquelles vous êtes
confrontés. Quand vous avez passé votre
vie à faire des dîner en ville et à
aller de d'émission télévision en
émission télévision, vous pouvez pas
avoir cette cette expertise. Donc vous
déléguez et vous de délégation en
délégation vous retrouvez avec un
stagiaire de 23 ans qui vous dit "On
crée le CPF". OK. Quelques milliards
d'euros qui vont disparaître au pire
qu'importe. Pareil pour les politiques
d'alternance, pareil. Vous vous êtes en
vous avez conscience là de du fait qu'on
a donc des sources pour les stagiaires.
Là ouais. Des centaines de milliards
d'euros dépensés en pure
perte pendant la la crise COVID. Euh
est-ce qu'il y a eu un fléchage ? Est-ce
qu'on s'est dit on va faire un programme
nucléaire, on va construire de nouvelles
écoles, de nouvelles universités, on va
relancer les filières de formation
d'ingénierie, on va faire de
l'intelligence artificielle ? Non, on a
distribué l'argent. Débrouillez-vous. On
a maintenu l'existant. Évidemment que ça
se désagrège. Évidemment que derrière on
se retrouve non seulement avec plus de
dettes mais avec aucune génération de
ressources en plus. Donc de l'imposition
en plus pour Mais je vous je vous dis
Macron mais j'ai lu les programmes de
tous les autres partis
politiques. Vous savez quels sont les
plus intéressants ? C'est quand vous
allez voir des cheminades, des petits
candidats qui eux bossent, vous voyez,
qui eux savent qu'ils sont obligés de
travailler. Pas quand vous allez voir la
France insoumise, le Rassembl national
et tout ça où ils sont en fait c'est des
bons vivants, c'est des gens qui
viennent en fait pour au pouvoir pour le
plaisir. Communist, ils ont fait un une
super étude sur l'énergie. Non, lesquels
? Les communistes. Moi je sais pas, moi
j'ai vu la note de l'Institut Labie sur
l'énergie qui vient de sortir. Il y a
c'est aberrant. Ils veulent réduire de
70 % la consommation de viande en en en
10 ans dans mon souvenir. Moi, je veux
bien hein, enfin on peut aussi pourquoi
pas 95 % et puis il y a il y a un moment
donné où on est sur de l'idéologie à des
niveaux qui sont qui sont hors hors de
toute proportion. On fait quoi avec les
agriculteurs ? On fait quoi ? Ça, il y a
aucun aucune question. Et en fait,
chaque chaque état par contre arrive
avec l'idée de son pardon, chaque
pouvoir arrive avec euh la bonne idée de
son de son stagiaire de service qui lui
dit "I faut créer c, faut créer ça." Et
c'est pour ça qu'on se retrouve avec des
empilements. Nous, il y a j'aurais dû
commencer par là, peut-être que ça
aurait pu intéresser vos vos auditeurs.
Euh il y a plus de 450 un peu aux taxes
cotisation en France, on en supprime
300. Voyez, on commence on commence par
le début, on commence par commence. Il y
a un nombre important de ces taxes
cotisation impôts qui sont un rendement
négatif, même pas qu' rapportent un peu
argent, c'est qui c'est ça coûte plus de
les prélever que on commence par ça, on
commence par la fusion de tous les
grands organismes, toutes les
administrations. On redonne du pouvoir à
l'état central, on supprime les régions,
voyez, on arrête avec c cette gabégie,
ces institutions intermédiaires qui ne
servent strictement à rien, qui n'un
recommence à donner une direction à la
France à travers à la fois un état
centralisé, puissant, mais en parallèle
avec un pouvoir de contrôle des
citoyens, les référendums, les mand
impératifsires. On rééquilibre la
machine et on se débarrasse de tous ces
corps intermédiaires qui qui sont en
train de piller le pouvoir en
place. Voilà. C'est mon côté autiste,
j'aime bien les pantalons en
place. Revenons à la la guerre
économique. On fait quoi là en terme de
production énergétique, de dépendance à
l'uranium, de dépendance au pétrole, de
dépendance aux matières premières, de
dépendance en terme de technologie,
d'ingérence en terme de technologie, des
gars
femmes. On arrive le premier jour de de
président Branco, il fait quoi ? Il fait
un conseil de guerre, un secret défense,
il fait une grande alors il y a déjà
déjà on on met fin au secret défense sur
le Covid tout ça enfin on remet en accès
libre toutes ces données que l'État a
voulu cacher pour des raisons quand même
qui m'échappent enfin que les politiques
sanitaires a fait l'objet de secret
défense c'est quand même une question
qui me qui m'interroge et qui me rend
curieux vous êtes pas posé la question
premier point bah moi moi je serais
curieux et je vois pas il y a pas un
parlementaire qui a posé une question à
l'assemblée sur cette question sur ce
sujet c'est quand même assez intéressant
on paye 577 personnes
8000 balles par mois en brut plus tout
ce qu'ils ont à gagner en terme
d'assistant parlementaire ainsi de
suite. Il y en a pas un qui a dit mais
oh pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi on est
seul pays au monde qui a rendu secret
défense les délibérations sur la
politique sanitaire ? Qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? par rapport au à P4 Busin, Lévi,
c'est c'est quoi où est où est la
pourquoi est-ce que quand on a un
journaliste comme Marc Hvell qui révèle
que dès octobre 2018, la DGSE était
informée qu'il y avait quelque chose qui
se passait à Onean au moment des jeux
militaires ? Non 19 non euh 2019 pardon.
Oui. Enfin 4 mois avant le le le
déclenchement officiel de du Covid.
Qu'est-ce qui fait
que cette information ne fait pas
l'objet de débat public ? C'est la DGSE.
Non mais une fois quelle fuite une fois
quelle fuite et comment et comment on
explique l'impréparation jusqu'au tout
dernier jours avant le confinement quand
Emmanuel Macron dit il faut sortir dans
le théâtre et ainsi de suite avant de
nous enfermer tous comme des bêtes
pendant pendant moi. Voyez tout ça c'est
des
conme ça montre l'état du débat public
l'incapacité aujourd'hui à c'est qu'on
on cherche même plus à faire émerger la
vérité. Il y a même plus une il y a plus
ces journalistes qui ont cette passion
de aller aller aller comprendre quoi,
aller mettre en
difficulté le le politicien, le
dirigeant et ainsi de suite. Tout ça il
faut il faut l'ouvrir. Ensuite sur la
question de la souverainisation du pays,
elle est multiple. On est sur des
productions énergétiques de 1500 TW par
an à peu près en France dont 50 % vient
de l'étranger. C'estàd que 50 % c'est du
fossile qu'on apporte du du gaz, du
pétrole et et un peu de charbon vraiment
de façon minime. Euh on est sur des
perspectives dressées par Emmanuel
Macron qui consiste à faire réduire la
part du nucléaire
jusqu'à sauf erreur de ma part 40 % du
de l'électricité euh dans le pays de 70
à 40 %.
Euh on veut remplacer ça remplacer ça
par du renouvelable qui n'est pas
fabriqué en France. Donc on passe une
solution euh qui mobilise des
compétences françaises qui
éventuellement peut s'exporter ainsi de
suite à une solution qui nous fait
dépendre de
puissances étrangères. On
a une incapacité à aujourd'hui s'assurer
que ça ne produise pas des difficultés
de type blackout. C'est-à-dire justement
à un moment donné euh avoir un réseau
suffisamment puissant pour supporter euh
l'absence de variabilité euh des énergie
renouvelable et ça leur capacité
justement à à gérer les stockage
batterie. Euh voilà. Et donc on est dans
une situation où le renouvelable va nous
amener à créer des énormes pleines de
batteries qui sont quand même
extraordinairement polluantes sans qu'il
y a une vraie réflexion collective sur
quel est le coût le bénéfice risque.
Encore une fois dès lors, je suis pas
pronucléaire mais on on a fait ce
choix-là. On va devoir gérer des des
chaînes nucléaires pour un certain
nombre d'années de quelques centaines
pour les plus dangereux à plusieurs
millions pour les moins dangereux. Donc
ça c'est fait. Donc euh est-ce que on ne
va pas jusqu'au bout de la logique euh
dès lors que de toute façon on est en
train de faire avec CGO et compagnie euh
l'ensemble des euh de mettre en place
l'ensemble des euh des dispositifs pour
traiter euh ces déchets ? Est-ce qu'on
se met en difficulté d'un point de vue
économique, industriel et ainsi de suite
euh par rapport aux puissances
étrangères ? Ça c'est un premier point.
Le deuxième point, c'est une réflexion
sur le modèle de société. Euh
visiblement, on est dans une situation
de course en avant générale, compris sur
la consommation, la production avec un
épuissement des ressources qui est réel,
ce qui a pas été beaucoup traité hier
par par vos interlocuteurs, y compris
sur les conséquences sur la
biodiversité, ainsi de suite parce qu'on
arrête énergéticien mais on parle
toujours de Mais oui, mais le problème
des énergéticiens, c'est qu'il parlent
ils parlent quand il parlent d'écologie,
ils ne vont parler que d'effet de serre
à la limite. C'est pour ça que sur notre
chaîne, il y a plein d'autres
spécialistes qui traitent un prisme de
lecture euh multifactoriel. Et
d'ailleurs, hésitez pas à nous financer
parce que c'est grâce à vous qu'on peut
faire toutes ces interviews et qu'on est
totalement dépendant et que on peut
aller moissonner toutes ses
connaissances et ses jus de cerveau pour
pouvoir ensuite connecter tous les
points et essayer d'avoir une big
picture, une grande image. Il y a en
France une un phénomène marginal de
désertification mais qui est nouveau.
C'estàd qu'il y a à peu près 1,5 % des
terres qui sont désertifiées en France.
rien en comparaison à d'autres pays,
mais c'est déjà quelque chose qui
n'existait pas il y a il y a 15
ans. On peut faire de la France à un
environnemental, vous voyez parce que la
condition enfin la situation
géographique fait qu'on sera pas les
plus impactés par rapport même si
aujourd'hui en terme de réchauffement,
on est déjà plus impacté que la moyenne.
Salinisation des terres
mais mais le problème c'est qu'on peut
pas être une île. C'estàd que toutes les
questions dont on parle sur la pression
migratoire et ainsi de suite évidemment
vont vont nous affecter, vont continuer
de nous affecter. On aura pas de réponse
si on se pense on sort de l'Europe ou on
sort pas de l'Europe on propose
immédiatement en fait on fait deux
choses immédiatement c'est tout coup
pour commencer on arrache les médias à
leur propriétaire oligarchique on les
sort on les redistribue aux citoyens on
interdit toute prise de contrôle ou de
participation de la part de puissance
économique dans les médias pourquoi
parce que l'information doit pas être
un quelque chose qui cherche à servir
des intérêts privés il y a déjà
suffisamment d'officines de
manipulateurs dans tous les sens dans
pays pour qu'en plus des journalistes
même soient des employés d'oligarque.
Vous voyez ? Enfin, à partir de là, vous
pouvez rien faire. Ils en souffrent un
peu, non ? Une partie en souffre et une
grande partie sont choisis et ont leur
poste parce qu'ils n'en souffrent pas et
parce qu'ils sont contents d'être là où
ils sont. Il faut pas être complaisant à
l'égard de celui conséquences que ça a
eu de faire la dissidence à ce
niveau-là, de pas accepter de continuer
le petit jeu qui faisait que j' des
portraits super élogieux dans tous les
médias et ainsi de suite. J'ai eu le
courage qu'ils n'ont pas eu. Donc je
considère qu'à partir de là, l'estime
que je leur dois est très limitée
relative. Ça c'est des enfants et je
n'ai pas pu fonder de famille à cause de
ça. Vous avez un crédit immobilier ?
J'ai pas de crédit immobilier mais je me
suis organisé je me suis je me suis
organisé. Mais non,
jeionn je fais partie des euh si en
terme de patrimoine, je fais partie des
10 % les plus pauvres de France. Vous
voyez ça, il faut quand même et c'est la
conséquence de choix. D'accord ? Et je
les assume complètement, mais il faut
pas venir comme dire des leçons et dire
que pour x y raison. Ça c'est très
important à prendre en compte. À un
moment donné, la vie est faite de choix,
il faut et il faut savoir les assumer.
Donc on libère les médias parce que
c'est la condition de d'un débat public
qui soit sincère.
Il y a plusieurs modalités de
financement possible. Il y a la solution
à l'allemande où vous affectez une
partie de vos
impôts. En Allemagne, ils font ça pour
les les religions à telle ou telle
église, à telle ou tel Non, on peut le
faire pour les médias par exemple. On
peut créer une licence globale qui fasse
que vous avez une taxe affectée de 5 €
par mois sur les abonnements internet et
que vous le redistribuez. Une partie
pour la culture, une partie pour les
médias et ça fait plus d'un milliard et
demi d'euros. Donc c'est très large
c'est largement suffisant. C'est bien
mieux que les subventions actuelles qui
sont distribuées sur des critères
opaques. C'est plus d'un milliard
d'euros euh en tous ces 4 milliards
d'euros dans mon souvenir entre la radio
et la télé, le pôle euh en en prenant en
compte l'audiovisuel extérieur et ainsi
de suite à vérifier. Je sais plus si
deux ou quatre mais on est sur cet ordre
de grandeur
avec avec des émissions. Vous savez
combien vers chaque année France
Télévision à Xaviniel ? Davel, hein,
Gendre de Bernard Arnaud, lui-même,
j'imagine 10e puissance de France 100
millions d'euros. Et mais et pourquoi en
en émission produite ? Vous voyez le la
glorieuse produit des contenus. Oui, la
Oui. Des contenus extraordinaires comme
le la glorieuse émission là à quelle
époque voyez le ce petit euh Vous voyez
pas, vous avez vraiment de la chance
avec Léa Salamé euh qui invite Nicolas
Bedos Louis Sarkozy dans une ambiance un
peu tamisée. 800000 auditeurs
spectateurs par vous en faites plus par
semaine. Et donc c'est ça les émissions
que produit Xavinial et qui qui est-ce
qu'ils invitent Xavien ? Magnifique non
? pareil sur cet à vous, c'est ce soir
qu'il produit aussi à travers Mediawe.
Donc euh tout ça, il faut mettre
vraiment fin rapidement rapidement
rapidement à tout ça. Euh ça ça permet
ensuite d'avoir un débat public qui est
libéré. Vous vous imposez la
transparence sur les algorithmes. Ça
c'est très important. Très important ce
qu'a fait euh Elon Mos sur Twitter sur
X. Il a dit voilà les critères qui font
que votre poste va être mise en avant ou
pas. Après il les a trafiqué pour mettre
en avant ses propres postes. Ça c'est
une autre affaire. Mais voyez cette
idéel ça euh bah vous avez bien vu
pendant toute la campagne Trump c'était
ce qui était il avait même créé parce
qu'il est assez provocateur vu. Est-ce
qu'il y a eu des sources des enquêtes ?
Non non mais il y a eu quelque chose de
de parce que l'algo il a été publié, il
il a été publié non il est pas à jour
justement. C'est ça la différence. Et ce
qui était génial avec Musk, ce qui est
un peu drôle quelque part mais enfin ça
pourrait être drôle si les conséquences
n'étaient pas sérieuses, c'est que quand
vous le mettiez euh soit en en voire
moins, vous voyez quand vous az cette
option sur X pour voir moins et bien il
il vous floudait 10 fois plus. Il avait
créé ce tric sur l'algorithme pour que
vous soyez il soit omniprésent pendant
quelques jours. Ah oui oui. Plusieurs
personnes l'ont remarqué. Donc mo
c'était une sorte de petite provocation.
Non non mais c'était c'était c'était
enfin quand vous retrouvez qu'avec des
postes d'on Musk après avoir dit je je
veux plus voir ce type de contenu euh
c'est assez tangible et ça a été
suffisamment répété pour que pour qu'on
pour que ce soit établi comme pour que
non mais ça peut être répété répété 25
fois si c'est pas vrai ça restera faux.
Non non répété comme expérience pas
comme enfin c'est avec les captures
d'écran et ainsi de suite. Non pas
répété comme comme un énoncé. J'ai quand
même j'ai beaucoup de défauts mais j'ai
quand même formation scientifique le
doctorat ça vous aide le rapport à la
source à enfin vous voyez enfin faut
vraiment aller la rigueur elle est elle
est très importante. C'est pour ça aussi
que j'ai survécu parce que sinon on vous
abat mais comme un comme un chien. Euh
donc libération des médias ce qui permet
un débat public enfin qui appartient aux
citoyens eux-mêmes. Donc référendum sur
l'appartenance à l'Union européenne, sur
l'appartenance à l'euro et sur
l'appartenance à l'OTAN. Les choix
stratégiques qu'on a volé au peuple
français en 2005. Comme vous le savez
avec le référendum, pour les plus
jeunes, ils savent pas mais euh le
peuple avait voté Sous Chirac contre le
traité que Sarkozy ferait adopté via son
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes Jean-Pierre Juliet qui est
celui qui a fait promouvoir Emmanuel
Macron derrière. Vous voyez en même
temps vient de là. Ça vous avez des
sources qui les fait promouvoir quoi que
ce soit. Trépuscule, pardon hein, je
suis un peu autoréférentiel mais mais
euh mais ça ça simplifie. Et euh et on
se retrouve donc dans cette situation où
enfin on sait si on reste à quelles
conditions et ça nous permet d'établir
tout de suite le rapport de force avec
les autres, vous voyez, et de décider
sur la politique monétaire. Et on
prépare la sortie euh de de l'euro
entre-temps, on prépare les contrôles de
capitaux, on on prépare avec la dette
euh la question d'éventuel aircut,
c'est-à-dire en fait de de
réduction de la dette qu'on considérera
légitime ou non. Et on fait redamarer
comment on se financera sur les marchés.
et on fait redémarrer l'appareil
étatique industriel euh de la magie non
en s'assurant que on est des super avis
budgétaire dès la première année vous
allez mettre la main sur les paragnes
des français non c'est que dès la
première année pour ne pas avoir à
dépendre des et ne pas avoir à subir les
secousses sur un marché financiers il
faut être en super avis de budgétaire il
faut il faut il faut pas être en déficit
parce que sinon vous êtes obligé d'aller
chercher l'argent et soit vous allez
dans les par des français soit vous
allez sur les marchés et les marchés
vont vous sacrifier donc premier point
et ça donc on C'est l'objet de notre
programme, c'est quelles sont les
dépenses ou absences de perception du
fait de tous ces dispositifs que je vous
décrit. J'ai pas parlé du CSE, c'est
tout c'est une autre aventure qui nous
permettent d'arriver à cela tout en
renforçant les services publics de base.
Ah, il y a des choses qui vont tomber
hein, mais en en ce qui concerne le
soin, en ce qui concerne la possibilité
d'avoir les meilleurs professeurs qui
soient payés correctement et qui soient
envoyés au très fond de la France parce
que cette logique qui fait que les
meilleurs profs sont au centre de Paris,
donc là où on en a le moins besoin,
c'est quand même une question qui se
pose. Voyez euh sur la question de la
sécurité justement et ainsi de suite.
Générer des services de base à nouveau
qui fonctionnent et après il faut
purger, il faut il faut aller faut pas
faire un dodge mais c'est un peu l'idée.
C'estàd qu'il va falloir s'attaquer à
des strates bureaucratiques enchaînent.
La suppression des la suppression des
mutuels c'est 5 milliards d'euros en un
claquement de doigt. Alors c'est vrai
que ça met 30000 40000 personnes qui
travaillaient pour le mutuel en
difficulté et c'est pour ça qu'aucun
politicien ne le fait. C'est parce
qu'ils osent pas. Nous on le fait.
Pareil sur le système de retraite, on
fait évoluer le système de retraite. On
crée un système où vous avez un taux,
vous avez par exemple trois catégories.
Une première catégorie qui est jusqu'à
un certain seuil assez faible, disons
1500 2000 € vous allez avoir un taux de
remplacement de 85 % disons 1500 €. Vous
voyez, c'est que par rapport à votre
revenu et ensuite par contre ça descend
en flèche, vous voyez parce qu'on
personne n'a besoin depuis 3 4000 € pour
vivre après 65 ans parce que ceux qui
ont droit à ces 3 4 5000 € de retraite
sont des gens qui en général ont
beaucoup épargné par ailleurs. Vous
voyez c'est cumulatif c'est des gens qui
ont beaucoup gagné pendant 40 ans.
Bah soit on utilise des pannes château
français qui a coûté une blinde toiture
qu'on le patrimoine des français. Il y a
un enjeu fondamental pour moi,
fondamental, on a cru, ça c'est une
autre erreur de la gauche, que l'État
pouvait remplacer la société. On a cru
euh gauche de la gauche
institutionnelle, cette gauche qui pense
que il est normal euh d'avoir construit
une famille où on envoie nos parents et
nos grands-parents à l'ÉPAD, voyez, qui
considèrent que l'État peut remplacer la
famille. C'est pas vrai. C'est pas vrai.
C'est ça n'a rien à voir de finir sa vie
avec ses enfants, ses petits-enfants et
ainsi de suite. Et c'est ça qu'il faut
reconstruire. Et pour ça, il faut
réfléchir sur la possibilité de se
loger, donc sur le prix des logements
lié à la politique monétaire. Il faut
réfléchir sur justement l'attribution
des ressources par rapport au retrait et
ainsi de suite. Il faut réfléchir aussi
de façon, je sais pas si spirituelle,
mais en tout cas sur le notre rapport à
l'autre. Vous croyez en Dieu ?
Non, mais je pense je considère que
enfin, est-ce que je crois en Dieu déjà
? Vous avez perdu le vote câ là ? Non
non non, je considère que les évangiles
enfin malheureusement le le vote
catholique aujourd'hui il est
qui est mon préféré. Les évangiles sont
sont un texte fondateur de notre société
et le fait qu'il soit pas enseigné à
l'école voyez le fait que la laïcité ça
dépend il y a des écoles où il les
enseignent. Oui mais l'école publique la
laïcité c'est pas l'oubli de là où on
vient c'est pas l'oubli de 2000 ans
d'histoire structuré et construit à
partir d'un texte.
On a on a construit ce pays sur les
quelques mots qui ont été repris dans
les quatre évangiles principaux, on va
dire. À quel moment on a pensé que du
jour au lendemain on allait faire
disparaître ça et faire tenir la société
sur sa même base ? C'est le reproche que
je fais extrême droite, c'est de pas
avoir pardon principale base sur sur sur
la les valeurs communes qu'on a généré à
partir de ce texte. Le reproche que je
fais à l'extrême droite, c'est vous
allez chercher des bouqu émissaires,
vous êtes dans la dénonciation et ainsi
de suite. Vous êtes incapable de
reconstruire ce fondement. C'est pas
vrai. L'extrême droite, ils connaissent
les évangiles, ils connaissent la
Marseille prier. Oui, bien sûr. Lesquels
? Je serais curieux de savoir. Ouais. Ou
ouais ouis. Je serais curieux d'avoir un
débat avec euh avec Bardella sur euh sur
les évangiles. Je suis je serais curieux
de lui demander euh ce qu'il pense de la
lettre aux Corinthiens euh et euh de la
nécessité de faire honte à ceux qui sont
puissants et de défendre ce ce enfin par
ceux qui sont faibles. Vous êtes plutôt
jésuite, vous êtes plutôt Non, mais moi
j'ai pas eu de formation. Euh enfin moi
je suis de cette génération là qui a
grandi. Mes parents étaient chez les
jésuites évidemment chez Salazar et
Franco. Vous imaginez bien
c'était J'ai j'ai pas du tout eu cette
C'est en fait c'est pour ça que j'en je
suis très libre par rapport à ça. C'est
en fait j'ai découvert sur le T et j'ai
découvert le manque qui était le mien de
ne pas avoir connu cette formation là.
Vous avez pas connu Saint-Paul et
Saint-Martin. Non
ça mais à partir de là en fait vous
philosophie. Oui. Non mais non
évidemment moi j'ai on s'en fiche de
moi. Enfin j'allais vous dire j'allais
vous raconter mon rapport à Augustin et
tout ça. D'accord. Non mais moi je c'est
par la philo ma formation donc c'est
Augustin c'est mais bon ça c'est
vraiment Thomas DQ tout ça Thomas Thomas
DQ on va bien sûr qu'on mais ça je l'ai
travaillé parce que c'est ils sont
considérés c'est ça qui est très
intéressant comme des philosophes voyez
et donc là ça devient légitime parce que
ils sont ils s'inscrivent dans une
tradition qui qui n'est pas celle du
religieux qui elle est interdite
d'entrer en dehors évidemment des des
études spécialisées sur la question. Euh
vous perdez ça, vous perdez un socle. En
fait, ça veut pas dire qu'il faut se
comporter tel que euh ces parole nous le
suggérait à l'époque. Euh la lettre au
Corinthiens, vous avez des
développements énormes sur le mariage et
compagnie. C'est pas c'est pas ça le
sujet. Ce qui compte, c'est c'est le
substrat spirituel qui est en dessous le
rapport à l'autre. La position qu'on
peut adopter. Moi, je crois
fondamentalement que la meilleure
justice, c'est celle qui est rendue par
le vieux sage sous son arbre. Vous
voyez, c'est que on est rentré dans une
fascination de la norme, de
l'abstraction dans nos sociétés
occidentales qui nous fait oublier que
ce qui compte, c'est de régler un
conflit de façon la plus équanime
possible. Euh peut-être que parfois la
personne va se tromper, peut-être que
Mais il faut il faut que la société
reprenne le contrôle sur elle-même, ne
dépendent pas de l'État de façon si
systématique. Alors, je vais faire tirer
après à une main innocente qui se trouve
à ma gauche n'importe quelle poche du
programme pour qu'on puisse l'aborder.
Ouais. Qu'on ne m'accuse pas d'avoir
choisi la proposition. Ouais. Et
revenons, revenons à au chamboulet. Si
vous arrivez au pouvoir, vous vous
rendez bien compte que avant ça va créer
quelques petites adhérences chez les
gens que vous pouvez critiquer ou mettre
dans la sauce ou j'en passe les
meilleurs. Envoyer en prison,
c'est toujours mieux que le des galen ou
la guillotine. Bah oui, non, il faut
toujours avoir un panel assez large,
hein. C'est comme c'est l'ambiqueté
stratégique, disait Emmanuel Macron.
C'est quand même barbare et archaïque.
Non, ce qui est barbare et archaïque,
c'est de voir s'arracher une dent avec
une pince.
Et c'est la réalité que connaissent
beaucoup de personnes aujourd'hui et qui
est le fruit des comportements d'arrive
au pouvoir.
Vous les graciez, vous les graciez pas,
vous les mettez en prison. À moi de les
gracier ou pas les graciers. C'est c'est
à moi euh et à ceux qui m'accompagneront
de créer des structures de justice et
punitives qui aillent chercher leur
responsabilité au lieu de les protéger.
Est-ce que vous allez mettre ministre de
la justice ?
Je pense qu'il faut qu'on on crée
d'abord on crée un défenseur du peuple.
En fait, ce qu'il faut que vous
compreniez c'est qu'on change
l'architecture de vous allez mettre mise
la justice. Non, on fait lire un
défenseur du peuple et le défenseur du
peuple va avoir la main sur les
tribunaux qui vont être construits pour
faire la transition. Qui est-ce qui va
être ministre des finances ?
J'ai une idée. Qui est-ce qui va être
ministre des affaires étrangères ? Bah
ça, je pense qu'on va J'ai des idées.
Vous voulez qu'on en parle sincèrement ?
Sans déconner, vous êtes là pour quoi ?
pour pousser un cadit. Non non mais il
faut qu'on il faut qu'on en parle. Moi
je pense qu'il y a il y a il y a des
personnes que que les gens ici
connaissent. Des gens comme Jean Covici,
des gens comme Dominique de Villepin,
des gens qui sont brillants et qui ont
une existence de l'espace public. Voyez
c'est pas pas que des personnes, on va
pas le mettre à l'économie
Dompan. On va éviter de de répéter
quelques erreurs du du passé. Mais mais
par contre aux affaires étrangères,
c'est fondamental. On a en fait on a des
idées pour à peu près tous les postes
fondamentaux. Je peux pas exposer tous
parce que je vais pas les mettre en
difficulté dein. Tout le monde sait que
je l'ai connu très jeune et enfin donc
c'est pas c'est pas une difficulté. Euh
euh Jean Covici de toute façon il sait
très bien qu'il va être appelé un moment
ou un autre à avoir des responsabilités
dans ce pays quel que soient des accords
qu'on peut avoir sur sa perspective des
croissantistes ou ou par rapport au à
cette sorte de fétichisation qu'il peut
avoir à l'égard du nucléaire parfois. En
réalité il y a un travail de fond et
surtout il y a une équipe derrière.
Voyez, ce qui m'intéresse aussi c'est
cette idée. On personnalise à outrance
et on se retrouve parfois avec des gens
qui du bon Moreti par exemple
n'arrivaient pas à constituer un cabinet
parce qu'il avait pas une idée de cinq
personnes qui auraient pu l'entourer
pour exercer et pour gouverner. Mais
résultat n'est pas n'est pas brillant.
Donc il faut commencer ce que Jean
Covici a fait avec le chiff project,
même si j'ai trouvé que le livre était
pas était pas bon, c'est trouver autour
de lui des personnes qui sont brillantes
comme Mathieu Azano et ainsi de suite.
Oui. Bah je pense que peu de personnes
l'ont lu en tout cas j'espère mais parce
queil y a un vrai problème dans ce
livre. C'est en fait c'est un peu le
c'est il fixe des objectifs mais il y a
pas de matérialisation des mesures
réglementaires, législatives et ainsi de
suite qu'il faudrait mettre en œuvre
pour effectivement sauver les
agriculteurs. C'est une de façon
générale, mais en l'occurrence par
exemple nous notre obsession parce que
c'est ce qu'on voit c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec un un pays qui se vide
de ses agriculteur qui ne considère
l'agriculture que comme une façon
d'équilibrer sa balance de paiement
c'est-à-dire en gros vendre du blé pour
pouvoir continuer à consommer des biens
qui de haute technologie ou des biens de
consommation fabriqués au Bangladesh.
Euh ça c'est tout ça c'est des enjeux
fondamentaux sur lesquels il y a pas eu
de travail véritable et qu'on a essayé
de mettre en œuvre dans cette dynamique
actuelle. La question monétaire, elle
est fondamentale parce que euh
aujourd'hui, pour vous donner un exemple
euh sur les agriculteurs, pourquoi
est-ce qu'il y en a de moins en moins ?
Un des facteurs principaux, c'est la
pression du foncier, le prix du
foncier. Le prix du foncier fait que
aujourd'hui, vous êtes dans la drôome,
justement là où j'étais, les paysages
sont magnifiques. Donc du coup, il y a
des touristes, des gens très riches qui,
du fait des inégalités galopantes sont
capables de mettre 500000 € dans une
petite maison d'agriculteur qui était là
depuis plusieurs générations et qui en
valait à 50000 il y a il y a 15 ans.
l'agriculteur, il va vendre, voyez,
enfin, il a il a il a souffert toute sa
vie pour nourrir son pays, pour un
moment donné, si c'est pas lui qui le
vend, c'est ses enfants qui vont pas
vouloir faire leurs 80 heures par
semaine pour gagner à peine de quoi
enfin en dessous du SMIC le plus
souvent. Et donc cette pression làous du
SMIC, aujourd'hui les politiciens sont
en mode "Ah oui, on va créer une aide,
on va je sais pas quoi, on va préampter
éventuellement." Donc on va dépenser des
comme comme exactement la même la même
erreur que la mairie de Paris à Paris
qui dépense des centaines de millions
d'euros pour acheter des bâtiments hors
de prix pour faire du HLM et du logement
social. Alors même que ce faisant, elle
réduit la part du parc locatif pour les
entités privées. Donc vous retrouvez
qu'avec des gens qui habitent en en
logement social qu'avec des gens très
riches et au milieu des logements
vacants. Tout ça à la fois la situation
de l'agriculteur et notre objectif c'est
c'est de faire lien entre les situations
des Français. À la fois la situation de
l'agriculteur et la situation du
Parisien, elles sont provoquées par le
même facteur, la monnaie. C'est
l'inflation, l'augmentation pas de la de
la de la de la pression spéculative liée
à des politiques monétaires
expansionniste qui ont été adopté après
la crise de 2008 et 2011. Donc on se
retrouve dans une situation où il y a de
plus en plus d'argent qui se concentrer.
Choc pétrolier hein. Non non mais là non
non la pression sur l'immobilier
parisien ou sur le foncier agricole
c'est depuis 2008. C'est depuis en fait
ces énormes masses d'argent qui ont été
injectées par les les banques centrales
dans l'économie non réelle sur les
marchés financiers qui du coup cherchent
des débouchés tangibles et qui vont au
plus safe, c'est-à-dire l'immobilier.
Euh et donc ça crée une sorte de
spéculation qui fait que euh qui n'a
plus aucun rapport avec l'usage, avec le
fait d'avoir véritablement besoin que
des gens vivent dans la ville en
question et ainsi de suite. Ça touche
principalement les métropoles mondiales
et euh les coins de paradis et donc
notamment euh euh beaucoup des endroits
où au travail des agriculteurs. Et donc
il faut en fait changer complètement de
politique monétaire pour le départ. Il
faut dégonfler cette cette bulle. Il
faut dégonfler en fait c'est cette
spéculation délirante qui fait que quand
vous êtes jeune euh vous pouvez pas vous
loger à Paris. Quand vous voulez fonder
une famille, vous pouvez pas vous loger
à Paris. Quand vous êtes chercheur, vous
pouvez pas vous loger à Paris professeur
et ainsi de suite quand vous poliier. Et
au lieu d'être toujours en train
d'essayer de rafistoler la chose ou
ailleurs. Ouais. Oui. Ou comme le fait
maintenant le le propose maintenant à
mairie de Paris des logements de
fonction pour tous les fonctionnaires
qui travaillent à Paris. On va aller
très loin comme ça, vous voyez. Enfin et
entre-temps, il y a plus un ouvrier, il
y a plus un étudiant, il y a plus à un
moment donné, il faut il faut casser
cette dynamique. Vous saviez qu'il y
avait autant de logements vacants à
Paris qu'à Louis ? Enfin, je veux dire,
on est dans des dimensions qui sont
particulièrement inquiétantes. Pardon,
j'ai vu que vous aviez euh eu la
sélection par un/3 euh parce que vous
êtes plusieurs en face de moi, hein. Je
je trahille je trahis un secret, mais
hésitez pas à nous soutenir. Donc, la
main innocente a pris euh une page, je
vous laisse la lire. Mais est-ce qu'elle
l'a choisi ou est-ce qu'elle l'a C'est
le hasard en fait, elle a fait tomber la
pile. Non, non, non, elle l'a
choisi. Mais vous voulez me la lire ou
non ? Parce que sinon on va penser que
c'est moi qui sélectionne. Non. Ah bah
bon. Bah l'agriculture, le vivant et la
mer. Non, sans
décis avant qu'on commence à en parler.
Bon, donc il y a création d'une charte
constitutionnelle du droit du vivant. Ça
c'est la plus généraliste, c'estàd on va
dire il faut progressivement sortir de
l'élevage en cage de toute une bon c'est
des choses qu'on qu'on connaît assez
bien. Transition de la PAC vers un cadre
extracommunautaire et fin de la gestion
régionale du deuxème pilier. Alors ça l'
très technique en gros bah c'est tout
simplement va sortir de l'Union
européenne à priori. Je pense que c'est
ce que les Français vont décider si on
on leur propose. Donc il faut commencer
à préparer la sortie de la PAC qui est
aujourd'hui la principale source de
revenu des agriculteurs et qui
fonctionne à la fois sur un système de
prime au nombre d'hectares détenus mais
aussi de cheptel et avec adorent ça et
avec beaucoup beaucoup d'effets de bord
de cet ord. la gestion régionale pareil,
c'est qu'en fait l'Union européenne de
façon générale est ce qui a amené à la
création des régions qui sont des
entités qui en France ne fonctionnent
pas. simplification unification des
dispositifs d'aide agricole sur le
modèle suisse avec établissement de sep
critères généraux accompagnés de
dispositifs de plafonnement et de
d'agressivité calculés de façon globale
sur la taille et type d'exploitation et
priorisant la biodiversité sur tout
autre critère édcologique. Là, j'ai pas
besoin de vous l'expliciter parce qu'en
plus on a fait une note de bas de page
où on détaille les critères qui ont été
adoptés en Suisse qui font qu'au lieu
d'avoir 40000 dispositifs où moi je
rencontrer beaucoup d'agriculteurs qui
en ont marre de de remplir les CERFA,
voyez, qui ont pas envie d'avoir d'avoir
à consulter les experts comptables pour
tout et pour rien, pour savoir s'ils ont
droit à telle chose, pour après
éventuellement pas avoir respecté à la
lettre tel critère, devoir rembourser,
se retrouver dans des situations pas
possible. Donc on simplifie tout ça, on
attribue des pourcentages aux critères
selon justement le degré de préservation
des des
paysages. Ça c'est un critère évidemment
minoritaire, la qualité la préservation
de la qualité des sols et ainsi de suite
pour
pour mitiger pour en fait orienter la
production agricole de façon douce.
Après plan de sauvetage des
agriculteurs. Donc on a un
rétablissement des prix planchés garanti
et primum d'entrée. Bon ça ça se passe
de commentaire. moratoire
restructuration de la dette des
agriculteurs qui commence à être une
vraie difficulté pour beaucoup d'entre
eux. Alignement des droits sentiels des
agriculteurs sur les salariés du régime
général. Assurer une retraite, assurer
la possibilité d'avoir en cas de de
maladie de chômage des droits égaux à
ceux d'un salarié. C'est la c'est la
moindre des choses qu'on leur doit à ces
gens. Surtout qu'ils sont pas si
nombreux que ça. Donc je veux dire le
déséquilibre serait serait serait serait
court. Donc instauration d'un minimum
vital pour toute fonction agricole non
industrielle. Euh il faut différencier
parce que sinon en fait on fait peser
sur la collectivité une responsabilité
qui euh qui devrait reposer sur les
grands exploitants. Création d'un fond
assurel public notamment lié au risque
climatique en remplacement de toutes les
assurances privées qui aujourd'hui
pululent et qui génère en gros beaucoup
de de difficultés. Il est consultable
quelque part le programme. Oui, on on
vient de le mettre en ligne en même
temps. On avait fait un petit tweet
programmé sur sur mon compte sur mon
compte. Euh alors je peux vous couper ?
Rentrer dans le détail. beaucoup. On
fait quoi avec l'armée ? Ben ce que j'ai
proposé, on passe d'une armée de métier
à une armée de conscription. Donc
service militaire à la Suisse, on
propose, on propose parce que c'est un
vrai le vecteur nucléaire et d'autres
vecteurs nuclé. Donc alors ça c'est très
important. Alors ça, on peut rentrer
dans le détail surtout qu'il y a eu un
événement assez préoccupant il y a
quelques jours, c'est-à-dire que notre
force de dissuasion nucléaire repose sur
deux facteurs. Il y a les forces
aériennes et les forces sous-marines.
Euh, on a eu il y a quelques jours,
c'est pas confirmé, les détails ne sont
pas explicités, mais un rafale qui
aurait été abattu dans la confrontation
qu'il y a eu entre l'Inde et et le
Pakistan. Euh le rafale est aujourd'hui
le porteur euh des vecteurs nucléaires
pour nos forces aériennes. Et donc on se
retrouve dans une situation où si le
rafale devient vulnérable notamment à
des dispositifs euh à enfin aux
nouvelles formes de radar et enfin de
dispositifs d'identification, il y a il
y a un terme technique euh sur pour
toutes les mesures de brouillage et de
et de diversion qui protègent le rafale.
On découvre que les Chinois, parce que
c'est les Chinois qui
ont vendu les jets aux Pakistanais en
contre pour faire contrepoids à la vente
de rafales français en Inde. Si on
découvre que les Chinois ont la
technologie pour pour abattre nos
rafales, ça il y a il y a la moitié de
notre dissuion nucléaire en gros qui
tombe et on se retrouve que avec des
sous-marins lanceur d'engin dont on ne
sait pas dont on ne sait pas si ils sont
aujourd'hui vulnérables ou pas.
C'estàdire que parce qu'évidemment s'ils
le sont euh les puissances qui auraient
réussi à à les identifier à trouver des
façons de euh de les empêcher euh ferait
tout pour qu'on ne le sache pas pour
pouvoir nous le cas échéant euh nous euh
euh nous saborder. Et en plus, on est
sur on a été sur une réduction de la
flotte des sous des SNLE qui fait
que on en a un en gros de disponible à
chaque fois sur les sur ce ce qu'on a
parce que entre celui qui est en
maintenance, celui qui Et or jusqu'ici
on en avait deux et deux c'est
important. Pourquoi ? Parce que il faut
en avoir un en Atlantique et un autre
dans le Pacifique au moins a priori,
vous voyez ? Enfin, c'est quand même Et
alors là avec un seul pour peu qu'on
puisse on arrive à en déstabiliser un.
les portesavions, on sait euh les
risques auxquels on est confronté
aujourd'hui avec la dronification et euh
et euh et tout ce qui est en train de se
dérouler sur euh sur euh sur le conflit
euh ukrainien avec tout ce que ça
implique parce que nous on avait de
grandes compétences en terme de
fabrication de missiles que ce soit avec
MBDI et tout ça, on avait entre les
exocètes, les Aster, les si on avait
quand même un certain nombre de vecteurs
différents qui euh qui aujourd'hui se
retrouvent dans une situation
d'asymétrie extraordinaire. qui coûte
très cher par rapport à à aux armes.
Enfin, en gros, on se retrouve avec une
arme, une lutte asymétrique sur le
solaire. ce qui est ce qui est ce qui
est ce qui est ce qui à ben c'est pour
ça en fait le passage armé de
conscription c'est aussi une réflexion
par rapport à ces évolutions récentes.
C'est de se dire en fait la la défense
du territoire elle va plus pouvoir
passer par ces énormes machines. On a
bien vu qu'on a des blindés pour tenir 3
jours dans le casre d'une confrontation
conventionnelle. Un nombre de blindés
suffisant pour tenir 3 jours. Donc et on
va pas en reconstruire 2000. Vous voyez,
on va pas repasser sur 2000 char lecler
après les avoir réduit à 10 fois moins.
Donc il y a un moment donné, il faut
qu'on qu'on réfléchisse, y compris en
fait à des formes de préparation à la
guerilla euh à la fois humaine et
technologique pour rentrer dans un
rapport de euh de préservation du
territoire qui n'est plus tout à fait ou
exclusivement assuré par la dissuasion
nucléaire parce que c'est aussi l'autre
leçon du des incidents entre l'Inde et
le Pakistan. Je conseille de lire les
écrits de monsieur Christian Orbulot.
Ouais. Concernant la guerria et la la
résistance. C'est très très intéressant.
Mais parce que parce que là sur l'un des
Pakistan, ce qu'on découvre aussi c'est
que en réalité une guerre
conventionnelle est tout à fait possible
entre puissance nucléaire. Là, on ça
s'est ça s'est plus ou moins arrêté pour
l'instant grâce à la médiation des
États-Unis, mais en réalité la
préservation effective de notre
territoire, celui qui sera capable
d'envoyer 15, 20, 30 vecteurs nucléaires
sur Moscou ou sur Beijing ou je sais pas
quoi, quel que
soit les dommages qu'on a subi nous, il
va falloir ne pas trembler au moment de
le faire parce que les conséquences
humaines, les conséquences en
représaille, ainsi de suite risquent
d'être lourdes. Et donc dans ce cas-là,
on voit bien que l'escalade peut arriver
à une guerre conventionnelle classique
et que du coup toute la théorie sur la
dissuasion
nucléaire doit pas être remise
complètement en question, mais elle doit
quand même être interrogée. Oui, sur on
a enfin de façon générale, on a on a on
a toute une reconfiguration à mettre en
œuvre sur le militaire qui est enfin qui
est très engageante hein, qui va qui va
qui va produire beaucoup de conséquences
mais qui doit se combiner avec toute la
reconfiguration industrielle parce que
euh c'est bien malin d'avoir c'est bien
mignon d'avoir une une industrie
pseudoautonome militaire enfin de
l'armement. En réalité, si tous vos
composants sont fabriqués à l'étranger,
ça sert pas à grand-chose. Si vous si
les puces que vous utilisez sont des
puces taïwanaise. Enfin, voyez, il y a
un moment donné, il faut quand même
avoir à l'esprit que notre autonomie
stratégique, elle va passer par la
renationalisation complète à mon avis de
STM. Donc c'est la capacité et les
moyens investis qu'on aurait pu donner
pendant le Covid parce que c'est
quelques dizaines de milliards d'euros
qui sont très difficiles à engager en
temps normal mais à cette époque-là
aurait pu être fait pour
baisser euh bah enfin pour avoir des
fabrications de puces qui atteignent le
nombre de nanomètres suffisamment bas
pour pour pouvoir fabriquer des
équipements militaires et aussi
industriel de haut niveau. Autre
question qui n'a rien à voir. Vous allez
faire des alliances avec d'autres partis
politiques. Vous allez faire de la
tambouille, de la petite cuisine
politique ou pas du tout ? Non, c'est
pour ça qu'on se présente pas aux
élections
intermédiaires. Là, la 5e République a
beaucoup de défauts, mais cette cette
fonction présidentielle permet d'aller
au Fenwick par rapport aux institutions
actuelles. Nous, ce qu'on veut adopter
c'est
c'est on veut rendre la parole au peuple
et si on doit en passer par toute la
tambouille parlementaire et ainsi de
suite, on en sortira jamais. ce pays va
couler si on si on donc plutôt il y a
plus il y a l'option coup d'état aussi
hein mais c'est un peu moins risqué de
d'embasser par élection présidentielle
donc essayons pour l'instant d'aller
d'aller d'aller d'aller de cette
façon-là si on nous empêche là de toute
façon les parrainages les parrainages
c'est la chose la plus merveilleuse que
l'on est conçu moi je comprends pas la
fixation qui a sur les parrainag les
parrainages c'est l'obligation qui vous
est faite d'aller écouter les derniers
politiciens qui sont un minimum
respectables dans ce pays c'est ceux qui
sont les maires des 36000 communes de
France des gens qui pour rien se
sacrifient, bossent toute la journée
dans des communes de 1000, 2000, 3000
habitants. Si vous êtes pas capable euh
de leur faire croire que ce que vous
faites a un sens et que va vraiment
servir la population, ainsi de suite,
c'est que vous êtes en décalage avec le
pays. Donc qui ait des pressions du
préfet, des partis et ainsi de suite.
D'accord, mais enfin si vous avez peur
de ça, il faut pas prétendre derrière
avoir un programme révolutionnaire qui
va vous mettre à dos les principales
puissances de l'argent et un nombre de
corporations infinies dans ce pays. ce
ce programme, est-ce que vous avez peur
pour votre
sécurité parce que là vous bousculez
beaucoup de milliards là. Oui, je pense
qu'en fait on
va Non, je pense je pense que le risque
c'est la mort sociale avant tout. C'est
vraiment essayer de vous dégommer par
des fausses accusations, des procédures
judiciaires, un harcèlement. J'ai quand
même eu le droit le lendemain de notre
dernier entretien qui ne date de il y a
pas si longtemps. J'ai reçu 150 pages du
barreau de Paris, une procédure de
tentative de radiation, une de plus,
dont l'une des raisons c'était le fait
d'avoir transmis euh une enveloppe
noire, un courrier dans une enveloppe
noire à un procureur. Dr parler du
détail ou pas Ce qui oui oui. Ce qui euh
selon selon mon ordre donc l'ordre des
avocats de Paris censé me protéger
suscitait suggérait une approche hostile
et inquiétante. Et ça c'est le point de
départ. Donc pour ça on cherche à me
radier. Vous savez quand même sur
l'ordre des avocats de Paris la moitié
au 2 tiers des avocats du barreau
dépendent destup. Enfin voyez évidemment
de de l'argent qui est blanchi, qui est
de l'argent en cash et compagnie. Je
veux dire c'est plus ça. Oui. Et là ça
c'est la moitié. Oui ben c'est pour le
coup mon expérience avec des des gens
que j'ai en face de moi aux audiences
d'autres preuves que votre expérience.
Et si vous allez chercher dans les
systèmes de blanchiment qui existe
aujourd'hui, je peux vous dire que vous
avez retrouvé pas mal de confrères qui
les utilisent. Ça c'est une partie
gratuit. Ça c'est non non c'est c'est
même pas c'est un fait. Enfin je dire
aujourd'hui c'est quoi le contentieux
pénal ? C'est du stup. C'est stup un peu
de proxénétisme beaucoup de violence
sexuelle. Enfin, mais c'est du stup,
c'est sur le stupe qui gagne de
l'argent. Et et l'autre partie, c'est
cabinet d'affaires qui eux font de la
corruption légale, vous voyez, qui
chopent des millions
pour ça a été le cas par exemple pendant
la tentative de fusion entre Suèse et et
euh et GDF euh où on s'était retrouvé
avec un confrère avocat qui avait touché
15 millions d'euros pour une mission de
2 jours, donc
pour une une mission qui n'a pas abouti.
J'en avais parlé dans 13 pières. Euh
donc moi parce que et en fait et donc
ils font une photocopie, c'est pour dire
le niveau cafïen et de tentative de
déstabilisation auquel on peut être
confronté dans des positions comme la
mienne.
Pour justifier de cette démarche, ils
font une photocopie de l'enveloppe. Donc
la pièce à conviction numéro 1, c'est
l'enveloppe et ils la font en noir et
blanc. Et pourquoi il la font en noir et
blanc ? parce qu'en réalité c'était mes
plus belles enveloppes et quand vous
l'ouvrez elle est dorée à l'intérieur.
Vous voyez, c'était une façon de c'est
une marque de respect d'en voyez et donc
voyez la manœuvre a mais et ça ça peut
valoir une radiation aujourd'hui de
l'ors des avocats de Paris. Vous voyez,
c'est à ça. Et pour en fait, si j'ai pas
la possibilité à un moment euh d'en
parler publiquement, de générer une
forme de résistance sociale et de honte
à leur égard de se comporter comme le
KGB pouvait le faire dans les années 60
70 euh à l'égard de ses opposants, et
bien je suis mort. Si j'ai pas la
possibilité de démanteler les
compromates qu'on met à droite à gauche
par la parole, la mort silencieuse
s'installe. Et aujourd'hui en France,
beaucoup de gens intègres, beaucoup de
gens intelligents font face à cette mort
sociale. Et c'est aussi pour eux qu'il
faut se battre et pour éviter que euh
cette situation continue de perdurer.
Proche, ils en subissent les
conséquences. Bah ça a été un massacre.
C'était un massacre. Et c'est pour ça
que avant la publication de crépuscule
euh j'ai pris soin de euh de me défaire
de de tout lien qui pourrait amener des
personnes à subir
parochet euh les conséquences de mes
démarches. Sauf que ça, vous pouvez pas
le faire à l'égard de votre famille.
Pour revenir au fait que vous avez reçu
un courrier le lendemain de de votre 170
pages he de votre parution. Ah ça avait
été envoyé avant. Ouais ça été envoyé.
C'était pas par rapport à vous, c'était
par rapport au fait que la procédure
disciplinaire précédente qui euh qui que
non non qui avait conclu le jour même
n'avait pas acté ma radiation et donc
ils en ont relancé une autre
immédiatement. Et qui a derrière tout ça
? Ça c'est établi. C'est quand même
c'est pour vous dire parce que
c'est les cinq sais là pour le coup le
dossier je v je voulais envoyer
d'ailleurs je pense les c les cinq
sources président du tribunal judiciaire
de Paris première saisine 2è saisine
premier président de la cour d'appel de
Paris 2è saisine 3è sis procureur
général de la République 4e saisine
ministre d'intérieur d'ant donc quand
vous êtes ciblé par les quatre plus
puissantes autorités judiciaires et
aujourd'hui leur ministre de tutelle
parce que vous avez fait votre métier
Mais en envoyant une enveloppe noire.
Oh, un des autres motifs, j'ai oublié
une formule de politesse. Un autre
motif, j'ai osé comparer la mesure de
déchéance de
nationalité dont a subi Kemis à aux
mesures qui étaient prises parce que
elles étaient sur le même fondement par
la France de Vichi. Dans les écritures
que j'ai transmises et en rappelant que
tout cela s'inscrivait dans un
imaginaire colonial qui visiblement n'a
pas quitté l'administration française
dans des écritures au Conseil d'État.
C'est qu'on me fait poursuivre et on
porte plainre pénalement contre moi pour
des écritures au Conseil d'État. un
avocat pour restreindre la possibilité
pour un avocat d'invoquer un certain
nombre d'arguments historiques. On a
déçu de la sa nationalité cet homme né
en
France de parents
français mais noir mais noir et ça il
faut quand même le prendre en compte
parce qu'il s'est opposé à une
tentative de déclaration de guerre
contre un état. a fait son interview euh
euh qui est disponible sur notre chaîne
dans l'onglet euh vidéo et non pas dans
l'onglet en direct parce que et on l'a
déchué à la demande de DGE. Ça c'est
important aussi parce qu'en fait il faut
il faut beaucoup mesurer l'influence des
services sur l'instance judiciaire. Oui
oui parce qu'en fait dans dans le
courrier dans le courrier qui lui qui
lui adressait euh et euh là il a dit il
était pas demande à la demande des
services de sécurité extérieure parce
que parce que les services extérieurs
ont trouvé des hecteurs extérieurs.
Ah, les les services de sécurité
extérieure, donc des GSE, enfin, il a
pas eu besoin de mettre l'acronyme
considérait qu'il était un danger pour
les atteintes enfin il atteignait aux
intérêts fondamentaux de la nation.
Donc, il a quand même été placé 72
heures en garde à vue ADG. Si je sais
pas si c'était avant ou après qu'on
qu'on se voit, mais je l'ai sorti de là.
il encouré 30 ans de prison parce qu'il
a tenu des discours et parce qu'il a
organisé des
manifestations. Et je peux vous dire que
ça s'est joué à ça, le fait qu'il soit
pas mis en détention provisoire et c'est
ça c'est ça l'état de notre pays.
C'estàd qu'à un moment donné vous
retrouvez avec en fait des services de
renseignement en roulibre d'où ça vient
ça vient en partie de ce qui s'est passé
sur le terrorisme. Et c'est là où vous
rendez compte que ça a été très efficace
ce qu'ils ont fait, que ce soit Daesh ou
ou Ak, ainsi de suite parce que en fait
ils ont créé ils ont déstabilisé nos
institutions de façon sérieuse et ça il
va falloir revenir dessus. Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils ont polarisé tous nos
services sur la menace. Non, c'est pas
ça ça. Ça heureusement quand même enfin
qui l'ont traité. C'est parce que on
s'est retrouvé avec beaucoup de procès
fantoches. On s'est retrouvé avec
beaucoup de procès dans lesquels euh les
dossiers étaient vides mais qui était
mené à la demande des services de
renseignement à partir de notre blanche
et à partir d'information qui était
communiquée en dehors de la procédure
judiciaire au magistrat de façon qu'en
fait les procédures auxquelles vous
étiez confrontés étaient des procédures
vidées. Du coup, votre capacité à
défendre les votre client et
éventuellement établir son innocence
c'était rendu impossible et ça ça a été
accepté parce que c'était le terrorisme.
Sauf que comme d'habitude peu à peu, ça
s'est étendu et vous retrouvez
aujourd'hui maintenant c'est pour des
activistes comme monsieur Sebba et peu à
peu voyez ça ça touche à des opposants
et vous retrouvez avec cette sorte de
lien un peu pernicieux, incestueux et
pas du tout acceptable qui fait que vous
avez des le principe du contradictoire
fondamental en procédure n'est pas
respecté quandme dans un pays où
rappelons-en rappelons-nous que 90 % des
personnes qui se retrouvent convoquées
au tribunal correctionnel et 95 % de
celles qui se retrouve devant une cour
d'assise sont condamné 90 et 95 %.
C'estàd qu'en gros euh le
taux de relaxe ou d'acquitement est
quasi nul. C'est de l'ordre de la marge
d'erreur. Je dirais que les enquêteurs
font mieux leur boulot. C'est en fait la
la l'audience en France est conçue le le
la processus le processus judiciaire en
France est est resté inquisitorial et
l'audience c'est une forme de rituel de
négociation de la peine en fait et rien
de plus. Mais donc du coup tout cet
imaginaire collectif qu'on a créé autour
de l'importance des avocats, de la
plaidoirie et ainsi de suite en réalité
est fictionnel. On passe à la politique
étrangère en terme d'alliance, pas
d'alliance avec qui ?
Et puis le conflit ukrainien si en 2027
il est toujours là, Ran Branco, il fait
quoi ? Bah, il arrête tout de suite
cette politique de fuite en avant qui
consiste à utiliser le fond européen
pour la paix, ce qui est quand même très
ironique pour envoyer des armes sur un
sur une zone de conflit. ce qui est en
contravention des textes européens sur
sur la question si on sort de l'Union
européenne, va falloir très vite
reconfigurer de la coopération et et des
accords bilatéraux tout de suite parce
qu'il va falloir reconstituer des pôles
de force, vous voyez, notamment avec
l'Europe du Sud et ainsi de suite. Il va
falloir rééquilibrer nos rapports avec
l'ensemble des pays. Il va falloir
rééquilibrer nos rapports avec la
Russie. Vous voyez, on peut pas on peut
pas maintenir tous nos accords avec les
États-Unis quand Trump est élu et
prétendre que parce que c'est Poutine en
Russie, il faut n'avoir aucun accord
avec la Russie. Soit on est sur une
dynamique où la personne, le chef d'état
et les personnes qui dirigent le pays
comptent, soit on ne l'est pas mais on
peut pas avoir un double standard. Moi,
je considère que dans les affaires
d'État, il faut traiter avec les États,
quel que soient nos désaccords sur la
politique intérieure, sur le respect des
droits de l'homme et ainsi de suite. Il
faut pouvoir l'énoncer, il faut pouvoir
protéger les personnes qui subissent ces
répressions, qui soient chinois, russes,
ainsi de suite. Moi, j'ai reçu euh des
un certain nombre de dissidents chinois
à une période parce que justement, je
considère que ça fait partie de la
tradition française et qu'il faut
continuer à permettre à ceux qui se
battent par la liberté d'être accueillis
en France, quel que soit leur leur
origine ou leur qualité. Mais par
contre, est-ce que ça implique de tout
d'un coup rentrer dans des dynamiques
délirantes où on se prive euh de toute
une série d'accords y compris sur le gaz
et autres ou qui nous amène à être sur
le point euh d'entrer dans une guerre
conventionnelle avec une puissance
nucléaire ? C'est inconcevable. Euh il y
a il y a vraiment une une immaturité
chez ceux qui nous dirigent teinté d'une
forme de paternalisme à la limite du
racialisme en ce qui concerne Emmanuel
Macron vis-à-vis de l'Afrique qui a eu
les conséquences que l'on sait des
échecs sur à peu près toutes les tous
les dossiers où il essayé de de
s'impliquer. Ça ça pas été assez dit
hein. C'est je repose ma question il
faut lui trouver au moins trois qualités
à Emmanuel Macron.
Je pense que quand vous êtes frappé par
le mal comme cet homme l'
euh euh chacun de chacun de vos actes y
compris les moins irrationnels sont
marqués par cette
caractéristique. J'ai
vraiment les trois qualités.
Il est beau gosse, il est bien manucuré.
Non mais je veux pas être caricatural en
en en étant mais mais j'ai du mal à
avoir une quelconque forme de respect ou
en tant que figure politique, en tant
que chef d'état, enfin pas en tant que
le niveau de
compromission qu'il a atteint est trop
important. Son intelligence n'est pas
contrairement à ce qui a été prétendu,
marquante. Son rapport à la culture est
très limité. Euh il y a une forme de
provincialisme au sens négatif du terme,
hein, c'est-à-dire une sorte de de
bourgeoisirance qu'il habite dans tous
les domaines. Et
euh et je pense que sur un certain
nombre de domaines notamment euh
militaire dans son logiciel en terme de
de suivi d'un certain nombre de
politiques, ça pouvait aller. C'est
qu'il y a eu un certain nombre de
programmes d'investissement qui ont été
menés qui étaient importants où on n pas
trop pris de retard mais mais c'est
compliqué. Bah justement sur tous les
tous les nouveaux tous les dispositifs
domiciles qui ont été mis en place.
Oui, si il y a quand même
eu vous avez il y a eu un programme de
de modernisation de de nos forces armées
qui a quand même été lancé et qui était
pas qui était loin d'être acquis il y a
il y a 10 ans. Je pourrais réfléchir sur
des mesures ponctuelles mais en fait
est-ce que ça c'est Victor Hubau qui
disait non quand vous avez des je sais
plus qu la citation exacte j'aime pas
faire des citations générales mais là je
l'ai lu récemment quand vous avez des
vues partielles vous n'avez pas d'idée
du tout enfin vous voyez c'est cette
idée de si on commence à essayer de
prendre des petits morceaux pour ce qui
importe c'est de voir la totalité d'être
allé chercher en détail ce qu'il a fait
mais après regarder c'est dans un grand
ensemble et le grand ensemble est est
pitoyable pitoyable pitoyable et et
dérangeant mais par contre Je ne veux
pas qu'on se limite à une critique
d'Emmanuel Macron parce que la classe
politique dans son ensemble en France a
lourdement perdu en exigence et en
qualité et on a une
fragilisation qui ne cessera pas avec le
départ d'Emmanuel Macron. Et si ce pays
veut sérieusement se doter de dirigeants
comme Jordan Bardella ou quelques
autres, c'est qu'il y a une difficulté
qui a trait à la société et pas
seulement à ceux qui nous dirigent. Et
ça ça fait partie de notre programme.
C'estàd qu'il faut qu'on arrête de
s'infantiliser. Il faut qu'on arrête d'à
chaque fois reporter sur ceux qui nous
dirigent un instanté euh des
responsabilités qui sont en réalité
aujourd'hui collectives. C'est-à-dire
qu'il y a les politiques qu'on mérite.
Il y a il y a quand même une part de ça
dont il faut qu'on soit conscient. Il
faut qu'on Moi, je le vois, le niveau
d'engagement en France est très faible.
quand j'étais au Mexique quand même. Non
non, c'est pas que ça. Quand j'étais au
Mexique, vous savez, c'est pas évident
de faire adopter des politiques de
gauche au Mexique. C'est quand même le
précarré des États-Unis qui ne supporte
pas beaucoup depuis la doctrine Monro
depuis quand même quasiment de siècles
la le fait que des pays d'Amérique
latine ou central s'autonomisent d'eux
pour des enjeux géostratégiques. On l'a
vu avec Cuba, on le voit avec Haïti
d'ailleurs et tout tout ce qu'ils y font
et pourtant ils ont réussi. Mais vous
savez combien ils sont d'adhérents au
aux partis en place de gauche ? 4
millions. Aujourd'hui la France
insoumise, elle a en réalité 20000
militants actifs. Je parle même pas
d'Emmanuel Macron qui en a 8000 enfin de
Gabriel Tal. Mais donc on est à un
moment donné où collectivement il faut
aussi qu'on s'interroge sur ce laisser
aller et ce confort en fait qu'on a
trouvé dans cette douce décadence dans
laquelle on s'inscrit. Et euh des gens
comme moi ont pris beaucoup beaucoup de
risque ces dernières années pour essayer
de protéger les intérêts des Français.
Et les marques d'expression de
sympathie, ainsi de suite ne suffiront
pas un moment pour sauver ce pays. Vous
voyez ? Et ne suffiront pas pour
résister à des forces qui ont beaucoup
trop d'intérêt pour se contenter de
laisser les clés au moindre effroid. Les
gilets jaunes ont pris beaucoup de
risques et on a vu les conséquences que
ça a eu. Et donc mon engagement éthique,
il est à l'égard de ceux qui ont pris
ces risques là et qui de se dire je vais
essayer d'élaborer avec vous des
instruments qui nous permettent demain
de résister.
On va poser des questions internet.
On y a répondu mais on la pose quand
même. Bonjour monsieur Branco. Comment
espérez-vous faire connaître par les
Français de tous âges ? Comment vous
faire connaître parler français de tous
âges et éviter les pièges des médias
subventionnés afin d'arriver au deuxème
tour ? Responsabilité collective, il
faut qu'on s'y mette tous. Il y a un
moment donné où on peut pas se
satisfaire. Voyez pourquoi est-ce qu'
aussi il y a il y a cet engagement ?
C'est moi j'ai très bien vu au moment de
crépuscule, ça aurait été très facile
pour moi devenir un
totem un peu intouchable. J'en connais
quelques-uns dans notre société. des
gens qui à un moment donné parce qu'ils
ont révélé un
scandale deviennent des intouchables et
s'en tiennent là. Euh moi mon obsession,
peut-être que j'étais trop jeune de
toute façon pour me satisfaire d'un
statut comme celui-là, mais mon
obsession c'était une fois qu'on avait
établi le constat d'essayer trouver des
instruments pour aller au-delà du
constat parce que sinon ce que la seule
chose que j'avais généré c'est cert un
soulagement parce qu'on mettait enfin
des mots sur ce qui s'était passé mais
aussi une impasse. C'est dire ah oui bah
il y a 10 qui fabriquent des candidats à
travers leur contrôle média ainsi de
suite. On peut rien faire contre eux
parce qu'ils sont milliardaires et qu'on
a rien. Et donc à la fois par mon
parcours personnel mais aussi à travers
les instruments de réflexion les livres
dans un premier temps puis après à
travers cette plateforme l'idée c'est de
se dire on peut pas se contenter d'être
dans un rapport de dénonciation
d'indignation. Ça a été le grand échec
d'indignez-vous. C'est il suffit pas
d'écrire. Il suffit pas il faut se
préparer. Il faut se préparer. Il faut
prendre des risques. Vous allez vous
financer comment vous allez nous
financer pas vous personnellement mais
il faut il faut se prendre en charge. Il
faut se prendre en charge. Il faut que
des gens mobilisent ce qu'ils ont. Si
quelqu'un a quelque part un lieu où il
peut accueillir, c'est en fait il y a un
le changement n'interviendra pas
autrement. Et l'idée c'est de donner
l'exemple, c'est on se met en jeu tout
ça prend énormément de temps. L'IA n'a
pas été mobilisé. On a utilisé l'IA
ponctuellement pour tenter de vérifier
un certain nombre d'équations
budgétaires de base, c'est-à-dire par
exemple savoir combien coûtait telle
mesure ou telle autre pour essayer de
trouver un équilibre d'ensemble plutôt
que d'aller chercher au fin fond un
rapport d'accord des comptes. Vous voyez
? Et après évidemment avec un système de
vérification parce que comment on le
fait comment le fait c'est des modèles
statistiques avec un taux d'erreur
important. Question internet. Dans le
programme de Ran Branco, ont-ils
réfléchi au système de contrôle du
pouvoir qu'il s'il arrive au pouvoir
permettrait à ces adversaires de le
contrôler lui-même ? entre parenthèses,
le serpent qui se mort à la queue a-t-il
la solution qui permet à tous les
acteurs d'un fonctionnement politique de
pouvoir encadrer un système politique
fonctionnel et vertueux sans possibilité
de le corrompre lui-même ? Il faut pas
il faut pas avoir le fétichisme des
normes. C'estàd qu'en fait une règle ne
suffira jamais à vaincre une volonté
individuelle de corruption ou une
dégénérescence collective. Donc la règle
en soi n'est pas suffisante pour
protéger euh la politique c'est et la
société sont des affaires de corps et
d'esprit et donc de volonté. Ça c'est un
premier point. Euh nous on a réfléchi à
des règles et à des normes et à des
dispositifs de contrôle. typiquement les
mandats impératifs et révocatoires. Ça
c'est par rapport à dérive personnelles
qui pourraient me toucher. Ça ça me
protège pas des effets d'influence que
j'ai vu naître y compris chez des gens
que j'ai beaucoup soutenu au Sénégal où
très rapidement les mêmes
bourgeoisies qui qui étaient prêtes à
les tuer pour les empêcher d'arriver au
pouvoir deviennent tout miel pour leur
proposer leurs services et du coup les
orienter et peu à peu les étouffer. Et
ça en fait c'est tout simplement la
préparation politique. Un des enjeux
fondamentaux à la fois d'autres
mouvements de façon générale en France,
c'est la formation politique. Les
mouvements de
gauche communiste, trotskiste, ainsi de
suite avait beaucoup de défauts pendant
la période de la guerre froide. Ils
avaient une qualité, ils formaient leurs
militants, ils for ils avaient
conscience de l'importance d'une
avant-garde et ça
ça crée une forme de russellement sur le
reste de la société. La fin de la guerre
froide a donné l'illusion d'une fin de
l'histoire qui a fait que les gens sont
désintéressés des principes fondamentaux
et des textes fondamentaux et de cet
effort de formation. Il faut qu'on
reprenne ça. Moi, j'ai pas écrit 15
livres pour rien, vous voyez. Enfin,
c'est pas pour mon petit plaisir. J'ai
pas publié ces 15 livres, c'est aussi
pour que chacun aille à un moment donné.
Oui, c'est sûr. Des livres sur Assang.
J'ai Non, c'est que chacun aille à un
moment donné puisse avoir accès à une
partie. C'est comme des rétex, vous
voyez. C'est euh des retours
d'expérience. Il faut à un moment donné,
il faut que les gens aient accès à
travers les ouvrages à quelque chose que
j'ai pu toucher mais qui ne m'appartient
pas. Enfin que je voulais redire. C'est
joli comme mot. C'est c'est bien c'est
bien achalandé, c'est bien
agencé. On n pas pris trop d'inertie.
On se retrouve pas avec des gens qui
sont blasés en catatonie émotionnelle,
compultant, qui sont dans l'avalanche de
problème du quotidien, de la gestion
quotidienne, de leurs problèmes.
D'ailleurs, peut-être que les
politiques euh Ouais. surf là-dessus.
Euh économiquement parlant, on n pas les
deux pieds dans le béton. Non,
économiquement parlant, on n pas les
deux pieds dans le béton. Moi, je je
vous donne un exemple très simple. Tout
ça, ouais. Je vais vous donner un
exemple par rapport à ça, par rapport à
notre nos capacités d'engagement réel.
Euh, il y a eu un scandale au Sénégal
justement récemment où ils ont découvert
que 7 milliards d'euros avaient disparu
en corruption. 7 milliards d'euros, moi
je vois ça, je me dis bon, à côté des
1000 milliards d'euros qu'on a créé de
dette, c'est pas grand chose. Ils vont
s'en remettre. Puis après, j'ai vu quel
pourcentage du PIB ça constituait pour
le Sénégal. 20
%. C'est-à-dire que le Sénégal
aujourd'hui c'est combien le PIB du S ?
Bah du coup 35 milliards. C'estàd que on
a 1 % combien de 0 ? 1 milliard. Bah
neuf neuf, il y a
euh on a on le Sénégal a un PIV qui
correspond à 1 % du PIB de la France
alors que et ils ont un état qui
fonctionne comme le nôtre formellement
et pour le coup vous arrachez pas des
dents à Dakar quand vous avez besoin.
Vous avez un rendez-vous avec le
dentiste dans la semaine. Et ça c'est
des choses que sénégalais ont pas encore
perçu et du coup ils continuent à à
prendre des des bateaux pour au risque
de leur vie pour venir jusqu'ici. Ils se
rendent pas compte de notre dégradation
alors même qu'on génère des ressources
extraordinaires. Donc la capacité
financière et économique, on l'a que ce
soit au sein de l'euro ou en dehors.
Vous voyez ça ça c'est très clair. On
fait quoi avec l'immigration ? la
question sociale la on refonde
complètement la politique de visa d'une
part on recrée un système à double
échelle sur les asiles c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait on crée des asile individuel
aujourd'hui en fait on a un système
d'asile général où il suffit que vous
veniez d'une zone de guerre qu' même si
elle est à l'autre bout de la planète
pour avoir droit à l'asile. Nous il faut
qu'on ait un système d'asile privilégié
pour ceux qui ont été ciblés réellement.
C'est des gens ce qui est le principe de
l'asile de départ c'està-dire que vous
aviez vous étiez persécuté persécuté par
un pouvoir pour une raison x ou y. on
vous accueillait et ensuite un système
d'asile plus général, plus restrictif
avec plus d'obligations pour euh les
populations à niveau structurel. On a
euh par exemple sur l'accès à
nationalité la même façon qu'il va
falloir si on en tout cas qu'on propose
ou pas d'ailleurs le service militaire
qui soit adopté ou pas, il faut que euh
les personnes qui cherchent à être
naturalisé, qu'ils soient immigrés de
très loin ou comme moi espagnol ou
portugais, il faut qu'il rende un
service à nation. Donc il faut qu'il
passe un temps en service militaire ou
en service cloyer. Donc en fait on crée
toute une série de dynamiques comme ça
qui font que toute toute la tension qui
s'est générée autour de cette questionlà
bien on respire un peu. Et une question
très simple. Moi, moi je serais très
content de voir euh le RN au pouvoir
demain tout en restant dans l'Union
européenne. J'aimerais beaucoup voir
comment est-ce qu'ils vont gérer les
questions n'importe quoi leur programme
aujourd'hui. Euh si s'ils veulent et si
on veut reprendre le controsion de
frontière réellement, il faut les
reprendre. Il faut sortir de l'Union
européenne. Vous voyez, on fait quoi ?
On fait quoi avec les OCUTF ? Mais les
OQTF, c'est toujours la même question.
C'estd que vous avez quoi ? vous avez
ceux qui va falloir expulser dans des
pays qui vont vous demander des laisser
passer consulaires et donc ça dépend pas
de vous. Et donc c'est la question de
l'UQTF lui-même. Est-ce que vous
préférez un UQTF ou est-ce que vous
préférez par exemple de mettre des
travaux d'intérêt général pour
infraction à la législation sur le
séjour ? C'est peut-être plus
intéressant non ? Ce qui vous permet de
mettre sous contrôle la personne. Vous
aurez toujours une minorité de marginaux
et de vrais dangereux. Il y a x % de
mecs euh ou de femmes en général plutôt
des hommes qu'il faut absolument sortir
du territoire. La réalité c'est que pour
la grande majorité c'est des gens qui
que vous pouvez faire contribuer à la
société et s'ils veulent pas être
réaccueillis dans leur pays d'origine
mais ça c'est c'est jamais la volonté
individuelle. C'est toujours la volonté
du pays d'origine qui qui va qui va
faire obstacle. C'est quoi ? On ouvre le
bagne, on fait Saint-Pierry Molelon.
Non, vous créez des
infractions à la législation sur les
étrangers. En même temps, vous les stock
comment ? Mais les stock, on peut on
parle d'être humains. Euh euh ils sont
là mais ils sont là. Moi pour vous
donner un exemple, mon père était a eu
une OCUTF parce qu' à l'époque c'était
les Portugais le problème voyez dans les
années 80. Euh oui bien sûr. Bah bien
sûr. Mon père ne prenait pas le métro
euh parce qu'il était euh il était venu
sans papier. Enfin il était venu de de à
l'époque on donnait pas de de visa au
portugais. Non il était passé par le
leagne le Royaume-Uni. Alors ah pas mal.
Il avait fait la planche Royaume-Uni
comme comme tous les immigrés enfin.
Qu'est-ce que vous appelez faire la
planche ? Bah dans dans le dans les
restaurants. Ah la plonge. La plonge
pardon. J'ai dit plaire la plaire. Ça
fait lo et ensuite il a il avait bossé
ici et il est resté sans papier pendant
très longtemps parce qu'il pouvait pas.
Et à un moment donné euh il a eu une
OCUTF, il s'est fait avoir et il a
trouvé quelqu'un qui euh comme il
commençait à travailler euh pour
produire des films, euh il trouve
quelqu'un qui met en contact avec
quelqu'un qui met contact avec le préfet
de Paris. Euh il lui dit "Tu peux
l'appeler ?" Et le préfet Paris dit "Bah
écoutez, vous allez en Belgique et vous
revenez parce que une QTF enfin il faut
il faut arrêter de fixer le débat sur c
enfin c'est un papier qu'on arrache dès
que vous traversez une frontière y
compris la frontière la plus proche.
C'est c'est ni une solution pour régler
les problèmes ni un problème en soi. En
réalité c'est un c'est une sorte de
formalité administrative un peu
insignifiante. Ce qu'il faut éviter
c'est plusieurs choses. Moi, j'étais
quand j'en ai parlé avec Emaus parce que
Emaus, ils ont quand même une grande
partie
d'étrangers, ce qui a obère aussi
d'ailleurs leur capacité d'accueil de
population enfin d'étrangers récents,
enfin de de population qui qui habitent
en France depuis longtemps. Et leur
grand défi c'est de s'assurer que quand
il libère une place, il y ait pas la
filière qui a permis à X ou Y de venir
qui tout de suite en fait envoie
quelqu'un d'autre qui vienne toquer la
porte à l'instant même. Donc il y a il y
a des enjeux fondamentaux par rapport
d'une part aux filières migratoires et
au trafic d'êtres humains qui qui en
découle. Et il y a de l'autre côté
l'organisation de cette précarisation.
C'est beaucoup plus confortable
d'exploiter un
individu quand il a pas de papier. Donc
vous avez pas régularisé quelqu'un alors
que ça vous permet de le traiter en
esclave ou en semi-esclave et de faire
des boulots que plus personne ne veut
faire. Vous voyez ? Donc il y a ce
cynisme là.
Et quand les autorités
politiques font mine de s'indigner parce
qu'il y a encore eu un esclare, un fait
d'hiver lié à quelqu'un un des marginaux
qu'ils avaient pas repéré, c'est évident
que vous pouvez pas les repérer vu que
ils n'existent plus. Enfin, voyez, vous
générez vous-même votre capacité à les
contrôler. Des fois, il y en a qui sont
bien connus des services, ils ont
Ah, mais vous voulez qu'on parle des
Moi, on peut ouvrir le dossier des
fallances de services. On peut on peut
parler de la personne qui était
poignardée qui a poignardé quelqu'un
cadéro. Donc Tac qui était surveillé qui
était au plus haut des listes de la DGSI
au point où la veille quelqu'un l'avait
rencontrer euh pour une histoire elle
avait besoin de récupérer 100 € pour une
histoire vraiment donc elle le rencontre
pas loin de de là-bas et elle rentre
dans le métro et elle se fait arrêter
tout de suite tout de suite. Et cette
même personne est capable de poignarder
quelqu'un le
lendemain. Cette personne qui dont
chaque fréquentation était immédiatement
contrôlée. pouvoir arrêter. Donc à un
moment donné euh quand on a un problème
structurel plus seulement de flux
migratoire et ainsi de suite mais juste
de compétences et de capacité à à
maintenir l'ordre sur notre territoire,
oui, il faut il faut une rupture
radicale. Mais ça fait partie aussi de
de ce qu'on propose. On fait quoi avec
les narcos
? On fait quoi avec les narcos ? Et on
fait quoi avec les États ? On a fait
voilà. Merci. Merci parce que
euh je vais vous répondre sur la
première question. La deuxième pardon
mais quel est le plus puissant état
narcoétat aujourd'hui ? le Maroc et
c'est là où on va faire une visite
d'État à qui on fait le cadeau de la
reconnaissance du Sara occidental à qui
on amène bon un peu tous les toutes les
épaves de la France lors de cette visite
d'état mais quand même il il y a cette
cette
c'est gratuit puéril c'est mais gentil
en comparaison au au aux frappes qui
nous donnent qui nous font subir
régulièrement
euh comment ça se fait qu' aucun moment
les épaves dans votre non voilà ça ce
serait gratuit méchant et et puril euh
alors que là ça c'était de l'ordre de la
du plaisir
rhthorique. Pourquoi est-ce que c'est
pas tirer c'est là le plaisir
rhthorique. Ouais. Pourquoi ? Pourquoi
est-ce que c'est pas un pourquoi c'est
pas un sujet diplomatique, politique
explicité ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait
une fixation sur l'effet
divers concernant ici ou là des des des
vrais drames, vous voyez ? Mais qui qui
en fait font partie d'une de défaillance
d'état et ainsi de suite ? Et on va pas
chercher à la source ces difficultés là.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on va pas chercher la
question de la responsabilité du Maroc
en tant qu'état dans la gangraine de
narcotrafic qui touche notre pays
aujourd'hui ? Ça c'est le premier point.
Il faut il faut mettre le Maroc sous
sanction. Mais non, mais comment on fait
? Comment on fait
? Est-ce qu'on rond les accords de
coopération avec de l'Union européenne
? C'est une vraie question. Est-ce qu'on
est prêt à faire ça ? Est-ce que le roi
du Maroc n'a pas suffisamment de secrets
sur nos dirigeants politiques ? Vous
souvenez cette querelle qu'il y a eu
avec Macron avant le retour de bâton euh
avant cette reconnaissance du SARA
occidental et cette réconciliation et ce
on avait des relations
extraordinairement tendues avec le Maroc
assez similaire à la tension qu'on a
connue avec l'Algérie aujourd'hui.
C'était lié à quoi ? Des écoutes, des
instrumentalisations mutuelles notamment
sur l'intimité de chacun de nos
dirigeants. On va pas en dire plus mais
ceux qui savent comprendront. J'ai pas
envie de faire sauter votre chaîne mais
ou de vous faire retrouver avec des on
sait parfaitement. Donc c'est vous avez
je vais le dire, vous avez des preuves,
pas de preuves, c'est gratuit, c'est pas
gratuit. Vous voulez que je dise ? Non.
Non.
Bon euh donc on se retrouve dans cette
situation où ça aussi c'est d'où
l'importance de la question de la de la
compromission de nos dirigeants et c'est
là où en fait la question de l'intimité
devient un sujet politique. Vous voyez
euh s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas de faille
au sein de ceux qui nous dirigent ça ça
répond à la question qui m'a été posée
et fondamental. Moi quand il tente de me
faire un compromate là c'est un point de
bascule. Soit j'ai en effet des failles,
c'est-à-dire j'ai des addictions des
comportements sexuels, des humains de
suite et c'est fini et du coup je
sacrifie tout ce qu'on a commencé à
construire. Soit c'est pas le cas et en
fait ils auront beau appuyer comme des
sagouins en remettre trois couches,
ajouter d'autres affaires, je sais pas
quoi. Non, ça prendra pas. Ça prendra
pas parce que moi je sais que je enfin
qu'il y a une forme de vérité qu'ils ne
pourront pas amener jusque jusque là où
ils le souhaitent. Et or, c'est pas le
cas de tous nos dirigeants et c'est pas
une c'est pas un jugement personnel,
c'est un vrai c'est une question, ça
devient une question d'état. Question
interne. Et donc sur narcotrafic juste
pour finir parce que je vais pas donner
l'impression qu'on est en train
d'esquiver, c'est sur tous les sujets
clivants comme celui-là, on va proposer
des référendum. Mais alors là, on va
proposer deux options fondamentales.
Une, c'est est-ce qu'on fait une réforme
à la portugaise, c'est-à-dire de
dépénélalisation d'un certain nombre de
stupéfiants avec accompagnement
sanitaire très important et du coup
concentration de tous les moyens de
police qui étaient fait pour contrôler
la population, ainsi de suite sur
justement le démantellement de ces
filières. où est-ce qu'on reste sur une
politique répressive de bannissement
intégral parce que c'est bien mignon euh
la formule à la portugaise mais on a vu
ce que ça a donné en Hollande avec à peu
près des dispositifs similaires. qu'en
Hollande complètement gangrainé au
Pays-Bas par les mafias alors qu'au
Portugal ça a tenu donc il faut qu'on et
parmi les portugais c'est pas les mêmes
non c'est pas que les Portugis c'est pas
les mêmes c'est une question
géographique aussi de flux de contrôle
des flux et en France on est euham
ouais et et la France on a on a on a
beaucoup de frontières on a beaucoup de
frontières et et leur contrôle est pas
si évident ce qui aussi sur la question
migratoire pose question la la la les
politiques adoptées par Mélonie sur la
question migratoire en Italie ne sont
pas forcément réplicables à l'identique
en France on va pas refaire l'erreur du
stagiaire
de Macron sur le CPF, vous voyez, fin
d'importation. Donc il faut il faut il
faut il faut il faut être très subtil,
il faut faire très attention et surtout
il faut éviter notre objectif c'est de
rendre la parole. Donc dès le moment
qu'on recrée de la délibération
collective, c'est que l'intelligence
collective se mette en œuvre et qu'on
réfléchisse tous et qu'on se mette
d'accord sur une direction donnée plutôt
que ce soit un gars un gamin qui
débarque pseudo génie 3è prix au
concours du conservatoire d'Amien. Je
parle de de de Macron ou je sais pas
quoi qu'on invente à chaque fois. qu'on
met en ver pour dire non mais il va
régler tous vos problèmes. Non non, on
prend nos responsabilités, on fait un
choix de société qui va dans ce sens ou
dans tel autre et derrière faut assumer.
Et si Cyilanouna se présente à la
présidence face à vous, bah on va le
faire
bégayer. Vous vous croyez vraiment dans
la possibilité Mais je parle de la Nouna
mais Bardella est quasiment au même
niveau. Au moins au moins Nouna, il a eu
un métier, voyez. Enfin, donc si on un
débat avec l'un d'entre eux, je peux
vous dire que ça va faire très très mal
vite. C'est des gens c'est des gens qui
Pourquoi faire mal ? Et parce que c'est
des gens qui sont potentiellement nocifs
pour la société. Enfin, c'est des gens
qui sont en train de de jouer en fait.
C'est des gens qui considèrent qu'il y a
quelque chose qui s'appelle la société
du spectacle, une sorte de super couche
qui est l'espace médiatique, politique n
na où on peut jouer et les fait sur le
réel, sur les gens qui peuvent plus
soigner, ainsi de suite, c'est des
instruments, vous voyez ça, on va
puiser, on revient, on raconte une
histoire. Non non non, il y a un moment
donné le politique c'est du concret,
c'est des corps qui sont affectés, c'est
des vies entières qui peuvent être
brisées. Et Cyril qui pense que c'est
comme ces émissions de télévision, il
faut qu'il comprennent que on est sur du
sérieux. On parle quand même
d'une, vous savez avant de me retrou
prendre une une intimidation un peu un
peu stupide policière il y a il y a il y
a quelques mois, on venait de lancer
cette idée de candidature qui a quand
même fait sauf erreur de ma part 6
millions de vues sur Twitter et
compagnie. toute l'écurant d' 20 enfin
je veux dire c'est de quoi de quoi quand
même ébranler un peu j' du monde qui
vient me voir pour faire mon portrait et
cetera enfin les choses commençaient et
là je me dis c'est quand même
étrangement facile pour la 8e puissance
économique mondiale puissance nucléaire
à la fois civile et nucléaire ainsi de
suite. On est 8e aujourd'hui. Euh de
c'est assez facile, c'est trop facile
c'est c'est étrangement facile de de se
lancer dans une disposition qui dans 2
ans va nous amener à voir entre nos
mains ses manettes. Enfin vous voyez qui
sont même pas des des destins de
millions de personnes. tout ce que ça 3
semaines plus tard convocation en garde
à vue pour une bêtise enfin évidemment
juste une tentative de déstabilisation
supplémentaire. Question internet,
n'est-ce pas une forme de terreur que
vous proposez ? Comment intégrez-vous
les pauvres et les inadaptés sociaux
dans votre régime tranchant comme une
guillotine pour l'interrogation ? Moi,
je pense qu'il faut il faut réintégrer
du contrôle citoyen partout. Un des
grands scandales de notre temps, c'est
euh l'aide sociale à l'enfance.
C'est euh euh une institution d'État qui
est devenue le principal pourvoyeur de
pédoproxénitisme. Ça c'est une vraie
difficulté, vous voyez. Enfin, on est
quand même dans une situation complète,
on investit des dizaines et centaines de
millions d'euros dans une institution
qui est censée protéger les plus
vulnérables de la société, ceux qui sont
pupil de la nation, ceux qui ont ont dû
être séparés de leur famille parce qu'il
y avait des violences sexuelles ou tout
court. Et aujourd'hui, les pires
prédateurs de ce pays, ils se mettent
euh en bas des centres d'accueil. Ils
attendent que la première gamine sorte
et ils les embarquent dans leur réseau
évidemment en profitant de leur
vulnérabilité et après évidemment avec
des complicités intérieures ainsi de
suite. Ça c'est des réformes. Si vous
dites on va réformer ça avec travers
l'état, vous oubliez que c mêmes
scandales à l'époque de la DAS. Vous
voyez qu'en fait c'est ça fait 40 50 60
ans. Pourquoi ? Parce que
structurellement il y a de la
vulnérabilité. Donc la solution c'est
quoi ? c'est de créer des commissions
citoyennes qui surveillent des gens qui
soient désintéressés sur le même modèle
que les juris populaires, voyez que qu'
avaient dans les juris aux assises et
ainsi de suite. Donc il faut qu'on
recrée des institutions de contrôle. Il
faut qu'on refasse société en fait. Il
faut plus qu'on arrête encore une fois
l'une des idées far il faut arrêter de
penser que l'État a solution à tout. Ce
pays a trop de prélèvements obligatoires
a trop de dispositifs divers et variés
qui pensent avoir solutions à tout. Il
faut relâcher la pression sur la
société. Vous grattez trop votre micro.
Mes excuses ingénieur de
euh je chope une question à la
volée. Monsieur Branco, que
proposez-vous pour la recherche
universitaire ainsi que du discours de
Macron d'accueillir des chercheurs du
monde entier et de faire de la France un
pôle de la recherche ? B on en a parlé
mais doublement du du budget du CNRS et
là vous me dites ouais bon il promet
comme tout le monde. Non mais vous le
financez avec la fin du du crédit impô
recherche. Donc il y a 8 milliards qui
part tout de suite dans l'institution
publique au lieu d'être distribué
aujourd'hui aux grandes entreprises qui
s'en servent en fait comme une niche
fiscale. 8 milliards d'euros ça vous
permet de doubler le budget, ça vous
permet de recruter beaucoup plus de
chercheurs et de les payer beaucoup
mieux.
Question internet. Quelle est votre
stratégie média afin de vous faire
entendre du français moyen ? Moi
l'objectif là c'est d'ici la fin de
l'année, il faut qu'on consolide en
fait. Il faut qu'on aille au plus près
des territoires, faut continuer
déplacement qu'on là, on va aller à
Montpellier à 7, on va on va continuer à
aller euh on va s'infiltrer au sein de
la société, on va essayer d'y chercher
les forces vives. C'est pas par le la
solution top down, elle a fonctionné une
fois avec Emmanuel Macron, elle
fonctionnera pas une deuxième fois. Et
d'ailleurs, on l'a vu avec le crash de
Gabriel Atal, c'est qu'il y a eu une des
plus importantes campagnes médiatiques
qui soit du Moi j'ai halluciné, je
voyais ma prof de lycée d'histoire
interviewé par BFM TV en boucle pour lui
tresser les louanges. Enfin même Macron
n'avait pas eu droit à ça. Et 6 mois
plus tard, première élection àquelle il
est confronté et ben il se fracasse. Ça
c'est fini. les gens n'y croient plus et
ils peuvent bombarder. Ça marche un
temps notamment pour se faire connaître
et ainsi de suite. Mais en réalité, on a
développé et heureusement une résistance
à ce genre de de mécanique de
propagande. Et donc il faut qu'on il
faut qu'on travaille au corps cette
société. C'est aussi simple que ça. Il
faut qu'on y aille. Il faut que des gens
commencent à émerger comme des relais au
sein du territoire pour en parler et peu
à peu propager ces idées. C'est pour ça
que vous partez 2 ans en avance. Mais
bien sûr, bien sûr. En fait, c'est une
question de respect aussi. C'est une
question de se dire enfin on est on est
face à quelque chose où il faut qu'on
travaille au corps ce pays. Et
d'ailleurs ça va là c'est une nouvelle
version. euh du programme, c'est déjà la
deuxième disponible où la première donc
sur mon compte Twitter, vous allez, on
vient de poster le lien et et en fait on
va en faire une trè et une 4è et on va
de façon à être à chaque fois plus
précis pour qu'on arrive à la chance
avec vraiment le programme incontestable
quelque part, vous voyez qui fasse que
vous on peut avoir des différences
idéologiques mais tout ce qui est
justement
idéologisé, il faut qu'il soit soumis au
vote, pas décidé par moi, par et après
tout le reste par contre toute la partie
technique sur laquelle on peut se mettre
à peu près d'accord, bah on la met
branle question internet. Tu casses, tu
répares, tu salis, tu nettoies, tu
défies l'autorité, on t'apprend à la
respecter. Ça vous inspire quoi ? Pas
que c'est très joli de faire des
déclarations comme ça, mais déjà il
faudrait se les appliquer à soi-même et
euh j'ai pas envie de faire sauter votre
votre chaîne. Quelles sont les causes du
désintérêt des Français pour les partis
politiques et les syndicats ? Est-ce que
Est-ce qu'ils sont jaunes, vendus ?
Bah, je pense que l'absence de résultat,
la décadence de ce pays depuis 40 ans,
euh la destruction du système médiatique
par les oligarques qui font que du coup
les gens sincères se font écraser
rapidement et ne restent aux manettes de
ces institutions que ceux qui sont
traîtres ou vérolés. euh le fait que à
l'acte 3, la CGT et abandonné les gilets
jaunes en décidant de ne
pas respecter la convocation de grève
pour les transporteurs routiers qui
auraient pu changer l'histoire de ce
pays. Voilà. Et pourquoi est-ce qu'on
fait ça ? Bah c'est parce qu'il y a de
l'argent à la clé obtenu par les
élections syndicales, les subventions et
ça c'est votre interprétation ?
Oui. Oui, c'est mon interprétation.
Question internet.
Bon, on en a déjà parlé mais on va la
poser quand même pour faire plaisir à
Remi. Bonjour Ro
Branco. Attends. Bonjour. Ran Branco a
dit soutenir le principe des
parrainages. Pense-il vraiment pouvoir
obtenir ce nécessaire à sa candidature ?
Peut-il développer ce qui le rend
confiant le cas échéant ? Écoutez, si à
Solino Cheminade, la salle l'ont obtenu
et qu'on l'obtient pas, encore une fois,
c'est qu'il y a quelque chose dans notre
façon de faire qui qui ne va pas. C'est
aussi simple que ça. Moi, je vais pas me
défausser euh en en en considérant
d'avance que le jeu est truqué et ainsi
de suite. Si ça marche pas, tant pis, on
a raté quelque chose et on aura apporté
autre chose. Parce que il faut tout ce
qu'on fait là et de façon structurelle,
c'est dans l'objectif que ça serve quoi
qu'il arrive. Vous voyez, que ce soit ma
candidature, que qu'importe. En fait,
l'objectif, encore une fois, ce que je
disais, c'est de préparer les Français à
une vraie rupture avec ce qui est en
train de se passer. La forme qu'elle
prendra, l'incarnation qu'elle prendra,
elle est très secondaire. Moi, je suis
un instrument parce que j'ai une
notoriété, parce que je peux être invité
par vous, parce que j'ai croisé
suffisamment de réalités pour justement
pouvoir et accompagner l'élaboration
d'un projet. Mais en réalité, il faut un
sursaceau collectif. Enfin, vous voyez
l'imaginaire, c'est c'est peut-être le
l'aspect négatif de l'imaginaire qui a
été développé par de Gaul au moment de
la résistance qui consistait à créer une
sorte de fiction par laquelle un homme a
fini par sauver tout un peuple. Vous
voyez, c'est c'est pas ce qui s'est
passé. Providence, c'est voilà. Mais
c'est pas c'est pas la réalité, c'est
que la providence, elle se construit et
elle est le fruit d'un engagement à la
fois collectif et individuel. Et un
engagement ou un sacrifice, les deux.
L'un peut amener à l'autre. Si on peut
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut pas, c'est
que le sacrifice soit gratuit et qu'il
soit inutile. Sacrifice, c'est toujours
gratuit. Non, mais au sens inutile.
Voyez, il faut pas qu'il y ait cette il
faut la gratuité de l'intention.
Regardez Jésus, il faut le il faut le la
production d'un résultat. C'estàd qu'il
faut que derrière ce que je me faire
flinguer de
façon inepte, ça apportera rien à
personne. Par contre, être prêt à se
faire flinguer parce qu'on croit en ce
qu'on fait, c'est autre chose. Moi, je
reprends toujours ce terme de de martir.
Non, surtout à l'époque où euh où où
j'ai dû partir quand même de ce pays, je
disais "Je suis déjà un homme mort." Et
en fait, à partir de là, tout est réglé.
Vous voyez ? Enfin, vous c'est pas que
tout est réglé, c'est tout est ouvert.
Voilà. Si si votre socle est celui-là,
il n'y a aucune inquiétude pour la
suite. Ce qu'il faut, c'est que chaque
étape que c'est vrai que vous venez vous
devenez réellement dangereux. Mais
pourquoi vous pensez qu'il y autant
d'effort qui est fait pour euh pour nous
écraser ? C'est lequel ? Parce que vous
pensez pas il en fait ils ont créé leur
propre monstre. Mais bien sûr. Et lequel
d'entre eux est capable de tenir ? Moi,
c'est ce que un des l'Élysée m'avait
envoyé un conseiller peu après
l'apparution de crépuscule parce que
crépuscule intervient vraiment alors que
les gilets jaunes sont très vivants et
ce qui les effrayait c'est pas tant le
livre, c'est la combinaison. Voyez,
c'est c'est la possibilité à un moment
donné parce que eux reposant sur leur
monopole médiatique avaient des armes
très puissantes pour fragmenter les
gilets jaunes, les humiliers, les on
arrive avec des gens comme vous qui me
donnant la parole font que ces gens qui
se mobilisaient se disent "Mais en fait
on a raison, on a le droit, on est
légitime à le faire et ça fait
contrepoids à BFM, à C News et ainsi de
suite."
Et donc il m'envoie un un quelqu'un qui
était dans ma promo à à Sciencepo qui
travaillait
là-bas et euh qui commence à tâter le
terrain en gros quoi. Et moi je je lui
ai dit mais j'ai à l'époque c'était pas
c'était pas j'ai pas peur de la
prison. On ira jusqu'au bout. Enfin vous
il faut il faut faut oublier là toute
toute possibilité de connivance ou de
c'est fini tout ça là. Là vous envoyz un
conseiller pour faire quoi ? Pour
prendre un café. Ouais.
C'est gentil fait ou non c'est ça c'est
la porte ouverte si on ferme la porte
vient le reste et le reste est venu et
j'ai n'oubliez pas on a parlé la
dernière fois que j'ai évité la
perpétuité au Sénégal à ça et notamment
parce que des gilets jaunes sont
mobilisés ainsi de suite. Voyez donc il
y a un moment il faut il faut il faut
mesurer à quoi ça se joue en fait c'est
à chaque fois millimétrique et on peut
reposer sur quoi sur les gens sur
l'intelligence sur la connaissance de
l'adversaire et sur une forme de de non
pas de prudence
mais je pense qu'en fait notre plus
grande arme aujourd'hui c'est même si
elle elle va pas durer longtemps parce
qu'ils vont finir par reprendre le
contrôle sur tous ces espaces on voit
sur YouTube et ainsi de suite. C'est de
la sincérité. c'est à un moment donné
les gens reconnaissent des paroles qui
euh qui ont du sens. Vous voyez ça et ça
ça permet de résister là où il y a 20 ou
30 ans, vous disparaissiez. Un article
de presse, une fausse accusation, je
sais pas pourquoi c'était fini. Là, il y
a quand même une sorte d'attente des
gens euh de la vérification par la
confrontation à l'autre et pour
l'instant on y est encore autorisé
beaucoup moins qu'il y a 5 ans déjà,
mais en même temps, on a réussi à
installer quelque chose entre- temps.
Donc, question internet. Monsieur
Brancou est-il favorable à un Dodge à la
française ? considère-t-il qu'un système
basé sur la blockchain permettrait une
plus grande transparence dans les
comptes publics et enfin quelle est sa
position sur le Bitcoin ? Donc
blockchain euh on l' c'est des questions
à laquelles on a répondu dans le
programme. Euh on on veut on veut que
les blockchains soient utilisés euh pour
euh que toutes les dépenses de l'État
soient
soient soient transparentes. C'est en
fait il faut la moindre hein, la plus
petite dépense qu'on y ait accès euh sur
la question du Dodge qui a été
relativement inefficace. De facto, s'il
regarde le programme, il va voir qu'on
est secteur par secteur. En fait, on
prépare le Dodge. Le problème du Dodge
tel qu'il était fait par Elon Musk,
c'est qu'il arrivé sans savoir et sans
s'être préparé. Et donc, il arrive quand
même avec cette génie. Voilà, il arrive
avec cette génie, pense-t-il, euh et il
pense que c'est un problème mathématique
à régler comme si c'était une entreprise
et en fait très rapidement, il se
retrouve face au nous en amont, on va
chercher toutes les synergies, les
fusions, enfin toutes les problématiques
et parce que je connais très bien pour
le coup l'état de l'intérieur, ce qui
était pas forcément le cas d'Elon Mosque
en ce qui concerne état
fédéral, on est en train d'essayer et
c'est un travail qui est en cours qui va
devoir va falloir affiner en train
d'essayer de trouver tous les gisements
qui permettent de on a un vrai au vrai
objectif hein de réduction des
prélèvements obligatoires en France ça
c'est une vraie différence qu'on a par
rapport à la gauche. Enfin vraiment, il
faut qu'on abaisse cette pression
aujourd'hui sur la création de richesse
et de façon structurelle. Pour répartir
différemment, les taux d'impôt, tout ce
qu'on veut. Mais et la bureaucratie, la
bureaucratie c'est l'entithesse de la
vie, vous voyez, c'est la mort. La
bureaucratie, c'est transformer un geste
en un papier et en et en et en un écrit.
Et ça, c'est pas possible. Le Bitcoin,
le Bitcoin, moi j'ai pas de Moi, ce qui
m'intéresse, c'est la blockchain. Enfin,
le Bitcoin, c'est une c'est une J'ai vu
un graphique récemment intéressant qui
montre que la la M2, c'est la masse
monétaire. Bon bref, enfin c'est ces
questions, ces critères techniques en en
économie correspondent exactement à la
variation du cours du Bitcoin, c'est
qu'en gros selon l'inflation ou la
déflation de la masse monétaire
existante, le Bitcoin va suivre de façon
quasi immédiate les cours. Euh ce qui
nous intéresse, c'est d'avoir peut-être
avec
les soit le Bitcoin et ses dérivés,
c'est-à-dire son séquençage de façon à
pouvoir l'utiliser comme une monnaie de
euh virtuelle, mais avec toujours cette
difficulté, c'est qu'en fait du coup le
les avantages du Bitcoin se perdent.
C'estàd queaufin de la sécurisation
absolue que vous aviez avec le Bitcoin,
dès que vous la dès que vous le le
subdivisez comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui pour faire des dépenses du
quotidien, enfin pour l'utiliser en
remplacement des cartes bleues, ainsi de
suite, vous êtes obligé d'en passer par
une plateforme intermédiaire. C'est que
c'est plus le c'est plus le c'est plus
la blockchain telle qu'elle Mais si
parce que la blockchain vous êtes obligé
de enfin le processus de vérification
n'est plus immédiat. Question internet,
je veux bien être fa checké parce que je
vois des un visage qui se se tort. Non
non, c'est c'est la
Vogienne.
Bonsoir. Il y avait un autre avocat
prérévolutionnaire plein de bonnes idées
qui s'appelait Robespierre.
Je n'ai pas lu son livre comment
fabriquer une guillotine, mais que pense
monsieur Branco de ce personnage
historique
? Et moi, je vais rajouter, je vais la
compléter. Et vous pensez quoi de Mara ?
Moi, je suis pas dans la mythologie
révolutionnaire parce qu'en gros, c'est
une prise du pouvoir par la par la
bourgeoisie contre une autre élite qui
était l'aristocratie et dans une
certaine mesure le haut du clerger.
Alors pour ceux qui nous écoutent en
podcast parce qu'il y en a énormément
euh c'était quoi le titre de livre que
vous avez montré à l'écran ? C'est celui
dont on vient de parler qui s'appelle
Comment fabriquer une guillotine et avec
cette 4è de
couverture, faut-il croire en la
violence ? La question est mal posée.
Rappelons ce que disait jeunet. Il n'y a
plus violent que la rose qui naî.
C'est beau. C'est
un c'est un renversement. Et donc là par
exemple, on avait ce qu'on va mettre
dans le programme, c'est non non non une
nouvelle géographie. Ah non, c'est ça
tout de suite. C'est la géographie des
pouvoirs. Non non, c'est pas le manuel
IKEA pour ça s'appelle Ouais ouais, j'ai
vu les cartes militaires qui
ressemblaient à ça. Allez, on ferme le
bouquin. Il sait combien ça coûte ? On
s'en fiche parce qu'il est aussi en
libre accès, mais il coûte 19 € mais il
sont un peu
cher. Mais voilà. Euh pourquoi est-ce
qu'on en parlait ? Oui, parce que sur
Robespierre Mara et la mythologie
révolutionnaire, moi je pense qu'il faut
en gros mettre en place des mécanismes
de démocratie directe. Notre objectif
encore une fois c'est qu'on puisse
décider à cour d'élèv on a des
mécanismes technologiques pour le faire.
Je sais qu'il y a une phobie par rapport
au fait de renoncer au votes en ligne et
ainsi de suite, mais il y a un moment
donné enfin renoncer pardon au vote sur
euh enfin dans les préot et les urnes.
La réalité c'est justement qu'avec des
mécanismes comme la blockchain et ainsi
de suite, on pourra rapidement recréer
des systèmes de confiance qui soient
vérifiables pas au sein de l'État mais
par tout un citoyen, tout un chacun.
Question internet. Bonsoir monsieur
Branco. Comment allez-vous sortir de
l'euro sans attirer les foudres des
autres pays ? Faut-il sortir aussi du
système monétaire ? Quel euro ? Merci et
force aux abeilles. Merci. Mais
qui vous pensez vraiment que si la
France sort de l'euro, elle sortira
seule ? Non, c'est la question, c'est
qui sortira le premier ? Bah voilà, donc
on va être accompagné. On va être
accompagné et
et évidemment ça sera la fin de l'euro
si la France sort de l'euro. Donc à
partir de là, il y aura une
reconfiguration générale euh
de de l'équilibre monétaire. Et donc la
question qui se pose, c'est est-ce que
il y a deux questions, on prépare la
sortie de l'euro si c'est le choix des
Français et une fois qu'on sort de
l'euro, est-ce qu'on recrée et c'est ce
qui va arriver des alliances notamment
avec les pays du sud qui sont
aujourd'hui de loin les plus sains
économiquement parlant.
Euh c'est ceux-là même qui étaient les
les plus méprisés par Il va falloir que
je vous je vous relâche monsieur Branco.
Maître Branco. Alors deux dernières
questions qu'on va essayer de répondre
plus rapidement parce que ça fait 2h57
que nous sommes en direct. On voit pas
le temps passer. Vous az tenu c'est
comment vous avez tenu c'est bien
supportez mal au goré. Là là, on est à
20 % de nos capacités très
cher. Si par hasard si par hasard ça
passe pas le cap du premier tour,
consigne de vote,
faire sauter la
banque. On pas sur une dynamique
révolutionnaire insurrectionnelle. Vous
pensez que je vais faire confiance à un
seul des dirigeants politiques
actuellement. Vous connaissez notre
point de vue sur la violence
la violence la force des faibles et
comment s'arrête les connaissances.
Vous connaissez le mien ? Oui. Mais
soyez accordons-nous sur ce désaccord.
Accordons-nous sur le fait que il n'y a
pas plus violent que le monde actuel
pour une grande partie de la société que
quand je vous parle du taux de suicide
des jeunes femmes et du taux
d'hospitalisation pour tenter de suite
des jeunes femmes, c'est une violence
extraordinaire. Vous connaissez
Christian Murti ? Non. Extraordinaire.
Et que il faut résoudre ça parce que
c'est une question de survie sociétale.
Donc moi je moi je crois pas à la
violence contre les corps par exemple.
Je pense que c'est un un impératif
absolu que de ne pas toucher au corps.
Par contre, je crois fondamentalement au
fait que le système électif qu'il existe
aujourd'hui est fondamentalement
corrompu. Que le système de
concentration de l'attention Pourquoi
est-ce que je crée aussi cette
initiative ? C'est parce que c'est la
meilleure façon de se regrouper. Quand
j'écrivais des livres soit de
dénonciation, soit de proposition
insurrectionnelle ou révolutionnaire,
euh ce que j'ai remarqué c'est que ça
diffractait. Les gens s'isolaient avec.
Or, on est dans un système où pour
condenser les attentions et pour faire
que les gens se voient, se rencontrent,
échangent, bien une initiative comme
celle d'une élection présidentielle
permet cela. Et donc en fait, c'est
c'est cette idée, c'est en marchant déjà
générer de la beauté sans attendre le
résultat nécessairement qui arrivera par
ailleurs. Mais derrière question,
beaucoup de ce que vous dites se
retrouvent dans l'ouvrage sans la
liberté de François Surau. Avez-vous
envisagé de vous en rapprocher ? Ah, le
grand ami de Xavier Niel, de Bernard
Casneuve et et d'Alain Min. Non, ça
Comment vous savez qu'ils sont amis ?
parce qu'il les a invité notamment
notamment à son fameux discours de
réception à l'Académie française à
laquelle il avait dit que jamais il ne
postulerait àqu n'irait jamais. J'étais
très déçu, très très déçu par cet homme
dont il m'est apparu que l'infatuation
du discours était liée à une
position sociale où tout cela n'était
que virtualité. Or euh c'est par
ailleurs un homme qui a des grandes
qualités intellectuelles mais qui qui
est qui est dans la vase en fait qui est
dans la vase et qui n'a jamais voulu en
sortir et qui tient trop j'imagine à ses
matinales sur France Interre, à ses
publications chez Galimar et ainsi de
suite. Non mais c'est gratuit ça. Non
c'est pas gratuit ce qui c'est pas
gratuit quand vous voyez un homme qui a
des discours d'apparence aussi. C'est la
séduction par le discours. C'est quelque
chose d'impardonnable lorsqu'elle est en
conséquence ou qu'elle n qu'elle que les
que les actes n'en respectent pas. Je
pensais que c'est des attributions bon
dernière question qui n'est pas une
question. Merci de donner des sources
par rapport à l'AS. Merci.
et les sources c'est elles sont
tangibles. C'estàd que si vous allez
aujourd'hui devant toutes les
juridictions chargées de la répression
ou devant les brigades de répression du
proxencisme ainsi de suite, ils vous
diront d'où viennent les victimes et
quels sont les réseaux qui se
nourrissent à travers ell. Vous avez une
conférence dans pas longtemps mais il y
a encore beaucoup de questions à poser.
Que faire des ultra riches et des
inégalités de richesse ?
Il faut il y a il y a plusieurs il y a
plusieurs questions. Je pense qu'il faut
créer comment s'appelle et s'appellera
son mouvement. Donc ça c'est les
aurores. On a créé des ruches sur
l'ensemble du territoire sur les les
personnes les plus favorisé de la
société. Il y a il y a deux éléments. Il
y a d'abord ceux qui profitent de leur
puissance économique pour s'accaparer un
pouvoir judiciaire ou politique. Donc ça
c'est les Xavier, les compagnies, c'est
ce qu'on appelle les oligarques. Eux il
faut qu'on crée un délit qui consiste en
gros à réprimer la corruption de
l'espace public. D'accord. C'est que si
vous utilisez votre argent pour
intervenir sur le contenu et les idées,
vous devez être réprimé parce que les
idées c'est si on veut une vraie une
vraie une puissance étrangère qui fait
ça. Si une puissance étrangère n'est
jamais par exemple les anglais une
puissance étrangère frappé dans
l'étendard de la vertu. Une puissance
étrangère n'est jamais soumise au droit
pénal russe. Oui. Elle elle n'est jamais
soumise au droits pénal d'une puissance
étrangère. Elle est soumise à des moyens
de répression diplomatique euh de guerre
informationnelle. Non, moi c'est ce que
je vais vous donner un exemple pour
répondre à cette à cette question. C'est
quoi un LRAC ?
Un raccé une lettre condéve accusé. Non
non, c'est un lance-requette antichard.
Oui, d'accord. On était pas sur la même
chose. Je pensais que vous disiez qu'il
fallait envoyer des lettres recommandées
pour menacer les enfin pour convoquer
par par poste les personnes. Ouais, les
ambassadeurs ambassadrices. Euh mais
pourquoi vous parlez de lanceroquette
antichar ? Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les
puissances étrangères qui font
l'ingérance sur les opinions, les idées,
les capacités des consé ? Si si on a
assaigné notre espèce public,
c'està-dire qu'on a un contrôle sur les
algorithmes euh qu'on a des médias qui
sont effectivement citoyens, on n' pas à
craindre des tentatives d'influence
informationnelle. Vous voyez, c'est
quand même là le l'élément fondamental,
c'est qu'aujourd'hui, il prospère sur
notre corruption, il prospère sur les
mensonges. Je poururais on aurait pu en
faire des discours sur l'affaire
Brigitte Macron, Jean-Michel Trieu et
pourquoi est-ce que ça a été facile ou
encore une fois sur les sachets de
cocaïne pour Emmanuel Macron mouchoir et
les les touillettes à café. Mais ce qui
est probablement le cas, mais voyez,
c'est sûrement le cas à 100 %. Et
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'ils sont
vulnérables à ce genre d'attaque ? Bah,
je pense que chacun le sait. Donc à
partir de là, on enfin ce qui concerne
le couple ça tape un peu dans la Non,
mais regardez par exemple sur le couple
Brigitte Emmanuel Macron, enfin on peut
revenir dessus mais est-ce que est-ce
que c'est intéressant pour nous de nous
intéresser aux états-dames de Brigitte
Macron qui cherchent des psidents Paris
parce qu'elle est malheureuse parce que
honnêtement les affaires d'état
comprendre c'est les affaires mais je
n'ai pas moi mon empathie va vers des
gens qui en ont vraiment besoin. Vous
voyez faut avoir de l'empathie pour tout
le monde. Il faut avoir de l'empathie
pour ceux qui question internet. Ne
pensez-vous pas, Ran Branco, que nous
sommes arrivés à un point de non retour
? D'après des calculs prenant en compte
la natalité et immigration de 1945, nous
aurions en France 20 millions
d'étrangers d'origine non européenne au
minimum. La France perd donc son
identité. Juste malade ou sur un lit de
mort. Il n'y a plus en plus Il n'y a
plus en plus de français en exil sans
intentions aucunes de revenir. Vous êtes
très courageux de notre pardon vous êtes
très courageux de simplement y croire
mes observations autour de moi et que
ces français en exil n'y croient plus du
tout. Mais je sais, c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont partis et et je comprends. C'est
pas c'est pas un jugement. Pas compris
la partie sur l'immigration.
Mais non, mais en fait ça je pense que
c'est une erreur de lecture qui consiste
à à ne pas comprendre que les fondements
spirituels identitaire de notre
civilisation se sont effondrés et ils se
sont pas effondrés du fait de
l'immigration. En fait, la nonégration
de l'immigration vient en grande partie
de notre incapacité à générer un
logiciel qui nous soit propre. Vous
voyez, c'est une sorte d'asservissement
un peu là. Prenez un exemple sur l'euro,
c'est Ouais, j'y vais. Mais juste juste
pour finir parce que c'est juste
vraiment l'euro vous le savez non que
c'est des faux bâtiments qui sont sur
les euros c'estd que même nos monnaies
nos billets on n' pas été capable d'y
mettre une incarnation de quelque chose
de notre civilisation quand on en est à
ce niveau de dépersonnalisation de
désidentitarisation évidemment qu'on est
vulnérable et évidemment que ceux qui
arrivent vont pas se défaire de leur
structure de ce qui leur permet de tenir
de tenir une famille compagnie le plus
souvent dans les positions de précarité
évidemment qu'ils vont s'y accrocher et
évidemment que ça va générer des
dérives. Donc il faut qu'on réfléchisse
aussi un peu de façon plus holistique.
Trois bouquins à conseiller à notre
communauté. Les misérables de Victor
Hugo, un
enfant les enfantanaires de Valzer.
Euh j'avais beaucoup beaucoup aimé pour
rendre hommage quand même même si
j'étais un peu dur à eux avec eux non à
à Mathieu Osano qui dirige le chiffre
project Jean Covici qui avait écrit une
Bible sur l'or noir qui est
passionnante. D'ailleurs, vous devriez
l'inviter, ça vaut la peine sur le
pétrole. Un conseil pour les jeunes
générations. Lutter luttez et ne nous
abandonnez pas. On a besoin de vous.
Branco. Merci. Merci à vous.
[Musique]